Hello, hello, everybody.
Hello, hello.
I'm gonna mute the game music for now because I have some updates for you guys, as always, in the beginning of the stream.
But hello, everyone.
Today, so I'm waiting for the aircon to, like, get into this room, into my sauna right now.
So I'm having trouble breathing because, like, it's really hot in my enclosed area with no windows.
So I'm waiting for it.
I'm waiting for the aircon to hit this room right now because it's really hot right now in this room.
But yes, no, it's not a greenhouse.
There's no windows in this confined area.
So there's no circulation.
And yeah, so that was my biggest issue, putting my office in here.
But anyway, some updates.
Okay, so I'll get the bad news out of the way first.
I was, like, not crying about it, but I was like, wait a minute.
But if you guys didn't know, I'm gonna be in the XQC Invitational tomorrow.
That's gonna be starting at 12 p.m.
Um, it is a draft...
It's not bad news.
I was like, wait a minute.
So I was thinking this tournament pretty chill.
But then, like, um, more details came out as, like, the days went on.
It's a draft pick.
So each captain gets to pick who they want to be on their team.
So it's, like, snake draft.
So if you guys know what the snake draft format is, um, uh, that's basically, like, uh, it's basically each captain picks one, one, one, one, and then it goes up and down, up and down.
And so here are the team captains.
I'll get to the, the, like, really scary news later.
So, like, the team captains are XQC, Shroud, Necros, Super, Tens, and Summit.
So, um, I think I'm the only VTuber in here because there's a lot of big streamers in this invitational.
Um, including Tyler1 is in this tournament, you guys.
Whoa.
I don't know which team I'm gonna get in.
But there's a lot of really big names in this tournament, including Tyler1.
Um, yeah, um, but the Witch Summit, Summit 1G, I'm pretty sure it's, uh, I mean, that's the only summit I know.
Um, but, yeah, so, um, the scary thing about this tournament was that I thought it was just gonna be, like, ex-pros and, like, streamers, but then, um, Shroud's pro team is also in this tournament.
Um, like, you know, all six of them.
So, like, I was like, oh, wait a minute.
I think they're the only pro players in this tournament.
Um, so, like, uh, so, it gets a little scarier because, um, if you guys didn't know, it is a 250k tournament.
So, um, um, and, um, first place is, I believe, first place is, oh my gosh, let me look.
Like, I know the prize distribution was, like, basically, each person gets 20k.
If you win first place.
Uh, uh,
let's see, 125.
Oh, yeah, yeah, each person gets 20k if they win first place.
And the second place was, like, 50k.
So, yeah, it's, like, it's scary because, like, there's actual players participating that have never played Rivals before and are starting, like, this week.
Like, there's an actual chess player.
I was, like, checking everybody else because I was, like, oh, it's interesting.
And I was, like, checking all the people that are in this tournament.
And there's, like, an actual chess streamer in this tournament.
And...
And I was, like, I was, like, oh, man.
I feel bad whenever...
If they have to...
If they are not in the team with any of the ShroudX players, I'd feel bad for them.
So, and then, like, I was talking to one of my friends and they're, like, oh, well, there's six of them.
So, like, one of them will be on your team.
But I was, like, you don't understand.
Like, it doesn't matter because the team that gets the pro DPS player is obviously gonna do better than the team that's gonna get the support pro player.
Like, I was, like, what the fuck is he gonna do?
Like, the support player is gonna do.
Like, I've seen tournaments.
Those support players still die to the pro DPS players.
Even when they're getting protected by their pro team.
You think, like...
So, so, it's, like, there's a pot...
Like, so, yeah, it's, like, I was, like, yeah.
And I don't know if you guys know, but, like, Nekros has been trying to do this thing.
Where, um...
Uh, Nekros is trying to do this thing where he's trying to prove to everybody that support players are, like, complaining too much.
But he's, like, hard-stuck GM right now.
So, he's been...
He's been...
And he's, like...
He's been streaming for, like, like, 10 plus hours today.
Oh, he's still going.
Oh, yeah.
Wait, he's still going.
So, he's been, like, crashing out incredibly hard.
And...
Yeah.
Um...
He's been, like, crashing out really hard right now.
Because he said that he was going to get Celestial today.
And he's sort of been, like, hard-stuck GM, like, for the last...
I believe, like...
Uh...
12 hours.
Sorry.
He's...
I miscalculated.
12 hours right now?
And he was...
It was so funny because I caught his stream.
And he was, like...
Was saying how, like...
How can I lose this much...
This many points when my DPS was doing absolutely nothing?
I don't deserve to lose that many points for the stuff I was doing.
And then all his chat was, like...
Oh, now you understand.
Like...
And the people in his chat were, like...
Wait, are you rage baiting?
Or are you, like, for real right now?
And he was legitimately, like...
Crashing out.
And, like...
Understanding the pain now.
Like...
Yeah.
Um...
So, like...
It's actually...
It was pretty silly.
Uh...
But, like...
Yeah.
So...
I'm a little...
After the stream, I'm gonna be practicing my four rivals.
Because...
Um...
But...
If I somehow get it...
If I...
My RNG is incredibly bad.
And, like...
Um...
If my RNG is incredibly bad with, like...
Uh...
I know that, like...
We might not...
We might struggle.
I'm gonna take the tournament as...
For fun.
During that day.
But...
Today, I'm definitely practicing rivals tonight.
I won't be streaming it.
But I will be practicing.
I have not been playing a lot of my...
I will have to admit.
I've not been playing as much as I should be.
Because I didn't realize...
I didn't...
I didn't realize what the competition was like.
But...
Um...
If...
During the day of...
Tomorrow...
Because, like...
We find out which teams...
Um...
Which teams we're gonna be in tomorrow because they're doing the draft pick like live on stream.
Well, not my stream, obviously on their own streams.
But they're doing the draft pick like live on the day.
So like if I realize, okay, like, you know, might not be like, you know, it's not winnable.
I'm not gonna like, you know, be like, and I'll be like, okay, I'll just do it for the vibes.
Just be like, I'll have fun, use it as like a way to get to know people on my team, like get to like networking thing, and then just use it as that.
And then, but like, but if my team is like full on try hard, I gotta make sure that like I pick up the slack for my team.
Because I think I'm like the only VTuber that's invited for this tournament.
And there's a lot of big names in this tournament.
Like Sweet Anita's in it.
If you guys who don't know who Sweet Anita it is, um, she's the, uh, the one with the tick.
Um, I don't remember what it was called again.
Uh, uh, I forgot what the, the thing is called.
Yeah, she's like a really sweet person.
Yeah, but she's in the tournament as well.
There's a lot of like, um, I think, I don't remember the, uh, Tourette's.
Yeah, she's the one with the Tourette's.
Um, and had like, uh, was like really big on that, uh, on Twitch a couple of years ago.
Yeah, yeah, Sweet Anita's in it.
And like I said, the captains are literally XTC, Shroud, Necro, Super, Tens, Summit, 1G.
Um, there's like, uh, like Fortnite people might recognize some of these names.
There's like Thieves, um, there's, uh, Raffle Waffles.
I was like telling my friend, I was like, oh, hey, I don't know who these people are, but there's like some non-rival, like non-rivals players, like non-FPS players in here.
And Mr. Raffle Waffles.
And then my friend was like, oh my god, the Call of Duty Easter egg person?
I was like, I don't know, he has, he, yeah, he's like the COD zombies guy.
Yeah, apparently.
And then, uh, and then there's a chess person too.
Um, I mean, there's the usual Overwatch, yeah, from the zombies walkthrough.
Yeah, he's in it.
He's also in it.
There's a lot of like Fortnite streamers in here too.
Like really big Fortnite streamers.
Um, I have no idea who they are, but I was curious, you know, I was curious.
I wanted to like, I looked at them.
I was like, oh, who are these people?
Um, I forgot which one's the chess person.
I need to look through everything, uh, to find the chess guy.
But like, there was a chess streamer in here too.
Um, but yeah, and then like, and then there's ShroudX's entire roster.
I don't, I don't know how, it's like draft pick, so each person's gonna be on a different team.
But like, who are we kidding ourselves?
I don't know how much the tank and DPS player would definitely have more value.
Because like, um, at least they can kill people.
I'm sorry, as a support player.
I know my value is a lot less than a DPS and tank player and like, we're not fooling anyone.
So, the two teams that might, unfortunately, um, might not be able to get the DPS and tank players, um, will be like, we might struggle a little bit.
Uh, especially because they're active pros.
Like, they're literally doing fight night right now.
Like, they're participating in a pro tournament at the moment.
No, as a fellow support player, I, I can only do so much, you know?
I can, I can only do as much as I can to enable my team and do the damage I can.
Um, but I am very thankful to be invited.
Um, because like I said, it is a, like, a huge, like, it basically, like, it's a lot of, like, anyone who's anybody on Twitch is sort of, like, in this tournament.
Literally, Tyler1 is in this tournament.
I, this would be my, I, I don't know.
I told my friends, I was like, I hope I get on a team with Tyler1.
Like, like, we're gonna lose, but, like, it would be so fucking fun.
Like, I think, I think it'd be really fun to be on a team with Tyler1.
I don't think we'll make it far, but I just think it'd be pretty fun.
I just think.
Yeah, Tyler1, the chess play, exactly.
Um, but we'll see, uh, we'll see how it goes.
Um, we might have a team that we might not know a lot of the people.
We might have the team who's like, I mean, the captains, the, the, all the captains are, like, really well-known streamers as well.
Um, like I said, the captains are XUC, Shrouds, Necros, Super, Tense, and Summit.
So, like, all of them are, like, um, really well, if anything, like, the captains are really well-known, uh, individuals as well in their own right on Twitch.
Um, so it'd be, like, you know, a great opportunity, especially if I'm, like, the only VTuber in here.
Um, and, yeah, I'm super excited tomorrow.
I hope it's not awkward.
Oh, God, I hope so, too.
I hope, I hope if we lose that it won't be too awkward.
I...
Oh, yeah.
Um, but, yeah, anyway, so that's, I got the, the little bit of, like, oh, shit, I gotta practice tonight.
Um, cause, I mean, I'm Celestia 3 right now, which is, like, not bad.
I also haven't played a lot to be Celestia 3.
So, I feel like if I was playing consistently, I would obviously be a lot higher rank, But I haven't really played that much this season.
Because Dive Meta... Captain America Meta fucking sucks.
I'll say it.
I really do not enjoy Captain America Meta.
Like... I was fine when it was just regular Dive.
When it's Venom Spider.
But the Captain America is so fucking oppressive.
The Captain America Meta is incredibly oppressive.
It's more oppressive than Spider-Man and...
Venom.
I hate it much more.
He just does... At least Venom can die.
A good Captain America cannot fucking die.
So... Oh, hey.
Necros lost another support game.
Wow.
I'm not hate-watching, guys.
I'm just, like, trying to see if he wins this.
I was curious.
I... I just thought it was... I thought he was really funny when he, like...
Finally understood.
Like... Oh, wait.
Wait.
They might win.
Their Luna just got... Sorry.
Their Luna just got two kills.
Oh, my God.
Never mind.
Congratulations.
You've done it.
You won.
You won a game on support.
I'm so proud of you, Necros.
All right.
Sorry.
Back to where I was talking about.
Um... Their Luna actually clutched it for them.
Wow.
Oh, my God.
Their Luna saved their entire team.
Um... The other support game.
All right.
Sorry.
Where was I?
Uh... Where was I, guys?
Um... Oh... Oh, wait.
Never mind.
They're dead.
They lost.
Sorry, guys.
Uh... They... Their other... Their... Their other support ended up getting, like... Uh... They lost, by the way.
It was too late.
Oh, yeah.
So, yeah.
Captain America meta is so oppressive.
And I realized that recently.
Because I was practicing.
Um... The last couple of days.
Um...
Because when I found out that ShroudX was in the tournament.
Or, like... There were, like... Okay.
At first, I found out, like... There were a lot of, like... Overwatch players.
Overwatch pros.
That were in the tournament.
So, I was like... Okay.
This is getting a little more serious.
Because, like... Obviously, Overwatch players... Can easily transfer their skills... To... Marvel rivals.
So, I was like... Okay.
This is getting a little serious.
So, I should practice more.
And then I found out ShroudX's team is going to be in here.
So I was like, oh, fuck.
Okay, maybe I actually should know what's going on.
Maybe I should remember how to play the game.
It's pretty miserable as a support, though, in that meta.
Because I was playing Loki and Sue and Luna.
By the way, Rocket's apparently garbage now.
Thank God.
I definitely have never touched Rocket during that season.
Like, you have no proof on stream.
But yeah, I'm glad that Rocket is garbage again, which is great.
And yeah, so I guess that is all the Marvel Rivals stuff out of the way.
For those who are like, or like, oh, let me know when she's done talking about Marvel Rivals.
Don't worry.
That's out of the way.
Now it's time for the other life updates.
Now it's time for the other stuff I want to talk about.
Oh, yeah.
So while I was... Sorry.
JK, we're going back to Marvel Rivals.
I'm sorry.
You can tab out right now.
If that's not what you want to hear about.
Don't... Sorry.
Just one more thing.
So I wanted to try and get some of the skins.
Because I realized, like, oh, hey.
So there's, like, I really wanted to get the Manta skin.
And I noticed that you can do some of it in practice versus AI.
Because I just can't be bothered to, like, try.
So I tried practice versus AI on easy.
And, like... Because I assume that everyone that does this is just farming for the skins, right?
Like, they're not actually... They don't play it because they enjoy playing practice versus AI.
Like, they don't play... But... The thing is...
During one of my games, I had two players that were actually, like, calming.
And, like, was like, oh, my God.
Good job, guys.
We did it.
And I was like, there's no way this person is serious.
I was like, there's... There's no way.
Like, are you actually, like... Like...
Trying?
And then... Okay, this is really toxic.
But, like... It, like, blew my mind.
Because I was like, are you okay?
Like, we're... We're... By the way, we're... We're in easy.
I was in... I was in easy lobbies.
Like, the easiest bots.
Because I just needed to get this over with.
I have the PPE choice.
So, I... Okay, this is incredibly toxic.
I don't.
But I was curious.
I wanted to know what it was like on the other side.
Of... Of the... You know, on the other side.
And then, so...
I looked... I looked their profiles up.
Because, you know, they didn't...
I don't think they realized they can lock their profiles.
Like, at that point.
Because they're, like, casual players.
So, I don't think that has ever crossed their mind.
To be like, I should private my profile.
So, I looked at their profiles.
And their profile was...
Majority was practice versus AI.
So, I was like...
Okay, this is a practice versus AI enjoy.
And then I saw losses...
In practice versus AI.
And that's when I was like...
How?
I was like...
There is no...
That blew my mind.
Because I was single-handedly...
Spawn capping the AI bots.
Like, non-stop.
As a DPS.
And so, I was like...
How do you lose?
How do you...
How did six people single-handedly lose to bots?
Like, one person can just spawn camp an entire army of bots.
Like, entire army of bots.
You have to actively try to lose to bots.
So, that, like, blew my mind.
And then, like...
But then I looked at their rankings.
Because I was like...
Okay, let's see if this person plays rank.
And then I saw their rank.
And they played 300 games.
And they were hard-stuck.
Bronze 3.
And I was like...
I...
Like...
I don't know what to say.
I don't...
I...
I was like...
I guess that's how you lose in practice versus AI.
I...
Yo, that's basically me.
Toke, come to France.
We're cool.
I just...
I don't know.
I've never, like...
Met someone like that.
Because it, like...
It just...
It just, like...
Blew my mind in general.
Because I was like, oh my god.
That's like the other side.
They're real.
Oh my god.
They have a life outside of gaming.
I want to know what that's like.
I'm sorry.
But like, for me, it's why I never play Valorant.
Because I know if I play Valorant, I'd be that person.
And it's why... because I... they're just so much stronger than me.
Because I was like, if I play 300 games and I'm heart-stuck bronze, I think at that point, I don't... this is not for me.
Like... I feel like... I feel like... this is... I got time to uninstall.
I need to choose a different passion in life.
They got... their mental... their mental game.
is so much stronger... than whatever I go through... daily.
Like... I would be done.
If I had... five losses... in a row, I'd crash out.
This person has three.
But like... I have five losses... in top 500 ELO games.
This guy... has so many losses... to beat.
That's the thing.
It's so hard to like... not rank up from bronze.
Because like... you're always gaining.
That's what blows my mind.
Because it's like... you don't lose a lot... in bronze.
But you gain so much.
So it's like... absolutely... I can't comprehend it.
Because it's like... how much do you have to lose... to like... debuff... the win points... you get.
Because when I... when I went from bronze... I get... plus 80 points.
So it's like... how much do you have to lose... to be stuck in bronze three?
I... I... I... and like... I was so... I... I don't understand.
10!
I... I... I... I... I...
Because you don't... you lose like... 10!
You lose 10!
In bronze!
Or like... I don't know.
I never lost in bronze.
So I'm just guessing.
And it's not like they started this season.
They've been playing for three seasons.
And they've been... I don't know.
I hope he's... He's so strong.
I hope he has a great... I bet his life is so happy and fulfilling.
And I honestly... If he is able to keep playing rivals after that, he must have an incredibly fulfilling life.
And I honestly... I wish I was him.
Like, I would crash out after five.
But he's like... He's enjoying life.
Like, he's like some pure, innocent soul that doesn't care.
He's out there grinding practice versus AI right now.
Enjoying his time.
Cheering his team on against little AI that you can spawn camp.
His happiness is not dependent on a video game score.
And like, I hope he's living the best life that he's living right now.
He has like... He gets actual joy from just being alive.
I... I...
I...
So... No, I... I... It was just... It was just crazy to like...
Um...
He's too strong.
He's like... He's like watching... He's like hanging out with his family right now.
He has a wife and two kids.
And like... After work, he plays a couple of games...
On my arrivals.
Before he goes to bed with his loving wife.
And just like, you know...
He's... He has a good 401k.
He has a good job that pays for the tuitions.
For like...
His children.
To college and everything.
Like... He's...
He's getting some tonight.
Uh...
That sounds like the dream.
I hate him.
That...
Like... That's the only way I can justify...
A person that can like... Like go on with their life and still come back to Marvel Rivals.
And still like... Come back to Marvel Rivals.
For their like...
301 game in rank.
And still be in Bronze 3.
That's the only way I can justify it in my mind.
That... Where he's still doing it.
Like...
Anyway...
Sorry...
The Marvel Rivals stuff... Uh... Tangent is gone now.
Alright, I'm ready.
I'm ready.
I'm ready to talk about something else.
Alright, so...
Um... Other than that...
I wanna talk about...
The...
The 3D...
Debut...
Bait and Switch video I uploaded.
Where I actually lost subscribers.
Because people were like...
I can't believe you did this.
But it's like...
That video...
Was...
Like...
Released...
A couple of months ago.
And...
Um...
And like...
So some people were like...
Mad...
That I...
Uploaded...
Okay, so...
The reason why...
Um...
I...
Uploaded...
Was because...
Um...
I actually got the video...
I had the video...
Polished...
And re-edited...
And added like...
You know...
More stuff to it.
Like music...
Sound effects...
And everything.
So...
That was the reason...
Why...
I uploaded...
On a...
Random Wednesday...
At like...
Right before...
Like you know...
Random Wednesday...
At 5pm...
Or something...
Um...
That was...
Because I was like...
Oh...
I finally got the video...
I guess I should upload it...
And just...
I don't know...
Get ad...
You off of it...
You know?
Like...
Um...
And then...
So people can like...
Watch the video...
On it's own...
Instead of watching the...
You know...
Rewinding it on the stream...
So I figured...
I might as well...
Upload it...
Because you know...
I have the video...
Videos done...
Like...
I'm not gonna wait...
Any longer...
I wasn't gonna wait...
To upload it...
Um...
And it was so...
And then I had to like...
Write an emergency comment...
Because people thought...
I doxxed myself...
And like...
Did a face reveal...
Even though like...
You can tell...
After several...
Like...
I wrote in the description...
Like credited...
The cosplayers...
And everything...
And also like...
You know...
There's different cosplayers...
So people thought...
And now I was like...
Guys...
I have to write in the comments...
And pin it...
And be like...
Guys...
Like...
It was a video I put on...
During the anniversary...!
So...
So, I thought I was... I was not... Okay.
The one thing I wasn't ready for was that I actually lost subscribers and pissed people off.
I remember one of the person that commented on the video was like, I can't believe you did this.
You know this is not funny, right?
Like, I...
They're like, you know this is not funny.
Like, this is gonna make your 3D debut less exciting when you do your real one.
And I was like, what?
Oh my god.
I forgot.
I'm sorry.
Like... Trip, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I was like, whoa!
Whoa!
I'm sorry.
I just wanted to upload this video.
I thought it was pretty funny.
I mean, it is gonna happen eventually.
I just... I just thought it was really funny.
But yeah, anyway.
So, I just wanted to talk about that real quick.
Another thing is that...
Today, I recently... Okay, so... Okay, so this is a really bad habit of mine.
But I don't check my mailbox often.
So, like, I let it build up for, like, several... Like, maybe, like, a week or two before I checked my mailbox.
Because I'm like, who's gonna send me mail?
But then I forgot.
So today, I checked my mailbox.
And I forgot.
Oh, the government sends me mail.
So...
Um, I got really worried.
Because I checked my mailbox.
And then I had, like...
Like, around five to six letters.
From the Canadian government.
And...
And then I was like...
Oh, my God.
Did I commit tax fraud?
Because one of them said the Canadian Revenue Agency.
So...
So, I was like...
Oh, my God.
Oh, my... Am I getting arrested?
I...
Because...
I saw...
There were so many Canadian...
And it said...
I can see...
Okay, I have them right here next to me.
And I got...
I got so scared.
I had to...
You know...
I...
When I went up the elevator.
And it was like...
Important notice inside.
And I was like...
Oh, my God.
Oh, I did not check my mail in a while.
I...
And then...
Because I was like...
Why is there so many letters...
From the Canadian government?
And so...
When I got up...
Obviously, I instantly opened my mail...
To be like...
What the fuck is in it?
And it was a check for money.
Because I did...
Thank God...
I did my taxes correctly.
So...
But the thing is...
I submitted various things...
And it was just...
It was like...
Oh, we're sending you...
This is your tax refund...
That you did for your taxes.
This is your tax refund.
So...
Later, you're gonna receive...
Another...
Letter...
That will have your...
The check for it.
So that's why I had like...
10...
Letters...
In my mailbox...
Mailbox...
Because like...
It was for various other stuff...
Regarding like...
My...
My tax refunds...
So...
Yeah, I got money...
So I got...
So I was like...
Oh, thank God...
I'm not getting arrested...
I was like...
Holy shit...
Because I was like...
Why did they send me...
10 letters...
Like...
I was like...
It wasn't like I haven't...
Um...
Checked my mail...
For a very, very long...
I just got...
10 different letters...
About taxes...
I...
So...
I was like...
Yippee!
Tax refunds!
So I got like...
A couple of checks for...
Tax refunds...
And they were just...
Telling me like...
You're gonna get it later...
I'm like...
Yay!
I didn't fuck up!
I didn't...
I was like...
Whoa!
I don't see...
I got a little scared...
I was like...
Oh my God!
Like...
Am I gonna get arrested?
Are they gonna...
They know where I live?
Um...
Did Joki commit tax fraud?
Uh...
Vox...
Thank you for the super chat...
Thank you...
I hope you're never too sorry...
For making overly serious people...
Rage...
Because it happens to make me personally laugh...
More than enough to make up for it...
Thank you for the super chat...
Thank you...
Yeah, I'm just glad...
I had a lot of people that did think it was really funny...
But also...
I was very surprised with the people that were very...
Very mad about it...
Um...
Anton...
Thank you for the super chat...
Thank you...
Your magic could reach through the screen and snatch your soul...
Why are you like this?
Thank you for the...
Uh...
Super chat...
Thank you...
Anyway...
Sorry...
That was a long...
Yap...
Uh...
Tangent...
Yapping section...
Before we actually played Dynasty Warriors...
Uh...
Today we're going to attempt...
To finish...
The Shu Kingdom...
For Dynasty Warriors Origin...
And after that...
The Wei and Wu storylines...
Will be moved over...
To Twitch...
So my channel...
Will stop dying...
And...
Ha ha ha ha ha...
My manager...
Was very happy about this...
They were like...
Uh...
Today...
They were like...
Thank God...
You're finally...
Moving the stream...
The series...
To Twitch...
Because it's affecting...
Your algorithm...
And...
They're like...
I'm like...
Yeah...
I'm gonna try...
My best...
Ha ha ha ha...
Yay...
Dooky's channel's gonna...
Die a little less...
After today...
But little does he know...
I'm gonna play Epic Mickey...
After...
And I don't think...
That's gonna save my channel...
Ha ha ha ha...
Ha ha ha...
Um...
And...
Please be more...
...considerate of that.
Anyway, so...
But what else was I gonna say?
I will attempt...
...to finish Dynasty Warriors Origins for Shu's storyline today.
Please stop self-sabotaging yourself.
Doki, please play Halo!
It will save your channel!
Doki, play Metal Gear!
Anything!
Stop doing this to yourself!
That's the thing, guys!
I could never get Disney perms in the past!
Now I can play all the Disney games I want!
Anyway...
What else was I gonna talk about?
Oh yeah, sorry, I said I should stop talking about stuff because we gotta play...
Sorry, this is a long, like, yapping section before the games start.
Um...
Anyway, so...
Yeah, I'm looking forward to...
To try and finish Dynasty Warriors today.
It's gonna be a long day.
Um...
But, like, at least at this point, we should be meeting my Oshi forever.
So, like, he's not just gonna show up for, like, five seconds and then fuck off.
And I have to talk to his goddamn wife who's making a...
Um...
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha!
Yeah.
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha!
And then...
Telling me how realistic it is and everything!
So, like...
At least I can finally talk to my husband and my Oshi and, like, things will be less awkward, I think.
Uh...
But, yeah!
Alright, let's...
Let's get play the game!
B-b-b-b Dynasty Warriors Origin!
Oh yeah, I forgot.
It's left Doki time.
Left Doki, where are you?
No, I keep using... I keep pulling up center Doki.
Whoa, and that's a little to the side Doki.
And that is not left.
Okay, that's center Doki again.
And then that's... I just pull up the same Doki.
Okay, there you go.
There's left Doki.
I keep pulling up the wrong Doki's.
All right.
There you go.
Abelion, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey Doki, today's my 38th birthday.
Happy to be able to spend the evening with my Oshi streaming my favorite game series.
Even if it killed your channel.
Yippee!
Don't worry.
We only filtered the weak.
If they can't love me from my Dynasty Warriors Fujoshi moments, then they can't love me during my other algorithm boosting moments.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Abelion.
Woo!
All right.
Let's see.
Where did I go?
Gah!
Oh, yeah.
I forgot.
There was no sound.
I turned that out.
All right.
There we go.
Gah!
Okay.
Am I supposed to talk to anybody?
No.
All right.
Wait.
Actually, I know that I have, like, there were, like, people I was supposed to talk to, but I didn't bother because they were not, like, the people I want to talk to.
Uh, Smokey, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, yeah.
I forgot to mention.
The reason why the Dynasty Warriors time slot changed to 5 p.m.
is that, um, um, I did ask, like, uh, I did ask everybody which one they prefer.
And majority of the Dragon's voted for 5 p.m., and that's why the time slot changed, uh, to be at this time to finish the series.
Yeah.
There was a vote.
We voted.
Just, like, how the Pope was voted in.
I like how, like, an American Pope, like, literally came out of nowhere with a steel chair.
Like, I, I was like, I didn't see these, I didn't see this candidate in my Pope watch.
In my, what was it called?
Pope Crave.
Like, that wasn't in my Pope Crave Twitter following.
Where did he come from?
Um, same, like, RKO out of nowhere.
That's the American spirit, bro.
Oh, yeah, I was following Pope Crave.
It's, like, Pop Crave, but, like, for Popes.
Um, I don't know how to explain it.
There was a Twitter account that just was basically following the, the live, it was, like, live tweet updates on, like, if they selected the Pope yet.
And, and it was pretty, they were, like, if, what was it called?
Like, a fan account of, like, Conclave or what?
Like, an incredibly obsessive account about the movie Conclave.
And then, like, yeah, then they decided, yeah, it was, like, Pope Watch.
I put all my money in Spanish, Pope.
Oh, it's you.
Give this a try, will ya?
Okay, what's this?
Launch a successful ambush charge.
Defeat using gauntlets and hit 200 soldiers with mounted charge.
Alright.
Sure, I can do that.
I can, actually.
Do I really wanna woo him, though?
He's just a Guan Yun fanboy.
And I want him for my son.
And there could only be one Guan Yun fanboy.
Alright.
Let's kill him.
The Pope bets.
Oh, yeah.
Like, the live bets going on who's gonna be the new Pope.
People were so sad that...
That, like...
The Pope that won literally came out of nowhere.
He was not on my betting sites!
Alright, what do I have to do?
Alright.
I need to...
Let's see.
I need to use the gauntlets.
Someone out there got the 50k.
Everyone lost so much money on the Pope gambling.
I need to use my gauntlets.
And then...
Success mount.
So, two mounted charges.
Wait.
Where my...
Like, my mounted charges?
Pompot.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki setting up.
Yeah, he shows for air again.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Let's see.
I need to use gauntlets.
Okay.
My hands.
Wait.
Is there...
Is it just regular?
Regular hands?
Okay.
I need to use battle arts.
Let's go.
Alright.
Where are they?
Don't worry.
I'm gonna go straight in.
Because I have...
I'm not very smart.
I'm just like the shoe forces.
I'm like the shoe forces, guys.
We don't know what we're actually doing.
Alright.
Nice.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
Please.
I don't know what I'm doing.
It's been a while.
Oh, nice.
I totally know what I'm doing.
Oh, shit.
Nice.
That's right.
Get over here.
I'm gonna keep fisting you.
Yeah, falcon.
Alright, to be fair, I'm like the peak shoe general.
We go in with zero plans every time.
All we do is we just fight.
Like, you have to admit, that's literally all we do.
We have no strats.
Let's get serious.
Okay.
I need that and then...
Oh, no.
It's been too long since I played.
Where am I?
Oh, I'm down here.
Oh, my God.
I didn't even realize where I was.
I couldn't tell where I was in this game.
Oh, it's been too long.
Alright, nice.
Oh, no.
Not nice.
Wait, ten of you guys are already dead?
How?
God, I hate this.
Oh, my God.
It's fine.
If they die, they die.
I can 1v3 all of them.
Alright, has been critically...
How?
All I've been doing is fighting.
How are you already dead?
I've only been fighting.
Okay.
Wait, did I do it?
800 flows.
Did I do it, guys?
I...
84?
Okay, I clearly need to fix this.
But I clearly...
Clearly, this is not it.
Maw of the Tiger.
Okay, I sh...
Is there anything that's better?
That's a 1?
Okay, power shot.
Okay, that's my bow.
That's clearly not better.
Oh, the ice.
Okay, we'll use ice.
And then...
Okay, that should be fine.
That's fine.
He'll be fine.
Guys, he'll be fine.
He doesn't need me.
Okay, I'll head over and so he'll eat his buns.
He did not need me.
He was strong enough for this.
Oh, Jesus.
Everybody is so bad.
Wait, who?
Are you giving up already?
How are you giving up?
Oh my God, there's only five of you left, Dragos?
How did you all die?
Jesus.
Okay.
Okay, maybe this is not the right...
Okay, maybe this was not the right thing.
Maybe I should not be doing this mission.
My team is not okay.
Everybody is...
Everybody is sort of dying.
Alright, nice.
He's one hit.
Okay, nice.
I don't understand.
For me, my fist is a bad weapon?
No way.
Take this.
Okay.
Get over here.
Gwanyun, how could you die?
You're literally the God of War!
How?
I've killed, like, almost all of them!
I feel like that's all I've been doing!
Oh my God, everybody is actually dying.
Oh my God, Gwanyun, please, not you too.
Gwanyun, please.
Each area we take.
All my might!
You're, I've been vested in the enemy officer.
That's how...
You're right, he has to die to become the God of War.
Okay, you're not wrong!
Gwanyun, please.
All my might!
I'm simply, like, speed...
I'm simply speedrunning his destiny.
Oh my God, he's actually one hit!
You shine like a beacon for the others.
Oh no.
Okay.
That should be fine.
I've killed them all.
If I could test my skills.
Let's go.
If I just have to go downstairs.
You're right, guys.
I'm simply just letting him become the God of War.
That's right.
So true.
Making sure he follows his destiny.
Sometimes you just have to run.
Wait, are they inside?
Wait, are they inside already?
Oh shit, I didn't know.
Oh my God.
I didn't know you guys are inside.
I was just...
I was doing my own thing.
Oh, is chat dead?
Okay, don't worry.
I'll save chat.
Oh my God.
Gwanyun, please.
Okay, nice.
No, fuck it.
I'm gonna use rage.
Alright.
Yeah, I can keep using this.
Now keep punching him.
That's right.
Get out of here.
Wait, get back closer.
Get back closer so I can use my musu.
Okay, nice.
No, there's still four of you guys.
Four of you guys are still alive.
There's still hope.
Alright.
Get out.
Okay, my team should be okay now, right?
Oh my God.
There's still one more.
Where did these people come from?
Where did they come from?
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Just need to do one more.
Nice.
Now I have free reign to keep fisting.
Pause my arms.
Don't worry.
We can give you.
We can rebuild you.
You're rebuildable.
We'll just give you like metal arms.
It's cool there.
The enemy officer has been defeated.
Oh, I killed him.
Oh, nice.
I did it.
I did my job.
Wait, get back here.
That's right, Zalio.
Do your thing.
That's fucking right.
Keep fisting.
And now I'll fucking throw you.
RKO.
Just like how the American Pope became a Pope.
This is going my way today.
Maybe next time.
All right.
So how do I get up here?
I go up.
That's very slow.
Wait, I can do the air.
Oh, my God.
There better be enough of you guys so I can do my stupid charge thing.
There is...
There better be enough of you guys alive so I can finally do my goddamn ambush.
I've been trying to do it this entire time.
Oh, my God.
I swear to God.
There better be enough of you alive.
I waited my whole life to get one successful tactic.
And it's gonna be him.
Oh, my God.
Wait, I should get...
Wait, can I even let...
Oh, my God.
Wait.
Oh.
Destroy this.
Okay.
Okay, guys.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
No!
Why are you all dead?
There was not...
Guys, there was...
There was actually not enough, guys.
There was actually not enough.
Who would have thought?
There was...
You are all dead.
You don't have enough allies.
How could all of you be dead?
I don't understand.
It doesn't make sense.
None of it makes sense.
Make it make sense.
We can respawn.
That's so far.
That's a little too far, guys.
That's...
I don't know.
How far is that?
Where's the next friendly base?
Let me...
Let me check how far it is before I...
Let me see it.
I mean, it's like...
All the way down there.
I...
I mean...
It's on you for dying, though.
Like...
Is it really my fun?
That's all I'm saying.
You did die yourself.
So...
I mean...
Why am I rewarding that behavior?
I did my job, though.
That means I must fall back for now.
I mean...
I was doing my job.
What were you doing?
I...
Did you...
I literally killed Chow Chow's cousin.
What do you mean?
I killed him.
What did you do?
You were dead when it happened.
Follow me.
Liubei.
Forward march.
I knew you guys were dead when it happened.
I didn't have enough of the...
Meter.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh, my God.
That's fine.
I can do this.
Nice.
That's not what it was written.
Well, like...
What if I was shy?
Huh?
I'm...
I'm just a little shy.
I didn't want to be...
I didn't want to be in the history.
books, guys.
I...
I was just incredibly shy.
Okay?
It's okay.
Dying doesn't impact the story.
Okay.
I want to make sure I'm full HD.
Before I do anything.
Guys.
Yeah.
Look, I was just...
You know...
I figured...
I wanted to give other people more credit and share my credit.
Because unlike some generals, I'm very humble.
And like, I wanted other people to have their say in history.
I'm just a very humble person.
With all my might.
Uh-huh.
Yes, you are.
How are people dying?
I'm killing everyone.
Okay, now...
We are at three now.
They call you...
Exactly.
I am the army of one.
Okay, nice.
Just want to make sure I get these guys first.
Jesus.
300 people was a lot more than I expected.
I...
I was not expecting.
Who would have thought?
300 people was a lot of people.
My God.
I was not aware.
Oh my God.
Who am I supposed to kill?
Who am I?
Am I supposed to kill him?
Oh, I have to kill two of them.
Okay.
Okay, this is gonna...
This is gonna be awkward.
That's a lot.
Two is a lot.
Two is a lot more than I expected.
Okay.
Like, this took me a while to do.
I won't give up.
This is it.
Not while I still draw breath.
Gotcha.
Guys, I'll fix the chat soon.
I just need to kill him.
Concentrate.
You guys don't understand.
This is...
A lot.
Okay, nice.
Alright, I got one of them.
The enemy officer...
I shall retreat now.
Has been defeated.
Wait, did I...
Okay, I got him.
Where's the other guy?
Oh, where's the other?
Where's the other boss?
Wait, where is he?
I saw one more.
Oh my god.
He's all the way there.
Why are you all the way there?
I had an attack...
Oh my god.
Get over here.
Oh, you're gonna run?
You are...
Oh my god.
I swear to god.
I...
I couldn't be of more assistance.
I swear to god.
Oh hey, all my guards fled.
Okay.
That's fine.
I can do this in two minutes.
All my might.
I can get you.
Don't worry.
I have more.
All my might.
Jesus, everybody is trying to come over.
Oh my god.
Please.
Jesus.
Okay.
Now, guys.
From no...
No general stuff.
Everything.
Okay.
Guys.
You guys got it.
Calm down.
Ow.
There's so many general sales.
What the fuck?
I can't move.
Oh my god.
I actually...
Okay.
I give...
I can't.
I...
I can't deal with this.
I actually...
I can't deal with that.
That is like...
That...
I have limits.
Guys.
I...
I have limits to this.
Where's the...
Where's the track...
Thing.
Where's the...
Okay.
There we go, there we go.
Like, I... Like, like, that is actual... Sorry, but like, that had... That had to end right there.
Alright, there we go.
Time to get... Time to get serious.
That was...
That was a little bullshit.
The enemy officer has been defeated.
Like, I was not dealing with that anymore.
I... I... I refuse to go through more of that.
Okay, now I need to do a hundred more.
Jesus, I thought I was getting close.
It was all a lie.
Okay, I need to build more.
The only issue is that it takes so long to build... To build any of my focus thing for this.
Oh my god, it takes fucking forever.
Okay, let's see.
Okay.
That's fine.
I gotta make sure I don't get...
I don't get rocked.
Uh, saying thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Any thoughts on... Uh, about Expedition 3D?
Would love to see you play it, maybe?
Is that the turn-based RPG?
I know a lot of people say it's really good.
But like, I'm... I'm not like a... I'm not really good at turn-based RPG games too.
So like, I don't know.
Um...
I don't play a lot of turn-based RPG.
I try to play Baldur's Gate.
But like, uh, for me, I think I only got to like...
I think I played it for like...
Two to three hours.
And then I...
I don't...
I didn't keep playing it.
But that's just me.
That's just me personally.
Okay.
Yeah, Baldur's Gate is like...
Not...
Oh my god.
Okay.
Yeah, I have no idea.
I don't know if I...
I heard it's really, really...
I will admit that I have heard that it's really, really, really good.
Jesus.
This is like an optional mission.
How is...
The fact that this is an optional mission and it's taking me like 20 years to fucking kill anybody?
Oh my god.
I feel like...
This is gonna take me so long.
Okay, at least I punched him.
Oh my god.
He's coming back.
I don't...
He's coming...
Oh my god.
Fine.
I got more ice in me.
Okay.
How is this taking...
What are they doing?
Why do they...
Why are they slowly...
Why are they...
Why are they slowly walking up to me?
Like, you think I don't see you?
They are just walking menacingly.
I'll take this duel.
That's fine.
Let me swap.
Okay, wait.
Alright.
Give me a sec.
I...
We are not doing...
Do it this duel.
We are not doing this duel with this weapon.
Give me a sec.
Bro.
Okay, nice.
Sorry, buddy.
I refuse to do that one.
We are absolutely not doing that duel with this.
No matter what you want.
Yes.
Okay.
Shit, he takes so long.
Oh my god.
No, I got hit.
No!
My perfect...
Oh my god.
Why do you take so long?
Jesus.
I'm trying!
Take this.
I see it.
He does so much!
Nice!
Oh, I just won it.
Let's end this.
Oh.
We were so close to perfect, but I did it.
You know what I get out of this?
Three more of you guys are going to die.
That's what I get out of it.
Three more dragoons.
That's just going to die anyway.
I love, I love dying.
Okay, that doesn't really matter that much to me.
Did I get this already?
I did, right?
I did.
It's like highlighted.
Okay, nice.
My life for aight.
Alright, let me fix chat real quick.
That should fix it.
Yeah, there we go.
Yay, see?
I got three more of you guys.
Let's go.
Alright, nice.
Uh, now I should be able to do the actual mission now.
Wah!
Wait, Lube?
Oh, I was supposed to talk to you.
I was going to be like, what?
I'm trying to do my mission, Lube.
What do you want?
Oh, hey.
Us in a garden?
In times of trouble, suffering, and sadness, you always manage to appear by my side.
Oh, yeah.
Like a guardian angel.
It does seem that way, Lord Lube.
Strange.
But your help is always welcomed.
I'd really appreciate it if you listened to what I have to say.
Yeah?
In the garden?
Just the two of us?
And he's right.
I think I may be lost.
A world...
...where all people can choose their own path toward the future.
I've declared time and again that this is the ideal world I wish to create.
But I still have no idea how to make it a reality.
You really are lost.
Me, don't worry.
Me neither.
I don't know what I'm doing.
I'm playing Epic Mix next week.
I shouldn't expect you to have the answer I need.
This is something I'll need to take care of myself, after all.
As Quan, you said.
We'll need someone to guide us if we want to find a solution to this problem.
That's why we should start our search as soon as we possibly can.
For us...
And for everyone else searching for their own path toward the future.
But...
Even if we did go to Jing...
Would we be able to find the sort of guide we seek?
Oh wait, are we getting...
Chu Got... Chu Got Learn?
Chu Get Leon?
Is that what we're trying to find?
When our other rivals are gaining strength as we speak.
I don't think we can afford to waste any more time here.
But don't take my anxiety as a sign of wavering resolve.
Oh my god, we're actually gonna have someone to think for us.
Instead of just sending people to their deaths.
This is the actual character development for him.
Our dreams again.
His entire strategy was just...
Send Guan Yun in there and then he'll kill everything.
But then like...
90% of the army dies for it.
Oh.
Didn't expect to see you here.
Hello.
That's me.
Who are you expecting?
I thought it would be Zhao Yun.
I can't turn around without him asking to spar with me.
Oh, he's trying to avoid him.
But I never get bored of fighting.
So, I don't mind.
I've taken him on a few times now.
If it ain't broke, don't fix it.
He has lost many...
fights because of it.
What do you mean?
Now we have a great lineup of strong fighters on our side.
He has lost so many battles.
Guan Yun literally left to join Zhao Zhao because of him fucking up.
But...
I'm worried we won't see eye to eye.
I learned how you work.
Yeah, you're right.
If they really are smart, they'll pick things up quick enough.
So, I've got nothing to worry about.
Whoever we bring into the fold, I just hope it's an honest person that I can get along with.
Because there's nothing I hate more than a know-it-all with a smug look on his face telling everyone how right he is.
Oh wait, I don't... I just don't think he likes smart people in general.
Report himself!
Zhao Zhao's forces are mounting an attack on us here on Runon.
Please, make haste to the war room.
He's not here to think!
He's just here to unga bunga!
Let's go!
He's gonna be like... He's one of those guys, he's like, I can take on one gorilla.
He's one of those guys.
And he's absolutely right.
Look at their strategy room!
Who is the strategist here?
This is the strategist room and there's literally zero strategist.
They stand a chance against their main force.
Heh, looks like they're not taking any chances with you on our side, brother.
Why is there even a map?
Does he plan to slaughter every last one of us?
Perhaps this would be a good time for us to flee to Jing like you mentioned before, Lord Liu Bei.
Agreed.
The ruler of Jin, Lord Liu Biao, is a relative of Liu Bei's.
He will surely welcome us with open arms.
Wait.
Under these circumstances, going to Jing would end up making it the target of Cao Cao's attack, would it not?
Oh my god, he's actually thinking about others.
I will force great hardship upon Lord Liu Biao and the people of Jing.
I think I'd rather...
You would rather throw your life away...
No, no, no.
He would rather throw all our lives away.
That's different.
Everything you want to achieve will die with you.
Condemning the people to lives of despair.
Quan Yu.
You worry too much, brother.
With a few more soldiers on our side, Cao Cao won't look so tough.
We'll make a stand in Jing and drive them back.
Right, Zhao Yun?
Yes.
And I won't let them lay a finger on Lord Liu Bei.
As long as Lord Guan Yu is there, I don't care where we go.
I'll be right by his side no matter what.
Oh my god, he's number one Oshii.
Brother, our hearts are set on Jing.
But the choice is yours.
The tier 3 sub.
You just can't let me give up and die in peace, can you?
Do you think 100 dragoons could beat one gorilla, Dogey?
But stop, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That's, that's a funny joke, guys.
At the...
Have only one Oorn to give before we go.
Everyone must survive this journey.
Now, prepare to depart.
Alright, where do we go?
Bada, Runan.
Okay.
Oh, it's literally right here.
Oh, that's convenient.
Oh, they're talking about Pantong and Jukaland.
You must have earned them.
Alright, nice.
Alright, I got a...
Yoink, mine now.
Oh, wait.
Alright, let's go fight.
I like how there's zero strategists in this room.
We had a strong one to form a Runan castle, but Tata has invaded with a large army.
We cannot expect to hold the castle.
So we have no choice but to flee the Jing province.
What managed the most right now is not the land or the castle, but the people.
I want everyone to escape, no exceptions.
However, compared to their vast force, we have barely a handful of soldiers.
I've never faced a battle quite like this.
So what do we do?
What do we do, guys?
Anyone that can think?
Neither do I.
Nor I.
And I'm not ashamed to admit it either.
What should I do, Doki?
Not Doki?
As a warrior, you have run fire and riot.
Perhaps you found yourself in similar circumstances.
You see things in a way the rest of us cannot.
Why not take command and find us a way up?
That's...
Aw, man.
Aw.
They think I stink when I play this game?
I don't.
Leave it to me, guys!
I'm grateful.
Their fates are in my hands now!
I'm the strategist now!
Is it...
Would you trust me to be your strategist, guys?
Oh!
Their fate is a...
Is in my hands!
Can I at least write my will?!
Oh!
That's funny!
I mean, every time I bring my dragoons over here, I somehow ended up with zero dragoons every time.
But their fate is in my hands.
I know what I am up for.
That's okay, I believe.
That's right.
Follow me, everyone!
Let's go!
Wait, don't wait!
I can't deal when they're all separated!
What do you mean?
The whole plan is for them to be with me!
Okay, we'll fight all of these guys together.
Guys, no, we go this way.
Guys, no, we go this way, guys.
Guys, no, no, no, guys!
Guys, guys, I thought we all follow me!
Guys, what happened?
Wait, one of you already died?
How?
How did one of you guys already died?
I'm not going to let my guard down for a second.
Wait, how did one of you guys already died?
I wouldn't let us escape so easily.
Wait, four of you guys died?!
Oh, we're hungry!
Does it make sense?
Okay, thanks.
Okay, I was told that all of you guys have to live.
Like, what the fuck?
Oh my god, I'm still trying to kill him.
I'm still trying to kill this guy.
All right, get out of here.
All right, get out of here!
That's right!
I can't believe the enemy officer has been defeated.
Guys, I don't think I can save all of them anymore.
I...
There is...
There is a chance that not all of them are going to live.
How?
Guys, what did we say about not splitting up?
Yes.
What did we say?
I don't...
We...
We said we shouldn't...
Split up!
Why is everyone splitting up?!
What do you mean, Lupe?!
You are literally the one guy that you should not be dying.
The whole plan...
Lupe is now...
Where are you advancing, Lupe?
Where are you advancing?
We are still fighting this fight.
You are not advancing anywhere.
Oh my god!
Who?
He's dying!
Okay, if he dies, that's fine.
I just need to know.
I need to know if he...
If he...
I need to know, like, what happens when he...
Do I lose?
He successfully divided their forces.
Oh, he's dead.
Okay.
I lose.
I will ever fulfill my purpose.
He left himself!
He fucking left himself!
Guys, let's split up, gang!
All right.
Like, I have to go from the beginning?!
Oh my god.
I killed so many.
I have no need for kingdoms or...
Like, how is this my fault?!
He left!
How...
How could this be my fault?!
The last one of us must escape safely.
Okay.
You have a keen eye for the battlefield.
I'm...
I'm not...
I'm not doing this.
I'm...
I'm not...
I'm not doing this, guys.
All right.
We'll put this up here.
I'm not doing this anymore.
I'm not doing that stupid mission.
I'm not doing this.
Let's just...
Let's just complete this.
Um...
I'm...
I'm not dealing with that anymore.
I can't imagine Liu Bei putting up much of a fight, but I'll defer to Lord Guojia on this magical.
Nice.
Oh my god, not again.
I'll run right over and push them back.
Okay.
We'll...
We'll deal with him soon, guys.
I just gotta make sure...
that I can live through all of...
I just gotta make sure to...
kill...
do as much damage as I can...
before...
this fucker...
leaves us.
We therefore should not be underestimated.
We will follow our orders without fail.
You know full well what we're up against here.
And I'm not going to let my guard down for a second.
Okay.
Let me kill him first.
It'll be worth it, guys.
I just...
let me kill him first.
Don't worry, he'll live.
I...
I believe in him.
All right.
I knew they wouldn't let us escape.
Let's go.
Let's go save that fucker.
You can't allow them to surround us.
Okay.
Where is he?
Oh my God.
Let's go.
Our orders are to attack them incessantly.
Sounds good to me.
He is so far.
He is.
I swear to God.
Get out of here.
Oh my God.
I used the wrong attack.
I was supposed to use the ice one.
When meet again we shall.
Good.
The path is clear.
Let's go.
I swear to God.
If you also split up...
If you are...
I swear to God.
If you also split up, I swear to God.
Stop the enemy.
And protect Liu Bei.
Take this.
Lord Liu Bei.
I have returned to my place.
All right.
Are you done?
Oh my God.
Where is he going?
Let's go.
He...
He like...
Lashed.
I...
I ended up fighting the guy he was trying to fight and then he ran away.
I'll clear a path with my own two hands.
I do arrows here.
And then every single one of us will escape with our lives.
Oh my God.
Forward march.
Is this a successful ambush?
Oh my God.
I swear to God.
Did I do it?
Oh my God.
I fought.
The big...
The high ground.
I did it guys.
I did it.
I accomplished it.
Time to act.
You're an absolute worst nightmare.
I finally did it.
I did an actual strategy.
The enemy officer has been defeated.
Oh my God.
It is possible.
I can strategize.
At least in part.
The strength of Liu Bei's officers is not to be taken lightly.
Okay.
Nevertheless.
We can use this division to our advantage.
We'll overwhelm them with greater numbers.
Okay.
Nice.
The enemy officer has been defeated.
Oh my God.
There's so many.
There's so many of them that's trying to kill us.
Who do I kill first?
I don't know who to attack first.
There's so many of them.
Okay.
This one first.
Get right here.
Nice.
Alright.
And then...
Oh my God.
Lupe.
Please.
Who are you fighting?
Who are you fighting, Lupe?
I don't understand.
Who are you fighting?
We're all here.
Where?
Together!
Okay.
Let me hit him first.
We got...
Where?
I don't...
I don't know.
I sense the bond between his strengthens.
We're all together.
How are you losing?
Okay.
Nice.
Yeah.
Thank God.
Thank God I decided to like...
Thank God I decided to like actually...
Use an actual weapon.
Versus one of the fuck weapon I had.
Nice.
Okay.
Got him.
Alright, Guanyi.
Do your thing.
Or Zhaoyun.
Zhaoyun and Zhaoyun.
Who will win?
I knew I could count on you.
Go on.
The enemy officer has been defeated.
There we go.
We took that path without most people.
Nice.
The enemy officer has been defeated.
Take this.
I don't see anything out of this.
What do you mean?
I just killed 20 people Zhaoyun.
Oh fuck.
We're next to each other.
Wait.
He's like, I need help.
Won't anybody help me?
And we're literally right next to each other.
Why are I...
My generals, we...
Guys, we need help.
We need someone to think for us.
Please.
Anyone.
Someone think for us.
Please.
We can't keep doing this, guys.
Oh my god.
And they decided to go the long way.
Okay, guys.
They decided to go the long way.
Alright.
What happened to like...
Don't worry.
I'll follow.
Not Doki.
We'll let her decide what to do.
What happened to that?
I missed those times.
I missed when they were like...
We'll follow her.
Okay, I need to swap.
I think I can use the gauntlets now.
I like kill 20...
20 men.
I should be allowed to use this now.
There we go.
That should give me like...
A lot of kills, right?
Nice.
Alright.
We're in the real place.
Okay, nice.
Wait, who...
Oh, there he is.
I was like...
Why is there still like...
People I need a kill?
I realize he's right here.
Yeah!
This is it.
This is how I'm gonna get my...
300 kills.
Right here.
So what am I going to do?
The world is not large enough for both...
I need all of this.
And Lord Cao Cao.
Give me those 300 kills!
Before you gain too much power.
Your overestimation of my ambition is becoming tiresome.
But I refuse to be defeated before making my mark on the world.
Can't get up.
I'm going...
You think I'm gonna ignore you too?
That's right.
You thought this was it?
Nice.
Oh, I came back for you.
Wait, I shielded it.
Yeah, nice.
I don't like how loud that gets.
Oh my god, whoops.
Whoops.
You know what?
I believe in you guys.
Oh yeah, you can definitely get it.
There you go.
Kill him.
That's not overkill, right?
You did it.
You hit him.
I'm so proud of you guys.
You actually hit him.
I was gonna be like, will you miss?
Let's find out.
We did it.
You did the bare minimum.
I'm so proud of you guys.
It's everything I've always wanted.
I cannot allow him to escape here.
Can't say it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Poor Doki is having to fill the strategist role even.
What do you mean?
Why?
Why did you diverge?
Hold on, hold on.
What are you coming after these for?
I'm warming with your time.
Why did you diverge?
Take this.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
You can't do anything, right?
I got the wrong one.
To cross the river here.
Lord knew that.
Please watch your step.
Take this.
I knew they'd be here.
Oh my god, okay.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
Okay, now we should be fine, right?
We made it through.
Let's hurry.
If we don't move fast, they'll be right on top of us.
Do what?
Strike while the enemy is stumbling.
Oh my god, it's him.
No, he's less fabulous though.
Wait, what?
What the fuck?
I...
What happened?
I turned around for one second.
Oh my god, what do I have to deal with now?
Took you long enough.
Okay, thank god.
Okay, he's doing something right.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
Okay, that's good.
He's doing something right.
That's good.
Okay.
That's fine.
Oh my god, Jesus.
Okay.
Okay, we're not gonna use Guanyu yet.
We're saving Guanyu for Tau Tau.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
I missed one.
Oh wait, his weapon's a spear now?
Really?
Aww.
I'm sad.
I liked his claws more.
His claws was so cool.
Like, honestly.
Yeah, they got rid of his...
They got rid of his, like, claws!
That shit was so cool!
It should be rather difficult.
We'll have to go after them ourselves.
Jeff's fear!
Now advance!
They added realism in my fantasy warriors game!
I miss when they use fans to fight!
I...
Do you remember when they would use fans?
Those were the good old days!
I can't believe it!
If they were gonna give me romance, then I should be able to be fabulous!
Alright, nice!
Come on!
What are you waiting for?
Let's get this fight started!
He lost his beauty.
He really did.
He's not as...
He's not as fabulous now.
True!
Oh my...
All I'm saying is that if I'm gonna have romance in here, I should be allowed to have, like, giant ass...
Oh wait, what...
Where are they going?
Where are we trying to fight these guys?
Okay, we'll fight in a while.
Yeah, that's right.
What you gonna do?
I'll body block you!
Oh, they're just gonna walk?
I like how we're just all waiting here for him!
What the...
Don't worry!
I shall guard the...
But they can't...
They actually can't do anything here!
That's actually fun!
Domain expansion!
Oh, I have to wait for these guys too!
Give me a sec!
Give me...
I'm gonna wait for them!
Dude!
Domain expansion!
Get over here!
That's right!
They can't do anything too!
That's so funny!
That's so dumb!
I did it, guys!
Don't worry!
What are you gonna do now?
Wow!
No!
Wait!
Oh my...
No!
I can't even do anything!
We'll slowly walk over!
Oh my god!
You got a good relationship!
Take this!
Okay...
Turbent times dictate such things...
That's fine...
So we have a duel then!
Be warned.
I shall not hold back!
Okay...
All that!
Oh my...
That's fine!
That's fine...
I just love how... That's so dumb.
That's actually so dumb.
Okay, nice.
There we go.
Nice, we got the other one.
It's just Tau Tau.
Okay, I think we win this now.
I think we just won.
We literally killed Tau Tau.
For you, I wonder.
Let's go.
Someday, our forces will clash in one final battle.
They shall talk about this battle for years to come.
Where we fought in the Tau Tau Pond.
Where we fought... I can't believe it.
Their one weakness.
Wadi!
Who would have thought?
Wait.
No.
You're too far.
Wait.
Let's go.
I'm gonna kill them.
Wait, how do I get over there?
Guys, how do I jump again?
Oh, there.
Don't worry.
Let me kill these guys first.
Alright, nice.
Okay.
They're all just witches.
Alright, nice.
Jesus, you're so tanky!
That's the worst.
When you're so god damn tanky!
Okay, nice.
One more hit.
Time to act.
The curtain cross here!
The enemy officer has been defeated.
Oh, what I thought.
Their one weakness.
Wait.
This should be like...
A successful...
There we go.
Alright, I'm gonna leave you guys there.
Wait, how do I jump out there?
I keep forgetting how to jump.
Oh my god, guys.
I don't know how to get back up there.
Okay, there you go.
Don't worry, I'm here, guys.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I could...
Oh wait, mounted charge.
Oh my god, this is a perfect mounted.
Go in there!
My eight men are still alive!
Oh my god!
You guys did it!
I've always believed in you!
My eight men are still alive!
They still have their legs!
We got one!
Fiction, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Gears of War is officially moved.
Oh, really?
Finally!
Oh my god.
I'm actually surprised.
Looks like we've got...
Can't believe they finally actually are...
Is it remastered or just like a port?
But thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That's one of the games I've always wanted to try.
Everything we do is supposedly impossible.
I'm just glad that...
Oh, poor...
That one guy fell off the cliff.
Indeed.
We all survive what many would not.
It serves as a strong reminder...
That I possess such reliable companions.
Oh yeah, companions.
Yeah, it's...
The great battle of the...
Wayside Pond Water.
Perfect!
And our great purpose.
It was truly a battle that people would tell for years to come.
Fispo, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The hardest battle that Southall I ever fought.
Nice.
Plus 28.
I finally did it.
I've held onto that goddamn thing for so long.
Hit, hit.
Lead a successful charge.
Is there any more?
Oh my god.
I don't understand this one.
What is the wheel recovery?
Is that the counter?
For the wheels?
Or what?
That was a narrow escape.
But we made it.
We were lucky everyone did their part.
I lost count of the times I thought that tidal wave of soldiers would swallow us whole.
So this is what it means to face the full brunt of Lord Tao Tao's forces in a direct conflict.
So it seems.
Zhao Yun, Zhou Tsang.
We've already put so much weight on you.
I don't see.
On the contrary.
Overcoming deadly circumstances is an officer's one true joy.
I'm thankful for the experience.
I'd go to hell and back for Lord Guan Yu.
As long as he's around, I can get through anything.
I see.
Okay, I know what wheel cover is now.
Thanks, guys.
We just need one more for the Pan Tong mission.
Whoops.
Okay.
Escape the ever-tighten grip of Tao Tao forces into the hands of Lu Biao.
They went on to spend a brief period under his protection.
Okay.
County Castle.
Shinye County.
A brief period of eight years have passed.
Wouldn't you agree?
That does sound so bad.
Let's drink away our problems, guys.
It's great to have a break from fighting.
But my body is itching for some action.
Forget it, Zhang Fei.
The last time you thought you had time to drink, you nearly destroyed Liu Biao's reputation.
He needs an intervention.
Come on, and I have boredom here.
I figured Tao Tao would be hot on our heels.
But he ended up falling back toward Hebei.
This is an intervention right now.
And go out on patrol.
Lord Liu Biao has given us a warm welcome.
And even allowed us to garrison here at Shinye Castle.
Alright.
I'm trying to get tissues.
I think it's best to meet Lord Liu Biao's expectations by governing well and earning the trust of the people of Shinye.
If you have time to get drunk, then you have time to listen to the troubles of at least one of the peasants.
Yeah, yeah, I get it.
But isn't that the sort of thing we've been doing since the start?
I thought Liu Bei brought us here to do something bigger and more important.
But while we're sitting around and doing our jobs, Tao Tao is getting stronger by the day.
It's because Tao Tao has like 10 strategists in his army.
We still have zero.
You gave me the role of strategist.
Every time he has a meeting room, his entire meeting room is just people that think for him.
What's best for us?
Also, Billy, thank you for the five gifted shits.
Thank you, thank you.
This strategy is for nerds, Doki.
We still haven't met him yet.
We've been losing, but somehow, for some reason, we still, we still haven't recruited a guy that thinks.
All right.
What kind of super chats do I have today from the ye olde dragoons?
To the one who saved our caravan once again.
Not Doki.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, caravan leader.
Thank you for defending our caravan from those bandits.
You just started your journey as wandering warrior when you helped us.
It has been a long time since I last saw you, but I'm relieved that you seem to be in good health.
What's more, I've heard that you have remembered your past.
And you still act with just as mishonor as you did before rediscovering yourself.
You are the scared, sacred wings that will carry our world to the peace that awaits us.
I have no doubt that you will continue to bring hope to all who gaze up at the sky in search of salvation.
Please accept this modest gift as my thanks.
I eagerly await the day we meet again.
Oh my god, this guy gave me $10,000.
Oh my, thank you for the aka, aka, aka, super.
Oh my god, we have an oil Saudi prince right now in ye olde ancient China.
A former patient.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Greetings, not Doki.
After the doctor helped you regain your memories and my body was stored to full health, I've been left with fewer reasons to visit him.
Life, oh my god, that's right.
If you, like, make them, like, if you, like, don't fully cure them, they'll always have to depend on you.
And then you'll make so much money as a doctor.
That is so smart.
That's very unethical too.
Life is just so peaceful these days.
Since then, it seems Master Yuanha has been traveling the realm, helping countless people in need.
I'm now worried that he may be working a bit too hard.
And, uh, and worrying is the only thing I can do about it.
If only he had someone to help him.
An assistant, perhaps.
Uh, no, I think an apprentice is what he needs.
I suppose it wouldn't be feasible to ask someone as busy as yourself, would it?
This will be my last letter.
But I leave the doctor's well-being in your hands.
Oh my god.
You fool!
You could have not fully...
Oh my god, he gave me 50 rocks.
Never mind.
That's fine.
I got 50 rocks.
I'm okay.
That's fine.
I need that 50 rocks.
Uh, Fat Cat, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
10 strategists versus 1 Guan Yun.
Needs more strategists.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, what does Xiao Yun want?
Uh, Lazy Squid.
Luke the Lazy Squid.
Welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Tonight, Lord Liu Biao is hosting a banquet in Xiangyan.
Lord Liu Bei will be attending, and I've been ordered to accompany him as his escort.
I'll need to be ready for anything.
Anything on your mind?
Yeah.
Why am I talking to you?
I'm just spending a little time here in Jing.
I've come to understand something.
Those who serve under Lord Liu Biao have divided into factions.
And one of them doesn't think very well of them.
Traitors!
Initially, Lord Liu Bei had hoped to attend the banquet on his own.
He said that having an intimidating escort would make us look un- And he chose you?
Ha ha ha ha!
You're more of a fucking pretty boy than intimidating escort.
Why not?
Yeah, why not?
Why not me?
Ha ha ha!
I'm so intimidating!
Why not me?
Ha ha ha ha!
Well, at first you planned on having the both of us as escort.
And he picked you!
I thought I had something special!
Lord Liu Biao wouldn't be able to relax enough to enjoy his wine.
Oh, we'd be too hot.
I get it.
I want you to rest, so you can be ready for anything unexpected.
As for me, I am bound by our leader's orders.
It's okay.
I'd be too distracted if we're both there.
It's just to be too hot.
After what I've seen, it's clear that not all is well here in the land of Jing.
All I can do is hope for the best.
The following day, fade to black.
Wake up!
Liu Bei's in trouble!
What?
Wait, I'm trying to sleep!
Wake me up in five minutes, guys.
Five more minutes, John Fee!
Stop running and get out of bed right now!
My brother!
My brother, he...
He's at the banquet, he...
Dammit, I can't explain it!
What happened?
Zhao Yun will tell you everything!
Just hurry up and come with me!
What happened?
Wait, why is Zhao Yun back?
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
He's a pretty boy.
He's a different kind of this.
He hasn't returned here to Xinyi.
Where could he possibly have gone?
What?
Just to reiterate what you told us, Zhao Yun.
You had one job!
Correct?
Yes.
One of Lord Liu Biao's retainers, Tsai Mao, made the suggestion to divide the banquet with the lords and the retainers seated separately.
And you agreed?
I just did the proposal over and over again.
But I relented at Lord Liu Biao's command and was forced to go to a separate room.
Oh, okay.
At least you'd, like, try.
Lord Liu Biao came later to inform me that Lord Liu Biao had gone to relieve himself and never returned.
Oh my god!
What if he fell in the toilet?
The whole banquet was in an uproar.
And that is when I became wise to Tsai Mao's plan.
You were supposed to go to the bathroom with him!
And saw the banquet as a chance to eliminate Lord Liu Biao.
Getting the lords and retainers into separate rooms was likely a ploy to pull Lord Liu Biao out from under my watch.
Such treachery.
But it is possible that our brother sensed danger and fled.
You were supposed to guide him to the bathroom and help him hold him!
No!
I hope he's safe!
He'll pay for this.
I'll kill him the second I see him!
Calm yourself, Zhang Fei.
For now, we need to make sure our brother is safe.
Damn it all!
And what about Liu Biao?
We all know he must have had a hand in this, too.
No.
Lord Liu Biao rebuked Tsai Mao and placed him under strict watch.
It really seemed like he had no prior knowledge of the plot.
Whatsoever.
Oh my god.
He is not at fault for what happened.
We had training for this, Jaliyu.
You should fall on the one who failed to guard his lordship.
That's right!
You shamelessly returned with nothing but excuses.
Whip yourself!
Now!
I will fight for Liu Biao.
Even if it costs me my life.
Punish yourself!
And after that, I intend to accept whatever punishment I deserve.
I think you're right.
All we have gone is faithfully guard our brother's life.
You have nothing to be ashamed of.
Lord Guan Yu.
While we're wasting time talking, our brother could be...
Right.
We've no time to waste.
The more of us we have looking for him, the better.
Joe Tao.
Send your man to Xi'an now.
What the fuck?
Why did we bring the intern?
Why is the intern here in this very important meeting?
Don't worry.
I'll get the job done.
He's got a cool hat.
Alright.
I knew it.
He should have picked me.
Yeah.
See, look at that.
Zao, you can't get anything right.
He should have picked me for the job.
There's like...
There's a city man that wants to talk to me.
Okay.
What's this?
Why does a city man want to talk to me?
Where is he?
Am I going to the right area?
Oh, I am not.
God, this map is a little confusing.
Lord Sun Tren will make a great war.
It should be like...
Here?
Weeeeee.
And then...
Okay, it's this way.
And then we...
Oh, there they are.
I see the city man.
Weeeeee.
Alright, city man.
What do you want?
Have we seen...
Yeah.
Have you seen him?
Uh...
What?
Who was that again?
I did not almost die in several battles for you to go who for Lu Bay.
Hey, come on now.
He was Lord Liu Biao's guest of honor.
Remember?
Hey, no.
Did they just say who to Lu Bay?
Oh, so he's pretty important, huh?
I don't know what Lord Liu Bay looks like, but...
I did see an elegantly dressed man over at the...
I can't believe it.
He got who mega lulled.
We usually go to the market up north, but there's a nasty bunch of soldiers hanging around there, so...
We went south and...
You don't even have a name and you don't know who Lu Bay is?
I think that must have been when he spotted him.
I'm sorry we couldn't be of any more help.
I hope someone finds Lord Liu Bay soon.
Alright.
Do you know what's going on?
I've been running around asking everyone I can.
But not a single one of these people have seen Lord Liu Bay.
Oh, that's not good.
I'm going to look around here a little more.
So, would you mind taking your search up north?
Everyone knows who City Madness is.
Every city has one of them.
So, your search brought you here as well.
That means my brother must have come this way.
At least one of them.
But there's a deep valley just ahead.
And I heard someone just cut the bridge down.
So, there's no way across.
I mean, I see the bridge right there.
You think that means he had to jump into the river down below?
And if he did, I really hope he made it across.
This bridge?
The one I just crossed?
Like...
That one?
He's like, they cut the bridge.
You mean that bridge?
Oh, City Mad wants to talk again.
But I want to know if there's anybody important back here.
Being hungry keeps you in low spirits.
Alright, is there...
Any, uh...
It's you.
Any interactions?
Oh, again?
Okay.
Oh, I could give him money.
No.
No, I...
No, we're not...
No, we're not giving the intern money.
He does this for free.
Like, we're not letting him have...
No.
No, the intern is not...
Okay, there's the city man again.
Wait, there's a second city man?
There's more than one?
In the city?
I don't think he's a child.
Sir, I think your child...
I might have just gone through puberty.
Oh, my...
Bro, that's...
I think...
I don't know.
There could be several possibilities.
This guy...
This guy is a little person...
And has scammed the city man.
It's like the orphan situation...
Where he's, like, actually some, like, 40-year-old man...
Who just, like, looks like a child...
And they adopted him...
And now...
And now he's trying to steal his wife.
I...
Oh, all right.
Shall we head downstream to the east today?
Oh, Tabby, thank you for the raid.
Thank you, thank you.
Water flows much faster up west.
Please excuse us.
We'll be going now.
I want to talk to your child.
Let me talk to your child.
Why does your child only have one line?
Let me...
Let me interrogate the child.
Let me hear what he has to say.
The quote-unquote child.
Wait, what?
He just...
Bro, we sent our entire army to find you.
Found him.
What did you do?
Sup, that's me.
Excuse me?
No, explain.
No, we're not just gonna travel five days to a new city.
Like, explore and then we fade to black.
They're just like...
I'm not gonna say anything of why I was gone for several days now.
But I'll say everything when I'm back home.
I didn't realize what Sai Mao was up to during the banquet.
I pretended to go relieve myself and made my escape.
I was not familiar with the area, so all I could do was wander.
Before I knew it, the night had grown dark and I was lost in the mountains.
Just when I began to...
Oh my god.
He met...
He met my Oshi, guys.
It was home to an old man named Si Ma Hui.
I told him who I was.
Oh my god, we finally can have someone to thank for us.
Si Ma Hui?
Why does that name sound so familiar?
Apparently, everyone calls him Master Shui Jing.
He is not in the service of Lord Liu Biao, and he lives in seclusion.
When I told him about my current circumstances, he gave me this advice.
Choose one of my pupils, the sleeping dragon or the fledgling fiend.
Phoenix, and your path will become clear.
Sleeping dragon?
Fledgling fiend?
Who the hell are they?
That's Pantong and Zhukotlin.
You've met many people in your travels.
Do you have any idea who those two might be?
Or both?
Okay, one.
No one comes to my mind.
We're getting my Oshi.
Zhukotlin.
So, you think he's either the sleeping dragon or the fleshly fiend?
That's right, I'm sorry, Pantong.
Phoenix.
With all due respect, Lord Liu Biao.
You're just gonna die anyway.
For the names of the sleeping dragon and fledgling phoenix.
Yeah, honestly, yeah, that's true.
That would really speed things along for us.
You were gone for like several days.
I did all I could to get the names out of him.
You'll know.
He would just say, you'll know, and smile without answering.
Hmm.
Perhaps he meant that you must put forth some effort to find what you seek.
And then we get both.
And even then, we can't save Lupe.
He's just like, you know, he's like one of those guys.
He has like all these like amazing generals and strategists.
And they're all like, I can fix him.
But in the end, he was just unfixable.
It was just that sad.
Everyone just kept saying, I can fix him.
And then in the end, like, it just was not fixable.
He had to prove he couldn't be fixed.
And the first step is to make his son just not mentally there.
And by dropping his son on the floor on his head.
Just to make sure that his bloodline ends there.
What's this all about?
I'm sorry.
I guess I should start from the beginning.
What Lord Lupe's ranks are missing is the guidance of wisdom.
I myself have spent a good deal of time in the...
John Madden.
Well, I may not have the vision of the sleeping dragon or...
And then like...
Jukotlan had to like...
Take care of the special son.
I feel so bad.
Yeah, after Lupe died...
He had to take care of him.
Where do I start?
South-South forces are attacking.
Make haste to the war room.
Right away.
South-South forces have already reached the castle gates.
And they've moved into such a...
They always are attacking me.
It's like...
South-South is like the...
The...
Like hand sanitizer.
That was like...
It kills 99% of the bacteria.
And Lupe is like always like...
But like he always survives the 1%.
But there might be even more of them coming.
If we stay on the defensive too long...
Our soldiers will lose heart.
The weekly event.
You're right.
More importantly, us holding up here would be a great burden on the people of Xinyu.
But what else can be done?
We aren't getting anywhere by talking.
I'm going out there.
All right?
We'll be right back.
Can you know this, nerd?
Would you be willing to help us through this?
What is your name?
I am Shishu, a pupil of Master Shui Jing.
I thought my skills would be best put to use in the service of Lord Liu Bei.
So, here I am.
Our first brain cells...
Wait!
His master didn't even mention him?!
That is so sad!
I had a look at the enemy's formation in the front of the gate just a moment ago.
It is known as the Eight Gates Formation.
Charging into that powerful formation without the right strategy would end in certain death.
That's our always... that's our strategy the entire time.
We've always done that and we live.
But if I could observe their ranks from a closer position, I may be able to tell you the best way to fight against them.
Brother, what should we do?
Can we really trust this strategist with our lives?
Are we really letting this nerd here?
I believe in him.
Besides, none of us had any idea how to get out of this.
So why not give Shishu's plan a chance?
Lord Liu Bei, you will not be disappointed.
The forgotten one.
Oh!
That poor guy!
No one mentioned him!
His master did not talk about this guy!
Dragon?
Liu Bei and his sworn brothers...
Alright, I'm gonna use the bathroom real quick, guys.
I'll be right back.
I can't wait to meet them.
Well, we won't have to wait long.
They'll be here today.
Sorry, I'm back.
I have to refill my water as well.
Woah!
Thank you guys for the super chats.
Uh...
Alan, Johnny, Solid, Mike, Bite, Zekra, Potipo, Duck, Mehdi, Smug, Anton and Kaz.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Really appreciate it, guys.
Thank you!
Alright, let's do this.
Let's...
Let's fight the...
Let's fight the hand sanitizer once more.
We finally have the one strategist in the strategy room.
I've not yet earned this place among you, but please hear me out.
What am I looking at?
What...
What the fuck is this?
What am I looking at?
What the fuck?
Okay.
That's a lot of people.
As you can see.
Tao Tao's forces, I've closed in Xing Yi.
In exceptional formation.
They're led by Xiao Hu Yun, and I'm sure you're all well aware.
He is one of Tao Tao's...
Yeah, it's like a big...
It's like the white blood cell ready to fucking kill me.
I'm like the virus and the white...
That's like the white blood cell that's about to fucking eat me.
Um...
He is one of Tao Tao's top officers.
That's where I sat.
We're commanded by Lord Lu Bei.
He is the formation on which our forces stand.
Without him, we will all be lost.
No.
Okay.
The other thought came into my mind.
That's the egg.
And I'm gonna be the first one in it.
I...
I appreciate the kind words.
But we can't afford to lose you either.
True.
Thank you.
It is true.
That I am the only one who knows how to break this formation.
Lord Lu Bu...
I'm gonna win the race, guys.
I'm grateful for your concern.
Now, let us discuss the formation we're dealing with.
It's a unique strategy called the Eight Gates Formation.
It's said that none who attack it survive.
But if we're careful to take the right steps, we should be able to breathe through and go straight in.
However, the Eight Gates Formation being employed by Tao Tao's forces in this battle looks slightly different from the one that I know.
To break the formation, we'll have to distinguish the gates of life, view, and opening from the others.
The first thing I do...
I need you all to do is capture the high ground so I can get a better look at the formation.
From there, I'll find an entry point for our troops to break through.
Until then, everyone must be very careful not to engage with the Eight...
No!
But I must be first!
You attack it with the wrong strategy.
The formation will overwhelm your troops.
Resulting in heavy losses for our side.
Hmm, I think that's all I have to say for now.
I'll have more orders for everyone as soon as I know about the situation.
Without you here, we probably would have blindly charged into the so-called Eight Gates Formation.
No, he's right.
He's right.
No, we would have 100% just went in there.
That's...
That's been our strategy for the last 10 playthroughs of this...
Of this game.
In this battle, we will rely on Shu Shu's...
On our strategist wisdom.
Everyone, do as you're told and fight with all your strength.
I like how...
If we succeed, he did all of that and history forgets him.
And then all we talk about is Pantong and Zhukotlen.
Alright.
What happens if I charge right in?
Will I lose?
Do you think I'd lose if I did not listen?
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna do it, guys.
No one's gonna...
No one can stop me.
Let's...
Let me beat them up first.
Wait, actually, let me check what I need to do.
Alright.
We need to...
We have 50 more for this.
And then...
Okay, we'll do the wheel later.
Alright, nice.
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna break that formation.
I don't need a strategist to tell me what to do.
It has always worked.
Why would it suddenly stop working?
Oh, he's gonna go straight in it.
Wait, he is gonna go in it.
Wait, I will...
No, he's trying to be there first!
Wait, that's not fair!
They're trying to...
They're trying to break through the egg!
Okay!
What the fuck?!
What the...
We can't go anywhere!
They surrounded us so quickly.
So this is the infamous eight gates formation.
Wait, that's the eight gate?
Nice.
I still have a chance.
I still...
Nice, guys.
There's still hope!
I'll break the formation.
Don't worry.
I'll be the one to break it.
They fell for the trap.
Now, well, that's what they get.
We're charging in without a plan.
Don't worry.
There's no time to spare.
I'll be the one to break it, guys.
Let's take the high ground.
Quickly invested.
They died trying to be first.
Okay.
Nice.
MINE!
Has been defeated.
Where should we go next?
It's time!
It's my turn!
Can I save this?
Okay, good- It's time!
It's my turn!
It's time!
Nothing bad's gonna happen to me!
Wait a minute.
I'll just kill him first.
Wait, I actually can't do anything.
It has like a shield.
I can't even break it.
Wait, that's...
Fuck!
Wait, I can't even break it!
It's fine.
I'll kill you because I'm angry.
Daddy's angry.
It's a little peek.
I just want to know what's going on.
Can I like... Eventually.
What if I do this?
Oh my god, I'll force my... Kwan Yun!
Make the opening!
I can't... I actually can't get through.
That's not fair!
I want him to be first!
No!
It's... They were safe!
They... No!
There's protection!
I can't believe it!
They're cheating!
No!
The protection was too strong.
I can't believe it!
It's okay.
They can be broken.
Why did I just say that?
I'm sorry.
Sorry.
I'm a little too wild today.
Let's get serious!
Oh, word.
They're so...
How...
Alright, nice.
I can't believe this.
Alright.
The enemy officer has been defeated.
Wait, where's the other guy?
Oh, there he is.
I was like, Oh my god, that's the other Daoyun.
That's... Oh wait, his name is Daoyun.
Oh my god.
Just one letter.
Alright.
Let's get to this.
That's fine.
Take this.
Boom.
And then...
Oh my god, he just kissed me.
Legally distinct.
We've done everything that you asked.
Alright, what do we do?
Now, we need to observe their formation.
Alright, we just stay up here?
He's just...
As I expected, their formation is incomplete.
Yeah?
If everyone follows my orders correctly, this plan is sure to succeed.
But...
The enemy is undeniably strong.
Wait, it's like a maze.
They made a fucking maze?
Just move!
To exploit.
The gates of life, view, and opening have been expertly concealed.
It will be difficult to determine which one to attack.
Hmm.
If we choose the wrong one, it will not end well for us.
Blue.
Oh my god, we're playing blues.
Those three gates are bound to be different from the others, somehow.
We just need to look for that difference.
If we choose the correct gate, their formation will crumble.
Okay.
How do we do it?
Then we now know what must be done.
Thanks to Shishu, we have a clue.
Alright.
We gotta follow the maze.
At close the formation, look for a gate that is different from the others.
Look for a gate that's... like that one?
When you've spotted the difference, enter the formation from there.
Enter the formation from there.
You will be able to dismantle it from inside.
Like, like this giant gate in front of me?
Like...
The enemy's movement.
We must have entered the wrong gate.
Oh.
Oh, that wasn't it.
You have entered the gate of destruction.
Oh no!
I entered the wrong gate!
No!
I thought I was being clever!
I was like, look at that gate!
It looks different, guys!
Oh my god, they're so stupid.
I was like, haha, they're so stupid.
Look how stupid this gate is.
It looks...
Look at that!
I can't believe it!
I was a fool!
I thought I was so smart!
What?
Guan Yu!
Get over here!
Wrong hole.
Mono Guan Yu, please.
I need you here.
Oh my god.
Oh my...
Get over here.
You dragoons, you might die, but...
God damn.
Oh, that was close.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
Oh, there's a fire arrow.
Don't worry, I saved you!
So like, okay, only three of you guys died.
Okay, come on.
Just one more.
I do in love.
Oh no!
Nice.
The enemy officer has been defeated.
Looking rough.
I shall retreat and fight another day.
Okay, so I entered the wrong hole, guys.
How do I...
Until another flaw appears in the formation.
Okay, I messed up.
Do you dare challenge this formation with your strength?
Oh, I messed up.
I...
What would have been like if I didn't mess up the hole?
What...
I wonder what would have been like if I found the right one.
I...
Oh, that's unfortunate.
So the enemy had units ready to attack.
The hate cage formation was to be used for a counter-attack.
Just as I predicted.
We should be able to stop the reinforcements at the Western Stronghold.
Not a moment to lose in dealing with the formation.
I'm trying to figure this out.
Kuan Yin, please!
Why aren't you helping?!
He's just...
He's just watching!
That, this is it.
I'm done.
That's it.
I don't care.
What?!
Oh my god!
What do you mean I've lost my entire army?!
It was one hit!
How did you all die?!
Easy.
G.
Oh my god!
You guys all died!
I don't understand!
How did you guys all die?!
The stupid 8 gate formation!
I don't know!
Why don't you help out and hit him!
Guan Yin!
What?!
He's like, are you okay?
I don't know you can help!
I can use the...
I can finally use my hands!
Okay, how many more do I have to kill?
The stupid objective.
Uh...
Oh my god, I'm at 90.
Wait, I'm almost there, actually.
To break their formation!
Oh my god, when will I ever break their stupid formation?!
There you go!
Did it break the formation?!
Has been defeated.
I can't believe you broke through with the force alone!
Oh my god, I did it!
Brute force!
I did it, guys!
From sheer brute force!
I told you!
That's all we needed!
Shit!
Alright, let's kill this guy real quick!
I'm gonna go kill this guy real quick!
She won the...
It's the sixth gate!
Oh my god, I told you!
I told you!
We can do it from brute force!
We didn't need...
We didn't need it, actually!
I would be honored!
If I could test my skills!
Wait, I couldn't...
Wait, give me a sec!
We can have the perfect mounted charge!
Oh no, we already messed up the mounted charge!
It's okay!
It's fine!
You know what?
Ah, fuck it!
I...
Can't be bothered!
I gave up trying!
Fuck it!
This is just easier!
Get over here!
The god of war is coming for you!
This might be overkill, but I don't care!
I don't care!
Get out of here!
I'll keep swinging until you're dead!
That's red!
And now I shall swing!
Nice!
I did it!
Oofy!
Alright, nice!
We actually needed bread, too!
Alright!
Let's go!
Okay, we gotta find the gate!
Cause I clearly messed up the first time!
Mr. Broken Bond!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Tookie, you went into the wrong hole!
Amateur!
Alright, guys!
Let's find the right hole now!
Which gate looks different from the other gates?
There's gate over here...
And then there's...
There's no gate here!
Oh my god!
Which gate is it?
Wait!
There's no gate here!
How do I...
Oh!
I still don't understand!
I...
Wait...
I still don't understand yet!
Oh my god!
I finished this stupid mission!
Okay!
Alright!
Let me get the...
Wait, actually?
Which is the strongest?
How do I sort?
Sort...
Oh wait!
This is the strongest!
I should use the strongest one!
Sorry, drag wounds!
Wait, actually...
Let me...
Change the...
Let me change it first!
I didn't know!
Oh, that's cool!
I'm only doing that because it looks cool!
Okay, then we'll do that and then...
And then we'll bring peace!
Oh my god!
Yes!
The peace bringer!
Alright!
Alright, nice!
Get out of here!
There!
It looks cool and that's all that matters!
That's all that matters!
Alright!
Let's use our e...
Our eye!
Gah!
Where do we go?
Wait, how does my eagle eye tell me where to go?
I...
I don't understand!
Everyone was like...
Just use your...
Your...
Your eagle power!
But...
What does that mean?
Oh!
The glowing flag?
Does anything glow to you?
Does anything...
Oh wait!
There it is!
Wait!
Wait, it's gone!
Oh!
There it is!
It glows!
That's the right formation!
Is it this one?
Where do I go now?
Which way is the right way?
Do I go straight?
We've entered the gate of life.
The correct point of attack.
We can break their defense from there.
Where do I go?
I'm gonna go the wrong way, aren't I?
I'm gonna die...
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha!
So you're trying to break our formation.
Not if I stop you first.
Okay.
Let's defeat that officer, and weaken their formation.
We're weakening it.
I'm just like, where do I go after though?
Instructions unclear!
Oh my god.
He has no name!
Why are you so strong?!
Oh, that was a long war.
We'll do something about this.
Any more surprises like that will make it difficult.
Okay, nice.
Cao Cao.
I must prevent him from continuing on his path.
Oh my god, he said, help me!
And after that, I cannot lose Liu Bei.
Shadow!
Or Silver!
Weak-willed followers of Cao Cao, bloodied on his path to domination, become lost in the fog.
Oh my god.
And lament your deeds.
Oh my god, he lit the incense.
What is this ghastly fog?
Oh my god, it's the incense!
He used the power of incense, guys!
The formation is beginning to break.
Let us strike before they recover.
I'm trying my best!
What is this?
Everyone, keep this up!
With all my might.
All right.
We did it.
The enemy officer has been defeated.
That should be the...
We've almost destroyed their eight gates formation.
Let's go.
All right, let's get out of here.
Let's get some distance from the formation for now.
We will enter from another gate to finish them off.
All right, give me a sec.
I'm gonna go kill...
Cheng Yao real fast.
A tactical mind is truly a great blessing.
Okay, I've escaped from there.
Okay, we have like one more to go.
The enemy attacks us where we are most vulnerable.
So much for an easy victory.
Now it's the border gate formation.
When did they get a strategist?
We got them in the first half.
They thought it was just brute force because I didn't know what the fuck I was doing.
I'm glad that the skills don't use you.
Where the fuck did they actually get...
Like, people could think.
Alright, don't worry.
I'm gonna go do a little...
little...
side quest here.
And meet Bai Liang.
Hello.
Hello, that's me.
Nope.
I'm gonna fight him.
They're like, let me handle this.
And I was like, no!
I wanna fight you!
That's right.
Oh my god, wait.
It's not fair.
It's fine.
Like, I said that, but I'm already, like, here beating him up.
From where I shall roar!
Oh, he, like, walked away.
He just...
Watch this, guys.
Oh my god!
Okay, watch this, though.
There we go.
I believe...
It's literally one guy.
There's no way you can fuck this up, guys.
There's...
It's not overkill.
It's literally...
He literally worked for Lu Bu.
It's never...
Overkill.
I see it.
Alright.
Boom.
Ariel.
Let's end this.
Yeah!
It's just that easy.
However, we shall meet in battle again.
Let you do it.
My job here is done.
What did you do?
You just lit a bunch of incense.
And do what you must.
What the fuck did you do, Bai Liang?
You literally just lit incense!
I did most of the job.
But you didn't do anything.
Let's go back.
And he did it well.
That's all you need to know, Doki.
Alright.
Oh wait, we did the...
Okay, we did that.
And then...
Oh, the wheels!
I forgot about the wheels.
Okay.
Wheels time.
Is that the strongest?
No, this is the strongest wheel I have.
Alright, time to find the last gate.
Gah!
Okay.
Where's the last gate?
Gah!
No, not this one.
Guys, don't worry.
I'm not gonna preforce this.
Don't worry.
We're gonna figure this out together.
Oh my god, I almost went through.
Oh wait, it's right here!
Is that glowing?
Yeah, it's right here.
That's glowing, right?
I can't tell.
Yeah.
Okay.
This is it.
Alright.
We've gone in through the gate of opening.
That should be the end of it.
Intruders?
You've got a bad feeling about this.
You need to defend this area.
With everything we have.
Concentrate.
Nice.
Okay.
Alright, I should...
I should really...
I should really swap my weapon actually.
I forgot how weak they are right now.
Uh...
Wait, actually...
Sword by...
Is that the strongest?
Wait, that is the strongest.
Okay, but this is so weak.
Yeah.
Yeah, this weapon is definitely stronger.
Let's go!
Okay, you know what?
Gotcha!
It's time!
It's ice time!
That's right!
Oh shit, you're too far!
Please!
Get closer!
Oh, nice.
It's still hit.
Nice.
Thank God for the walls.
To have you here is all I need.
There we go.
I'm counting on you.
Now and beyond.
Let's end this.
Gonna break your neck!
The enemy officer...
Yay!
Alright.
And then back to the wheels.
Oh shit!
You know what?
Wait, actually...
We defeated our formation with both precision and resolve.
Oh, wait, I missed!
What?
I missed!
That's a little awkward.
Time to act.
An opening.
Take this!
Now.
Head!
Take this!
That's fine.
I just gotta keep using my things.
Oh wait!
He uses wheels too!
Oh my God!
Twinsies!
Nice.
Twins!
It's okay, dragoons.
Sometimes we all just miss.
You can't miss this one, right?
You know, guys.
Literally, he's right there.
I was gonna say.
I swear to God.
If you guys missed that one, I'm...
Oh my God!
Oh!
Guys.
Guys, this is not looking so good for me right now.
This is actually not looking so good.
Oh my God.
Guys, I think he's better at this weapon than me.
Guys, I think he might be...
Oh my God.
Oh my god.
Oh, we did it.
We live.
Maybe he is.
Okay,
we're okay.
We're okay.
Oh my god.
I might have to go back and get buns later.
I... I don't know who I'm gonna live!
Oh no.
It's okay.
We have Kuan Yin!
Your strength, for a new path will show itself.
Jesus Christ.
It's okay.
We don't need it.
We don't need it, guys.
Guys, we don't need the buns.
Oh my god.
We did it.
Okay.
Oh my god.
We finally did his stupid fucking missions.
Okay.
We did it.
Okay, we're never gonna... I don't know if we're ever gonna do that one correctly.
That... that seems...
We might need to pay the intern, guys.
That's... that's a lot to ask for.
This launch successful charger ambush five times.
That... that just seems like a lot.
That... that really does.
Wait, I'm not even close.
Wait.
Wait, they're like all the way over there.
All right.
Don't worry.
I'll just bring...
I won't lose.
I can just bring Kuan Yin into this.
There we go.
All right, Kuan Yin, it's time.
Yes, because I have him now.
No, I definitely know I win.
Okay.
Is that it?
From Kuan Yin.
What do you mean, is that it?
What just happened?
That's fucking right.
Get over here!
I am the god of war!
And it's over.
Easy.
Is that it?
Wan-Yoon smash!
Yay!
Alright, nice.
Yeah.
Finally leveled up.
Yeah!
My horse is a little stronger!
Yeah, I finally made enough money for Pantone.
This grants a very small chance of receiving guard support when attacked.
That's not even me.
My dragoons die before they can do that.
We did it, guys.
We broke the formation.
The egg is ours!
I thought you served Cao Cao.
But now I see you in the camp of Liu Bei.
Liu Bei is my lord.
I see.
Liu Bei has an important role to play.
It is to eradicate Cao Cao.
And through him, the Han.
Oh my god, even like...
He must be protected.
Even like the peace people are like, I can fix it.
The heart of the sacred bird has grown still.
Wait, that wasn't you?
The young boy grew to be a man.
Yeah, that was you!
And over the years...
Why do I still see you?
The horse gave way to rage and hatred.
Wandering the boundless world, searching for the purest revenge.
Thirsting...
God, the incense goes hard!
Guys!
This incense is crazy!
And then, he came upon the people of the north.
But how could you possibly fathom what lies within his heart?
How can one who has forgotten everything possibly see into the mind of one who remembers everything?
The paths taken by the two of you shall never cross.
Now, there is only one way to reach the end.
Through your shared trust and mutual resolve.
Oh!
Cao Cao's eight gates formation was undeniably impressive.
But even so, it shattered like a vase before the might of our forces.
And more than anyone, we have you to thank for that, Shishu.
Oh my god, our first strategist!
Who would have thought?
Remarkable.
I wouldn't say that, my lord.
We actually had someone to thank for us, guys!
I just know a few things that are useful and make him back alive.
It's not just jocks!
We have an actual nerd!
The sleeping dragon?
Huh?
Or is it fledgling phoenix?
I can't decide.
My lord, I don't...
Hmm...
I thought if I dropped it casually into a conversation, I might trick you into confessing.
You think I'm the sleeping dragon?
Or the fledgling phoenix?
That's awkward.
That's so sad because none of the things...
Either of them did not do that.
They were not able to fix him.
I can tell this... I feel like this voice actor is Asian.
Because his pronunciation is actually so good.
Like...
The Fletchling Phoenix.
Yes, I suppose I have been known by that name.
And I'm sure Shishu has told you that I would be delighted to serve Lord Liu Bei.
But I'm afraid you were misled.
I've had my fill of generals and warlords.
For now, I'm leading a peaceful life.
Are you sure?
Don't you want to just, you know, die?
Randomly?
From, like, rocks?
Today, at least.
Would that be silly?
I truly believe that Lord Liu Bei is a great man.
Did that happen?
It would be an honor to serve him.
But let's just say, the timing isn't right.
No.
Right now, it's the quiet life for me.
But I hope you will be a friend and not mention this meeting to Lord Liu Bei.
If his lordship does ask about me, just tell him... tell him that the time isn't right.
Yeah, it's not his time to die yet, guys.
He's like...
I'll only join when it's, like, almost closer to my desk.
All right, assistance in Shu province.
Okay, let me... let's go grab...
Oh, never mind.
I was gonna say, is there, like, strong...
Yeah, no, the weapons suck.
All right.
Let us...
check if we have any friendship meters.
Oh, yeah!
Penton!
We leveled up your friendship, so will you wanna join me now?
Oh my god, it's still him.
Wait, but I leveled up your friendship.
Wait.
Where are you?
Oh, there he is.
I was like...
Wait, I thought you wanted to talk to...
Oh, there he is.
You are a wonder.
I was just hoping they'd come by sooner.
Here you are.
Do you think you can do me a favor?
I'm almost out of incense here.
I'd like to find me something high quality.
You have to find...
Okay, in the mountains.
Okay, it's, like, literally where I live.
Should be here, right?
Ah!
Yeah, there it is.
I recognize that.
All right, don't worry.
I got you the good shit.
These are the type of incense where I actually started seeing some crazy shit.
You don't see something like this every day.
A scent that is both difficult to describe and yet absolutely captivating.
A little bit like you.
This is wonderful, thank you.
Okay, nice.
Now we're extra friends.
Okay, I'm just gonna pay.
I can't.
I don't think I can do the ambush thing correctly.
Yay!
I'm sorry.
I had to pay the intern, guys.
He couldn't just do extra credit his whole life.
Oh, I got another one.
Now do you want to join LuBe?
You seem to be in rather high spirits.
Oh, yes.
Might you remember what I said to you before?
You are no one.
So you can yet be someone.
And you can be someone.
And yet you are still...
No one.
Oh, that's why they write me out of history.
Ring true to you?
Yeah.
Yeah, it does.
Because...
Ever since I killed LuBu and they, like, didn't even include me in the cutscene, I realized...
Ah, excellent.
I knew my faith in you was not ill-placed.
What you choose will, in turn...
be who you become.
That's...
what I wanted to say.
Right now, you're figuring out the path you should take.
It's plain to see on your face.
The path you ought to take.
Hmm.
Do you know something?
No, no.
I'm afraid I was giving advice beyond my station.
For...
What kind of person am I?
What kind of person...
will I become?
I have no right to speak of such things to others while I myself remain unsure.
I...
Well, it is a shameful thing.
Giga, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
For ambushes and charges.
Grind on skirmishes.
But this is not Pokemon.
I'm playing Mario on...
on Saturday.
We're gonna be grinding.
I might as...
We'll do that on Saturday anyway.
Don't they?
A further loss of face.
Now you're the one encouraging me.
Each time we interact, I walk away feeling energized anew.
Now, I've no excuse to avoid putting my all into the matters ahead.
It's okay, I can pay to win.
I'll...
I...
I have 50k.
It's fine.
It's...
That one...
That conversation felt, like, really useless.
Not gonna lie.
Show him what you're made of.
Alright.
Uh...
We gotta...
Okay.
He's right here.
Yeah.
I wish there was, like, another fast travel for this area.
Alright.
Let's increase our bond in turn.
That's our whole thing!
Yes, my lord.
Got it.
Lord Chaoyun.
I'll be more diligent.
I don't understand.
Do we...
Your force is, like, literally the Shu kingdom.
Special!
Oh, it's you.
So, you saw Lord Chaoyun and Lord Guan Yu reprimanding me just now, huh?
He's now officially taking me under his wing!
Though the novelty wore off in an instant.
But, uh...
This was my first time learning to fight for real.
After the yellow turbans were defeated, it took everything I had just to eek out a living as some second one bandit.
I miss...
I can't wait to do...
Um...
To do the Red Army.
But...
Because, like...
Because then, like, we could talk to Gan Ning.
Cause our first encounter with him was crazy.
He's a great teacher.
Good for you.
Yeah, he is a great teacher.
Well...
Yeah.
Anyway...
He's really demanding and shows me absolutely no mercy.
But...
I really do get nervous around Lord Chaoyun.
I remember when we first met...
Vividly.
Like, that guy literally sent us love letters.
In our first meeting.
I wanna know how far that goes.
I...
I was sure you wouldn't stop until you killed me.
I was ready to bid this world goodbye.
Did you ever sell things?
Oh, be open with him from now on.
I'd really like to, you know?
And it's not like Lord Chaoyun hates me or anything like that.
But...
It's just tough love.
Tend to stick with us longer than a stain on a hat.
Well, whatever helps me earn Lord Chaoyun's respect.
Let me just send the others away while we have this place for ourselves.
Just you and me.
Oh yeah, that...
That was our first encounter with him too.
You've made it all this way on your own without anyone backing you up.
Yeah.
So I take it that you must be like me then.
You're just another bandit that left that life behind...
No, I'm sort of better.
I'm definitely a lot better than you.
We both started at the bottom.
But his lordship already respects you that much?
Amazing.
Where do I even begin?
It's fine, really.
It's good to have someone like you around.
Everyone needs a rival.
But I'm not letting you have my place as his top underling without a fight.
But if you really want it, you're going to have to earn it.
But anyway, I really want to show Lord Chao Yun what I can do next time.
So let's get some training in.
You ready?
Number two?
What?
I was here first!
Okay, we're not...
Guys, I'm sorry, but we're not increasing our bond with him.
We're not increasing our bond with this guy.
And that's...
He will not join my harem.
He...
I'm not...
I'm not letting this guy into my harem.
Alright, let's see.
Deplete fortitude 200 times.
Withhold...
Continuous attacks using a...
Jesus...
I...
I don't understand.
I'm paying a win for Daoyun too.
You dare to think that he's better than me?
The other day, I told Lord Liu Bei about Zhuge Liang and Peng Tong.
I wanted to help his lordship in any way I could.
But now I'm worried they'll be angry at me for doing so.
You see, they're quite...
Well...
They're hermits.
Hermits?
Most men seize every opportunity to show off their talents and knowledge, however modest.
But those two are different.
Unless it's for a cause they care about, they prefer to keep their talents to themselves.
But...
I'm certain that if they got to know Lord Liu Bei, they gladly abandoned their hermit lifestyles to serve him and his cause.
It's not simply that Lord Liu Bei cares about us.
He wants to earn our trust.
To be the man we can turn to when we need help.
He's no sage, I admit that.
But if there was ever a man fit to rule the world and be loved by all of his subjects, it's Lord Liu Bei.
And if he is the man I believe him to be, then I have no doubt he would win Zhuge Liang and Peng Tong.
He's a really good politician, I would say that.
Lord Liu Bei?
I want to devote my life to his cause.
He's a really...
He's all talk and then he fails to do anything.
Dango, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki is number four, but never number one.
And they say this fellow is even sharper than Shishu.
Now that will be something to behold.
It certainly will.
But brother, are we certain that this is the right move?
Shishu's guidance has been invaluable.
It doesn't seem right.
I know, right?
We're like, I'm done playing with you now.
Poor.
He told me that Lord Zhuge Liang was the man I needed in order to accomplish my goals.
It would be an insult to ignore his counsel.
So, we will go together to find this great strategist and ask for his help.
We will be gone sometime.
The castle is in your hands while we are gone.
I get to have a castle!
Thank you.
I'm determined not to let this opportunity go to waste.
However, Liu Bei was in low spirits when he turned from his trip to see Zhuge Liang.
He had been told that he was away, and so they did not meet.
What?
Just go back!
You look so glum, brother.
He may not have been home, but we did leave him a message.
I am certain he'll come to us.
Just go back!
Rather than later.
You didn't wait?
After all Liu Bei himself went to him for a visit.
Xu Gu Liang's bound to return the favor after a gift like that.
I think you may be overselling the value of my presence.
Just wait for him!
Yeah!
He has to come back home!
Someday or later!
I'm sure what you could help us for not seeing us right away.
We just need to be patient and wait him out.
Yeah, camp out at his porch.
Go back!
That's it?
Go back in there!
Hello!
Are you depressed that we're replacing you?
Ah, there you are.
I was hoping to ask you something.
This is just an idle thought.
A hypothetical, if you will.
Imagine that you found out someone you cared for was in grave danger.
If it meant saving that person, would you be willing to sacrifice something very important to you?
The Shu Ormi can only have one strategist.
That's why we had to kill off the phoenix.
One time we had two.
And then he died.
You really are quite blunt, aren't you, my friend?
I suppose it's the men who can act decisively.
Regardless of the choice being made, that end up having a true effect on the world.
I suppose it just goes to show that I'm out of my depth.
The decision half made is no decision at all.
And indecisiveness only ever leads to regret.
Forgive me.
When you are around, it seems I can't help but pardon you with such matters.
Disregard everything I said.
I'm just like, huh?
Well, something seems off about him, yeah.
Yeah.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey, how long has it been since we left that message for Shu Ge Liang?
We hear anything yet?
No.
There's been no sign of a reply.
Perhaps, he still hasn't returned to the Hermitage.
Or perhaps, something has befallen him.
Brother, I think it might be a good idea to pay his home another visit.
Huh.
What is it, brother?
It's nothing.
Pay me no heat.
Let's do as Guan Yu suggests.
And visit Lord Shu Ge Liang's residence again.
I mean, that was my original plan.
He should have done that.
He should have just camped out on his porch.
I can tell that Jon Fei, voice actor, is not Asian.
Every time he says his name, it's different.
I don't understand it either.
Oh my God, he got ghosted again.
To avoid our brother.
He could be testing you.
Maybe he's just not interested.
Stop being so desperate.
By doing so.
I've had just about enough of this.
Whatever is going on, it's too early to tell for sure.
Let's give him a few more days, and then try again.
But, if Lord Shu Ge Liang really doesn't want to meet us, perhaps it would be better for all our saves.
Are we too desperate, guys?
Does it seem like we're a little too desperate?
Uh, well...
Uh...
If Shu Ge Liang had no interest in meeting you, he would have made that clear the first time you came.
Shishu?
Hey, Shishu.
What's wrong?
Why are you depressed?
No, I...
Forgive me, Lord Newbay.
I can't.
That is to say, I'm unable to continue to serve you.
I told you we can only have one for some reason!
We can't have more than...
What?
All I can say is, I have to leave for the sake of my elderly mother.
For your mother?
I see.
I can see in your eyes that if you had your way, you would rather stay here.
It's like a rule!
And if there's more than one, they kill them off!
Such female society is to be admired, especially in this day and age.
I won't try to change your mind.
Like, they just somehow die!
If there's anything you can do to help you and your family, name it.
If it is in my power, it will be done.
My lord...
Thank you for having given me the opportunity to serve you.
It was an honor beyond what my humble talents deserved.
I wish you luck in your future campaigns.
Alright, time for the third visit.
I'll be like, Hey, boo.
I got rid of the other guy.
I told you you're the one for me.
You got learned.
Oh, it's you.
I'll be leaving Xinyu soon.
I wanted to thank you for everything that you've done for me.
Why are you leaving?
I can tell you, but no one else.
Don't worry, it's our dirty little secret.
A short while ago, I received a message from one of Cao Cao's men.
It was an invitation to join his council.
He doesn't need more!
He's taking the monopoly!
What do you mean he wants more strategies?
That first blush, that sounds reassuring, doesn't it?
But I knew immediately what it really meant.
She is their hostage.
The battle of 6k.
The first two don't count.
Look, they give us a super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
But Lord Liu Bei would have tried to do something to help.
I can never have too much get poached.
Roster mania.
To serve Lord Liu Bei.
But that, it seems, is an aspiration.
A dream I must give up.
Perhaps this is the selfish choice.
But I agonized over it for days.
And now that I have made the decision, I cannot regret it.
Still, I would like to ask you for one last favor.
Will you look after Lord Liu Bei?
He is a great man.
And I truly believe he will unite the land.
Aw man, that's so sad.
Why did everyone believe in him?
Thank you.
Knowing that is great comfort to me.
Though my serving Cao Cao may make us enemies on the battlefield.
In my heart, we will always be friends.
Everyone wanted to fix him.
I hope you will continue to follow your true path.
Alright.
The third visit!
The third cutscene!
This is it.
We're gonna see my Oshi.
But he's a little ugly, okay guys?
I know he doesn't have his mustache.
So like, don't...
Don't judge him too hard.
Okay?
I'm telling you, I don't like it.
Why do we have to keep crawling back to him?
If it's a show of sincerity he wants, we've given him more than he could possibly need.
It's high time he showed us something in return.
You can stay here if you like.
But I am going to his hermitage.
He just looks wrong.
No, it's not that like...
It's like...
It's like how Liu Bei right now.
He looks like a...
A boy...
He looks like a guy in a...
Like in a...
Boy band right now.
It's just when he doesn't have a mustache.
It just...
It looks rye.
...
Back then, did you think we were so important that wise men would come running at our call?
Chishu said that if Lord Chuukoliong truly did not want to meet us, he would have said so the first time we came calling.
But he hasn't refused us yet, has he?
He wasn't there.
Lube is like, I can't go back.
He understands now.
He's like, guys, you don't understand.
We can't keep... I can't go back to Angabunga.
Guys, we need one brain cell at least.
He knows now.
He's got a taste of strategy.
Now he wants more.
You are a tenacious visitor.
I will give you that.
Alright.
Don't laugh, okay?
I...
Don't worry.
I will OSH you even when through the hard times.
Where is the beat?
Don't worry.
If you can't love him without the mustache, you don't deserve him.
Speak plainly.
Don't worry.
I'll still be there for you.
Even your dark times.
That's enough, Jonfei.
Fine.
I'll dispense with the formality.
We are there for his ups and downs.
Simply put, I have a mission and you can help me.
I've staked my life on a great endeavor.
God.
And will do anything to see it through.
But I can't keep by myself.
I am trying.
For my OSH.
In help.
A great endeavor.
In sickness and in health.
I'll build a world where people can live as they wish.
I see.
But again, that's not very specific.
For starters, what does it mean to live as you wish?
How different would this world of yours be?
After all, living as you wish isn't that hard.
Look at me.
I refuse to serve any man.
And here I am.
Living as I please in the mountains.
But you are the exception.
The reality is, few people have...
I think I would have liked him better.
If he didn't have, like, his attempt of trying to grow a beard.
Like, I...
I think if he had, like...
It's just weird.
I...
But I'll be strong for you.
I'll be strong.
If some men live as they please.
And some men don't.
Don't worry.
What is it that divides them?
I'm strong for you.
War, chaos, and anarchy keep men from their dreams.
A trite answer, I know, but true nonetheless.
Constant war leads to ruin and poverty.
And poverty narrows a man's world until it is a prison.
If we can offer a helping hand and lift up those in need.
It's sure to eventually lead to something better.
Yaaay!
Benevolence!
Surely there's no harm in trying.
So, you want to put an end to the turmoil across the land.
Is that your dream, Lord Liu Bei?
I...
Ugh...
I don't know.
Yes, I suppose so.
But it's not that simple.
If peace were merely the absence of turmoil, I could stop fighting Lord Cao Cao today and achieve it.
Brother...
But Lord Cao Cao only sees the distant future.
He doesn't see the destruction that he leaves in his wake.
You killed too!
I was in five battles!
All those lives cut down.
Sacrifices to his grander vision.
I see the righteousness of Lord Cao Cao's cause.
And I understand the sacrifices.
But even so, I cannot accept them.
You don't understand.
He kills for peace, guys.
Laugh if you want.
For the good of the people.
I know that what I'm saying seems like the selfish desires of a child.
Hmm...
Maybe so.
But still...
If you were determined to achieve such things with your own hands...
Then I wouldn't call it...
Selfishness.
I'd call it...
Purpose.
Assumingly, he doesn't Lupe...
Okay, we don't know that, guys.
I'm pretty sure at least, like, one army has done that.
Like, Lupe cannot control all of them.
He uses the sword to an eternal.
And the rule of reason to impose peace.
It's the most obvious path.
Logical and clear-sighted.
Oh no, he wants to fix him.
But inevitably, it demands many sacrifices.
See, I told you.
Everyone just wants to fix him.
The way is the way of a king.
You put the people first, and refuse to abandon anyone along the way.
But it is also foolishness.
A fantasy woven out of clouds and good intentions.
No wonder you don't know how to go about it.
Let him brew with me.
Yes.
How can I make your reality?
How?
By bringing the entire land under your rule.
Then, and only then, can you shape it into the world you desire.
And... how do I do that?
The Long Zong plan.
Divide and conquer.
Drive South South.
Risk.
And make this a three-sided war.
Three kingdoms!
I will show you how...
Iffy!
And that's how the three kingdoms can be!
Where's Lord Liu Bei?
Is he with Lord Juga Liang again?
Yes.
Ever since he brought Lord Chu Gu Liang back here.
They've been holed up together.
Talking day and night.
Okay, Guan Yu is definitely not, not Asian voice actor.
For sure.
He finally found water.
All his vague ideas for a better world.
Are being hammered into solid plans.
I don't think I've ever seen our brother look happier.
That's all well...
That's a new one, yeah.
What exactly are they talking about every day?
Nah, I don't like it.
Not one bit.
Alright, you know the best part about being a doughkeeper?
Nobody butchers my name anymore.
That's...
I'm not sure I like it either.
But as much as we'd like to...
You cannot help us.
We're doing more than we can have.
We don't know what advice this Lord Chu Gu Liang is giving our brother.
Or what plans they're hatching.
All we can do is watch and wait.
I remember Ximie.
And how Lord Xu Su seemed to control the battle at will.
I've never seen anything like it.
Now if a man as smart as him says Lord Chu Gu Liang is even better, then who am I to deny it?
Our army had everything but the sharp-minded council needed to guide us.
If Lord Liu Bei has found the missing piece in this military strategist, there'll be nothing to stop him from achieving the unmagical...
Oh my god, we're actually using our brains now.
I agree.
I thought you would.
They say that one great strategist is worth 10 million men on the battlefield.
Yeah, and Cao Cao has like 20 of them.
Even as a humble warrior, it will be a thrill to fight under a military...
We have a brain!
How will Lord Xu Ga Liang use me?
What will my role be?
I can't wait to find out.
I told you guys, right?
The story?
Before then?
Oh my god, no.
No!
She's back!
It's you!
How long has it been?
No!
Are you not satisfied with the doll?
No way!
Wait, that's good.
I like that answer.
You see me?
We studied well.
I heard you I'd become a vassal of Lord Liu Bei.
So I thought I'd take the opportunity to come see you again.
The fact is, I recently entered Lord Liu Bei's service myself.
Wait, what?
Which makes us allies and comrades.
How did you get in here?
Oh, no.
Did she marry him already?
No!
She married him!
How did that happen?
You see.
Lord Shuga Liang wishes to speak with you.
He wants to talk to you about plans for the next battle.
We have sent out scouts, but so far there have been no reports of any approaching armies.
I'm so sad.
He saw the doll.
I hope he doesn't think other reasons.
I hope he didn't see the doll, guys.
I don't want there to be any misunderstandings.
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm convinced that the kingdom shattered into three because everyone was such a freak.
I have not read a thousand year old romance.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Whoa!
Hold on!
Slow down there!
Uh, what's this next battle?
Who's gonna be attacking?
And when?
Hmm.
Huh.
Forgive me.
I left out some key information.
Cao Cao's forces will soon march against us.
But we routed Cao Cao's army some time ago.
And we haven't seen any sign of attack from them since.
What makes you think they're coming now?
Huh.
Me, my wife, and her wooden doll of an unnamed hero.
Giga, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's inevitable.
He is his natural enemy.
Being fought off once will not be enough to break their spirit.
They will come again for the kill.
So long as the opportunity remains.
Taking into account their losses in the last battle, I believe they should be more or less ready to make their move.
Are you sure?
That would be remarkably persistent of them.
I doubt they'll give up.
Not until you kneel before Cao Cao.
They've eliminated the remnants of Yuan Shao's forces, and the situation in Hubei has stabilized.
There is little reason for them to hold back.
Hmm.
So Lord Chu Gu Leon, how might we defeat Cao Cao's forces?
We establish a position at Boangpo to defend against the enemy.
It is complex terrain with natural obstacles.
Perfect for fire traps and ambushes to confuse their advance.
Traps?
Those are for pussies!
It is hard to believe a trick...
A trick!
Well, I'm interested.
Let's see how far our master strategist can turn things around for us.
Agreed.
By the way, I was wondering about something.
Who are you?
This is plus one.
Forgive me for the lack of introduction.
No!
This is my wife.
What?
It is a pleasure to meet you.
I will be serving Lord Liu Bei alongside my husband.
No!
He's not single!
Guys!
It's okay.
Liu Bu wasn't single either.
But we got in.
We can do it again.
We did.
Come to think of the lady you will be here when we heard.
The pleasure is ours, Lady Yue Ying.
Zhao Yun.
You're okay with this?
Hey!
I know you've got something to say about all this.
Don't you?
Sorry.
After finding out that she's his wife now.
I'm sad.
Not really.
I will do whatever I can to assist my husband and everyone here.
We appreciate it.
I, for one, am glad to have another ally we can depend upon.
Okay, but like, she has my doll.
So like, he knows!
He knows!
He hasn't said anything about it!
Alright, let's see.
I don't know what objectives I have to do anyway.
Is there anyone that I've really needed?
Not really.
Okay, I wanna...
Let's see.
Let's see if there's any, like, really...
Is there a better weapon?
Or is that the best one?
I just wanna be sure.
Yeah, that is the best one.
Alright, oh yeah.
So that's how...
I told you guys this, right?
For like, my name?
Back then?
I wanted to be called something else.
Because...
When they gave me that name, I...
My...
My literally number one complaint...
Was that...
People are not gonna be able to pronounce it correctly.
And then...
But they were like...
Oh!
But...
This name we give you...
It has zero Google searches.
So it'll be good for discoverability.
So I was like...
I had to be...
I had to have that name.
I was like...
Can I be this name?
So it's easier to pronounce?
And they're like...
No.
Shall we start?
Alright.
Let's go.
We are now blessed with the presence of the sleeping dragon himself.
I think...
Guys, I wouldn't have picked a name that I couldn't pronounce.
Guys.
Next scene.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You were one of those people who couldn't pronounce it.
Welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha.
I think Chikwotlan should be the one to lead this meeting.
As you wish, Lord Lupe.
Now...
Allow me to start by explaining our situation.
Chow Chow has wiped out the House of Yuan.
And his large army has closed in on Jin Province.
Ha ha ha.
To confront this threat, we have positioned our forces in Bo Heng Po.
They are led by Chow Chow Dun, one of Chow Chow's most trusted generals.
Defeating him will rob them of their commander.
And they will surely flee.
Conversely, if we lose Lord Lupe, we will suffer the same fate.
We must do all our power to protect him in this battle.
Now that I have explained the situation, I will lay out our plan for engaging Chow Chow's forces.
The conditions of this battle are clearly not in our favor.
We are numbered and our formation leaves much to be desired.
What?
You chose this battlefield and our formation?
Now you're saying we're at a disadvantage?
Patience, Zhang Fei.
Lord Zhugot Lun isn't finished.
I understand your concern.
Our disadvantage is playing the C.
But that is precisely what makes our plans so unpredictable.
Now, the enemy's main force is concentrated in the center of the battlefield.
We eliminate them all in one final swoop.
Fire should do the trick.
After we let their momentum bring them into range, we unleash a fire attack.
To do this, we must hold strong against their assault long enough for the chance to present itself.
When it's time, our forces will pull back.
Lord Zhou Khan and Yunying will keep the enemy at bay in the north itself.
And Lord Zhao Yun should be the one to lead our central forces.
Lead it to me.
I'll run right around the outside of the battlefield and hit them from behind.
I'll lead our archers.
We can suppress their advance with volleys from high ground.
The task before me may be difficult, but it's also an opportunity to prove my worth.
I'll not fail you in this fight.
While our forces are holding off the enemy advance, we need Lord Guan Yun and Zhang Fei to prepare the fire attack.
Uh...
Guan Yun should go north and capture the base in the mountains.
Zhang Fei will head south to take the forest base there.
Wait, then... Wait, are they not coming with me?
Lord Zhao Yun will pull his forces back.
And when the enemy's front line moves forward in pursuit, we'll launch fire arrows from each base.
This is really complicated.
I missed my Ungabunga strategy.
I...
Yes, I'm just just going straight in.
Their truce will be engulfed in flames and lose their will to fight.
This is when we turn the tide.
Your long, fancy speech hasn't convinced me that any of this is going...
Oh, I'm Zhang Fei right now.
That's bad.
If I'm Zhang Fei, that's really bad.
I...
If I'm thinking like him.
I've placed my trust in the wisdom of our strategist.
If you believe me, please do what you can to help Zhugut learn.
Damn it, that's not fair, brother.
When you put it that way, I guess I have no choice.
I'm counting on the rest of you as well.
We'll carry out Zhugut learn's plan and claim victory in Bo Wen Po.
Alright.
Wait, I know I can go pick Guanyu.
Wait, where was he supposed to go?
Guys.
I already forgot.
Where was he supposed to go, guys?
Oh, this is bad.
I don't remember.
Okay, I still did not like the battle cry.
That shit takes too long to process.
Let's grab something else.
A spirit wave.
Okay, we'll grab spirit wave.
Alright, he did...
He talked so much that I already forgot which way.
North base.
Okay, north base.
But yeah, I thought it was funny, like a little piece of lore.
Because people thought...
They're like...
Why did she pick that name if she can't even pronounce it?
I didn't.
Like...
My complaint was that...
Nobody could pronounce...
I knew no one could pronounce that name.
I...
I was always like...
Every time I met somebody new, no one could pronounce that name correctly.
I had so many different mispronunciations of that name.
Because no one could pronounce it correctly.
Like...
You could nearly make a clip of the amount of times people have mispronounced it.
Every time I met someone new, it was different every time.
Our central forces will block the enemy advance.
Meanwhile...
Okay, where was that?
That's the base up top, right?
It was really funny, though.
It was...
I would admit, it was funny.
Yeah, I know which base it is.
Don't worry, I figured it out.
Jesus Christ!
Where...
Where is that boss?
Just as Lord Chuguliong said.
Archers, let your arrows fill the sky.
Oh my god!
They're so strong!
Don't expect an ambush here.
It won't last long with these arrows raining down on us.
Bro!
Just let me hit you!
Do not waste!
Oh my...
Let me hit you!
Let's march!
With all my might...
Oh!
No!
Okay.
That's fine.
Jesus Christ.
It was so...
Oh my god!
He has so much HP!
Heeeeh!
Whoah!
Why do you have so much HP?
Heeeeh!
I'm just trying to get past this area!
Not so dead poor.
Thank you for the super chat.
How's this?
Oh, table's turned.
Alright, get over here.
Nice.
Oh, thank god I had that saved up.
I'm just saving up my thing, just in case.
Okay, nice.
He's almost dead, so I can rush up to that north base, too.
Please!
Die!
Here we go.
Nice.
Alright, now we can do the thing you were supposed to do, Guanyin, before I kidnapped you.
Okay, let's do your thing that you were supposed to do, like, 20 years ago.
Oh no, Jonfei has already got the base.
Whoops.
Oh no.
Begin the advance.
Oh no!
No!
We were supposed to get this base earlier!
We have to capture the base in the forest.
Bring him down.
All of this is a bit too precise for my liking.
Move forward!
Okay.
There we go, there we go.
There, I got it, I got it.
Oh wait, I didn't get it yet.
Don't worry, we're almost got it.
And do my part!
Oh wait, I'll get the duel.
I accept your challenge.
I'll show no mercy.
Wait, did I got the wrong base?
Oh no.
Oh my god!
What?!
Oh my god, this guy is so good.
Easy.
Oh, no wait, I got it!
I got the block!
There you go.
This should be it.
This should be it!
Which...
Which base was I supposed to take?
I got the right one, right?
Or is it the one in the top right?
Guys, I was not listening.
Which base was I supposed...
Oh my god, I got the wrong base.
Oh my god.
I'm so sorry.
Sorry.
I... I got the wrong one.
Alright.
Sorry, give me a sec.
Give me a sec.
I got the wrong one.
Wait, which one?
Is it like... the top, top left?
Is it that one?
The top, top left one?
Or is it the... the one below it?
Oh my god.
God, whoops.
I... I'm sorry.
I wasn't listening to Kotlin.
I'm sorry.
I was absolutely not listening.
I know you had a really... Wait.
Oh my god.
The one word.
There's a sword.
Wait, you're so right.
The one that has the sword.
Oh my god.
I can't read that.
I'm sorry.
I failed the task.
I got the wrong one.
Don't worry.
I'm here now.
I figured it out.
I just... I just... I just... I don't know.
It was a pretty symbol.
But like, in my mind... I didn't think that symbol meant anything.
I... I don't know why.
I thought that symbol didn't mean anything.
I just look pretty.
The enemy officer has been defeated.
Time to act.
My bad.
Wait, guys.
Give me a sec.
I'll help out the other lieutenant soon.
I can't do this one.
Alright, I did it.
This terror attack is ours.
Our allies aren't yet ready.
You must wait for the right moment.
The enemy is on the back foot.
Soldiers, this is it.
Let us rip into their lives.
Start the advance.
Take this.
Okay.
The center of their formation looks to be unraveling.
Concentrate our troops there.
There we go.
I did it!
So, the trap is ready.
The time has come to set the plan into motion.
Don't worry.
We have the strong muscle.
I am certain you will see it done.
Boom!
Five booms!
The enemy officer has been defeated.
Alright.
Nice.
And then we can do a little twat!
That's right!
Oh, shit!
Oh!
Whoa!
Nice.
Wait, that's a nut!
Oh my god!
He did more than that?
But you don't have an actual name!
How do you have such a strong attack?
Oh my god.
It's okay.
I'm not scared.
I can take him!
Oh nice!
Okay, I killed him before he did his fancy thing!
It is just as Lord Chuga Leon said.
It will be my job to make sure this plan works.
Okay, what else are we missing in this plan?
I did my job.
I was late, but I did my job.
I was late, but it still worked.
Oh nice, it's doing it.
Nice!
Fire!
Nice.
Oh my god, they're all like so weak now.
That's actually so good for me.
Oh my god, they're all so weak.
They're like, you've been using strategy?
What is this?
This is a whole new world.
They're not used to it.
They're like, they're smart now?
We've got comrades currently engaged.
Let's go give them our support.
Boom.
The enemy officer has been defeated.
Okay, we killed everybody.
That's it.
Oh wait, no.
I forgot this guy.
The most important one.
Get out of here.
You have no HP now.
We use fire!
The enemy officer has been defeated.
There is the enemy officer.
They have brains now.
No!
Charge them head on and push into their main camp.
Let's go.
All right, we'll go this way.
This way's faster.
What an incredible plan.
Ambitious and yet exact.
Chigulian is as talented as Liu Bei believes in to be.
Sorry.
It's so...
It's so funny.
I'm trying to pronounce his name.
It's different every time.
Don't worry, Chigutland.
I don't know how it feels.
I got you in please.
All right, open the door.
All right, nice.
We do a twirl!
Twirl!
Ultra twirl!
Slash!
Oh my god, look at our combo!
Oh my god, it's like we're like meant to be, Guan Yun!
That was such a good combo!
Okay, nice.
All right, I have more for it.
Oh my god, we're just like running in.
Oh my god, finally!
Finally!
A successful charge!
Oh my god, I completed an actual training!
Where are we?
You call that an officer?
All right, this is where the main guy is.
I should just go straight in.
What the fuck am I doing?
How do I get there?
Like this way?
Oh, it's this way.
Yeah, what am I doing?
Why am I just like letting...
Go straight in.
That's right.
That's right!
I'm coming in!
Where are you?
There we go.
That's right!
Get over here!
I'm not done with you!
Wait, where did you go?
Where are you?
Where did I miss?
Where is he?
Oh, you think it's over?
That's right!
It's not over!
Wait, but where is he?
Hey, where is he?
Oh, there he is!
I lost him!
I actually lost him!
Get over here!
It's time!
I will twirl forever!
Domain Expansion!
Boom!
Easy!
Twirl Maxing!
Oh my god!
His one strike traveled all the way here!
The God of War has done it again!
Oh wait, I can hold this!
I didn't realize I can hold this attack!
This will likely slow down South-South forces!
So we can plan our defense of Jing province in the meantime!
I learned something new today!
I could actually hold my attack, guys!
Yay!
Level 25!
Yeah, I was not holding it the entire time!
I don't know if you guys noticed that!
Was that obvious?
Is this what it's like to use strategy?
If we were by ourselves, we would have been well on our way to retreat!
But now...
Oh my god!
I hope I was able to show some of what I am capable of!
You did!
Strategy?
I can now see why brother regards you so highly!
Yes!
Well...
Fine!
I'll consider you on par with Shishu!
No!
That is more than I could ask for!
I wish to build good relations with all of you here!
A strategist acts as the mind of an army!
But...
We are powerless...
Without capable limbs!
And warriors such as you...
Who have assisted Lord Liu Bei for so long...
Are a necessary part of the plans I've laid towards our ultimate victory!
Now...
Do excuse me...
I must see to some post-battle matters!
Well...
What is he gonna do?
You know...
He may be a schemer...
By the way...
He flatters people...
Might be a bit like brother...
Uh...
But only a tiny bit...
Wait!
Why is he leaving?
Why don't you wanna...
Why are you leaving?
Sir?
Why are you leaving me?
I thought we had something!
We did your strategy!
Have you heard?
They say there's a dragon living...
We did his strategy and then he leaves?!
There is something we must tell you...
We have heard that Lord Liu Bei fell ill a few days ago...
His condition appears to be quite serious...
Honey, why do you have us?
I mean...
He is getting pretty old...
Born brothers!
They say he doesn't have a lot of time...
He found the doll and then it felt awkward...
Having me in the same room...
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Another storm will be brewing once Liu Biao is gone...
And just when we found a place to call home to...
Indeed...
The circumstances are similar to when Lord Tao Chin...
Asked brother to be his successor...
Back then...
He refused the offer of governorship...
Which eventually led to Louis Bu taking over Shu Province...
But now...
That Lord Chugu Lian is our strategist...
I wonder...
If brother's answer will be different this time around...
So...
You wish for me to take over as Jing's leader?
Cao Cao currently controls the entirety of Hebei...
And will continue to focus on invading Jing...
Should he succeed...
No one in the land will have the strength to oppose him...
Now that Lord Liu Biao has fallen ill...
You may be the only one who can defend the province from Cao Cao, my lord...
Given the circumstances...
Perhaps I should be more blunt...
Taking Jing is a way for us to put a stop to Cao Cao's advance...
But at the same time...
It will be a first step toward a greater goal...
Once Jing is under our control...
Let us go on and obtain Yi...
Oh my gosh...
We're doing so much...
Making it particularly important...
Liu Zhang...
Who currently rules Yi...
Slow down!
Like, this is our first time!
We never had a strategist before!
My lord...
If you were to decide to rule both Yi and Jing...
The common folk would accept it with open arms...
Not used to it!
By taking both provinces...
And allying ourselves with Su and Chuan...
Who controls Jiang Dong...
Our factions...
Trying to understand his strategy!
He's like...
I never see you're this quiet...
I... I'm trying to understand!
That will require me to stand up against Lord Cao Cao.
I've never...
I've...
I joined the Angabunga army to not think!
Lord Cao Cao, Lord Sun Quan...
And myself sharing power...
Splitting the realm into three...
But I cannot and will not steal Jing away from the rightful successor of Lord Liu Biao...
Not when he has treated us so well...
Instead, we ought to support him while he is ill...
I would be willing to take over the administration of the province...
But...
Taking Jing for myself would not be my way...
That is but a betrayal of trust...
And it is not something I wish to do...
Of course...
Then...
I will not force this upon you...
You aren't going to attempt to convince me?
I was sure you were going to say as much from the beginning...
However...
This will limit our options...
It may make our path...
Much more arduous...
I do not care...
There cannot be anything more difficult than betraying my own principles...
I understand...
Goddamn stupid benevolence...
Fool...
You can tell that Jukotlen is like...
I hope...
I hate you...
He's like...
Maybe he's not fixable...
His son went on to succeed him...
Leaving Lu Bei with the task of guiding the young leader...
Meanwhile...
Tata was personally leading his great army...
Towards Jing province...
You know...
This might be weird for me to say...
But...
I'm actually glad that Liu Song took over for Liu Biao...
Why are you glad?
Well...
Xiu Gu Lian...
Tried to talk brother into succeeding Liu Biao...
But...
He said no...
Is that bad?
It just goes to show that he's still the same man as ever...
One who sticks to his principles...
Oh my god, that's what we're losing!
We might have talked about this before...
But...
You know how our responsibilities have changed a lot...
Right?
Hmm...
But brother...
His heart hasn't changed since the very beginning...
His decision made that obvious...
That's the kind of man I wanna support...
He has...
Charisma...
Something I suppose every...
He only has Charisma!
That's his own issue!
That's all he has!
He needs to be careful to maintain it...
Everybody wants to fix him!
Even though we may not have a big plan in mind...
My brother or Xiu Gu Lian...
Let's keep moving forward...
Through sheer grit...
And effort...
Alright...
I'll do what I can...
Humble as ever, huh?
But I know you are the kind of guy who gets stuff...
Done...
Right then!
Let's go give that bastard, Tau Tau, something to sweat about!
Liu Bei and his sworn brothers fight...
Alright...
Wait...
There's so many people that wants to talk to...
I'm so popular!
There's so many people that wants to talk to me!
Hello?
Hey!
Lord Guan Yu!
Training up?
Yes!
And from the looks of it...
You've been doing likewise...
I want to eat lasagna tonight...
I don't know...
I feel like it's a lasagna day...
So I figured I would do what I can...
While I can...
Sorry, I came out of nowhere...
I just...
I just had a craving for lasagna for some reason...
Well, that is a good start...
What if I order lasagna?
You know, I'm...
Okay, I'm gonna be like...
I'm gonna order lasagna right now...
I'm gonna be...
Alright, sorry...
I need to use my phone to order lasagna...
We cannot let that happen...
Joe Zhang...
Spar with me for a round...
Oh...
Seriously?
Absolutely!
Oh my god...
I get to Spar with my senpai?
Wait, what?
That's it?
I thought...
What?
Okay, I thought I had like...
More purpose in this story...
I thought, you know...
I had a bigger purpose there...
Okay, lasagna...
What the best option would have been...
I just like...
Watched...
Another person's...
Another person's like...
Route...
It...
Didn't include me...
With a massive army advancing toward us...
Would that not have been the best option?
I cannot see Lord Liu Song being up for a fight...
Where's my lasagna?
Alright...
You might be right...
Sorry, I wasn't...
I didn't say what...
I didn't say what Daoyun was saying...
But...
He must be right...
Still...
I am also somewhat glad that things have gone this way...
Lord Liu Bei is a man who brings honor to these lands...
That is why so many are willing to follow him...
For me...
It was witnessing how he risks his life to see justice done that won my loyalty...
If he had changed his ways and take a Jing from Lord Liu Song...
Perhaps his followers would have deserted him...
Such a choice could have ruined all that he's built up over the years...
But whatever the case...
It is our duty as his retainers to keep him safe...
No matter how formidable our adversary...
Okay, the last time we had...
We...
We let him be his guard...
He like failed...
So I don't know...
Like he's clearly not doing his job very well though...
I don't trust him...
I want to order a caprese salad too...
I want to be fancy...
Why are you here?
Lord Liu Bei...
You have come to call for our surrender, have you not?
Huh?
As a messenger of Cao Cao...
I see you have not changed...
Wait, he's blue now!
You'll see through it all...
Even without a word...
Lord Liu Song has already surrendered to Cao Cao's forces...
What?
He supposedly promised that he would hand you over...
No...
Treaty!
I'mma five your mom!
The moment Lord Liu Song switches the lines...
You lost...
And while this may be unexpected...
Coming from your enemy's messenger...
Lord Liu Bei...
I beg of you...
You must escape...
You will have more opportunities...
As long as you stay alive...
Okay, I got my lasagna...
And my caprese salad...
Although...
That is not to say...
It is impossible to defend...
I'm...
I know where your mom lives...
While fending off...
Cao Cao's army...
You're saying there's a way?
Indeed...
We can use the people of Xinyu as decoys...
To lure the enemy forces into the castle...
There...
We crush them...
That will not do...
By employing such tactics...
We will be robbing the people of Xinyu...
Of the ability to decide their own fates...
Which is why I said that Xinyu is correct...
I know your mom's bed...
Very well...
See you later...
Son...
I can winy buddy...
Let's do that...
I know...
Why is he saying all that?
When Cao Cao's strategist is literally just standing there...
He's just like...
Wait...
So what are you guys gonna do again?
I wish to be with you in spirit...
Do not provide strategies to him...
Not now...
Or ever...
I might not be able to advise you directly...
Bro...
Wouldn't he like...
Be suspicious about that?
No...
Any subterfuge of that kind would only be a detriment...
Instead...
Would you be willing to help us plan our next move?
You want me...
To help you plan?
Abandoning the castle is worth...
I feel like...
Knowing that...
He worked with Lu Bei...
He should have like...
An actual guard with him...
Some sort of strategy...
To avoid this situation...
I am certain...
That we can make that strategy...
Even better...
Like...
They know that...
He's like...
Really close with Lu Bei...
Why did they not send him a guard?
Cao Cao will not notice...
You really haven't changed...
Have you?
Fine...
A small contribution it shall be...
I trust you shall utilize it...
To aid Lord Lu Bei's cause...
Yeah...
I feel like that's weird...
I...
I feel like you would bring...
Like...
Someone to look after him...
To make sure he's not gonna like...
Betray you...
I'm gonna check my super chats...
Nobody...
Thank you for the super chat...
Thank you...
Not Doki...
Can you guess who this is from?
I don't suppose so...
I'm no one special...
Just one of the soldiers...
You're always saving...
These days...
Even the commoners...
Are aware of the hardship...
Lord Lu Bei is...
Facing...
He may even be driven...
Out of his current territory...
Which is why...
Many of us have already made the decision...
To follow him...
Should that occur...
But the reason I am writing all of this...
To you...
Is that I believe...
You will help us in the end...
If for some reason...
I am no longer able to send letters to thank you...
I have already instructed a friend...
To write them on my behalf...
Please take care of yourself...
And now and forever...
You will always have my admiration...
Yay...
Thank you...
You old dragon...
Alright...
Sushu...
I wanna spend a moment with you...
One last time...
Whoa...
You come to the location written at the end of this letter?
I know that I have no right...
To be making requests like this...
But even so...
Banking is...
Oh my god...
He likes to beg...
Please...
Give me a chance...
To make my feelings clear...
Whoa...
Okay, buddy...
I guess we see him...
Tonight...
Oh, he's right outside my door...
Okay, hi...
He was literally right outside my door...
You weren't annoyed...
By...
Me sending a message...
But...
I'm unable to visit you now...
This...
Is...
The only option...
And...
I'm grateful you've come...
Well...
Don't worry about it...
I'm glad you seem to be well...
You're too kind to me...
After all...
I may very well become your enemy...
I knew this the moment...
I chose to serve Lord Cao Cao...
But...
It's...
Difficult to admit as much...
Yeah, I mean...
Thank you for the super chat...
Thank you...
Don't you lost some sub...
To support the emergency...
Honey Pop 2 stream...
Now...
It's...
Oh, you should come back...
I truly would...
If I could...
Also, thank you so much for the raid...
I really appreciate it...
My heart is resolved on this matter...
I made the decision after thinking carefully...
About how I would protect all I hold dear...
Weighed against the things...
I could not bear to lose...
My idealism is...
Trivial...
Besides...
Lord Liu Bei has gained a great ally...
Zhuge Liang is a once in a generation genius...
You're sad...
You're our wingman!
You're right...
You sound sad...
But...
Thank you...
For thinking about me...
Why are you sad?
Do you remember...
I told you...
I can be sad...
To be myself around you...
Yeah?
A lot of them say that to me...
So today...
I wanted to make sure...
To confirm...
That I had made the correct decision...
Now kiss...
And now...
Here before the one I admire so deeply...
Whoa!
Would you mind if I ended with a selfish request?
What's the...
Whoa!
I want you...
To remember...
That you met a good-natured...
Naive...
Man...
Called...
Shishu...
Though the good times were brief...
And we parted ways in the end...
Remember that I strove alongside you...
And...
More to your very selfish...
Desire?
Uh...
Why was there a pause after I want you...
Whoa!
And one day...
Even if we've become enemies...
He's gonna remember me for the rest of his life, guys...
I leave that type of impact...
I may not be a person of great talent...
Or skill...
But my resolve in this...
Is unmatched...
Bye!
Wait, no!
No!
We could do more!
Do you have any other requests you would like to make?
I'm all prepared and ready to go...
I think I'm getting used to abandoning castles and running away...
I am sorry...
My stubbornness just keeps causing more trouble...
He was just too shy to ask...
You will not worry, brother...
All we need to do is survive...
Just like we've always done...
We will protect you...
Right...
We will protect you and your family with every bit of our strength...
Also, guys...
I just realized...
I suppose I can't...
How close are we...
To finishing this game...
Especially with my brothers...
I think I was a little too overcome...
Because I know...
We have the battle of QB...
In...
For the Shu Kingdom...
But like...
It feels like we're not close to it...
Okay, we have three more battles...
I was gonna say...
I feel like we're not close to the battle of QB yet...
Like...
Ha ha ha ha ha...
My lord...
I'm grateful to see you...
Some of the peasants here...
Escaped from Cao Cao's invading forces...
Oh...
Others...
Barred from their castle...
Look...
There's the children...
They've endured much...
Difficulty...
They've nowhere else to turn...
We humbly ask for your guidance...
Don't worry, I'm here now...
Benevolence...
Now clap...
Bringing them along...
Would...
Inevitably...
Slow our march's pace...
I know we brought...
I know in the books...
We brought them along...
Cao Cao's forces are unlikely...
To raise a hand to peasants...
Who have shown no resistance...
Hmm...
Zhuge Liang...
The Longzong plan required...
The acquisition of Jing province...
I have a speech to make...
And now...
I have taken Jing province...
It would be truly strange...
To suggest relinquishing it now...
My apologies...
Oh my god...
Is he proud of me...
Or disappointed?
I can't tell...
Like I...
Lupe does so much of both...
Indeed...
A kingdom is more than land...
It is those who call it home...
Who are truly vital...
And you have indeed...
Taken Jing province...
Hehehehe...
So...
Let us combine our abilities...
To overcome hardship...
And discover...
The way forward...
To your kingdom...
Lord Liu...
Oh my god...
My shoe kingdom...
Yes...
Finally...
I can stop running away...
Forgive me everyone...
I...
Wish for them to accompany us...
That...
Is my desire...
Finally...
We have a home...
Lupe's history of kindness...
Was repaid...
As soldiers and peasants alike...
Joined his fleeing flock...
Their flight to the south...
Was a slow one...
And soon they found themselves...
Able to hear...
The stomping feet...
Of Cao Cao's forces...
Catching up to them...
Our advance is far too slow...
We need to put some distance...
Between us and Cao Cao's forces...
But at this rate...
They'll catch up to us...
The cause...
Is fairly obvious...
I cannot just leave...
Those who came to me...
Seeking help...
Yes...
I understand that...
Yeah, this is the famous retweet...
And it is my job...
To do something about...
Our current predicament...
Well said...
I will now head to Jiangxia...
The governor there...
Lord Liu Qi...
Owes me a favor...
It's time for...
Jiangfei...
To guard the bridge...
This is the bridge scene...
Right?
From Jiangfei?
Just what kind of scheme...
Did you pull?
Oh...
It was nothing really...
Lord Guan Yu...
I would like you to...
Accompany me to Jiangxia...
See, I'm not a fake fan...
I played all the Dynasty Warriors...
And return to...
And I will continue playing more...
Hehehehe...
Zhao Fei...
Zhao Yun...
Take care of Liu Bei...
Until I return...
They can remake this game...
200 times...
And I'll still buy it...
With my life...
Thank you...
All of you...
My life is in your hands...
God's strongest consumer...
Hehehehe...
I will play the same story...
Over and over again...
Hehehehe...
There you are...
Zuluan...
I see you are still with Liu Bei...
Assisting him in his struggle to stop Cao Cao...
That is good...
The incense calls for me...
Going on...
What is Liu Bei...
Trying to do...
By taking this many commoners with him...
As he flees...
Trying to follow his ideas...
What...
Do you mean that he would risk the lives of the people...
For something so abstract?
Whatever his reason is...
This will most likely end in a great deal of casualties...
We've killed so many!
Why would we not run and leave the people behind?
If we leave them behind then she'll all still die!
And why would they...
Not try to leave Liu Bei?
This many individuals displaying such loyalty to one man...
At the risk of their own lives...
I don't believe Cao Cao would...
Like...
I don't believe Cao Cao would like...
Be nice to the peasants too...
I don't believe it...
It...
This proves that...
I believe he'll become a hero...
I say as I'm in denial...
What?
Spreading his beliefs...
And dragging his people into war...
Huh...
I suppose that is befitting of what people usually call...
A hero...
And as with all so-called heroes...
Wherever Liu Bei goes...
Destruction and violence follow...
No matter the words they use to glorify their cause...
In the end...
Each of them sacrifices people for their goals...
And judging from how dire this current situation is...
Perhaps he...
No he is...
I feel like a lot of these generals and strategists...
Would like...
Have better lives...
If they didn't follow Liu Bei...
What will Liu Bei do now?
Cling on to his conviction...
Like it's so sad...
Jukot Lun...
Had his peak in...
The battle of Red Cliff...
And then everything went downhill...
And every strategy he had...
Was just failing...
Over...
And over...
And over again...
It was so sad...
I'll never...
I would never...
Sorry...
I...
I didn't mean that...
You're always a genius...
Maoshi...
I...
I was just telling them a lie...
Why don't you rest your wings...
A lot longer...
I want you to chase down the enemy quickly...
Will you do it?
Wait, what?
Is it this?
Carry out requests to chase down...
Alright, I'm gonna use the bathroom...
Real quick...
I'll be right back guys...
I got more water...
Sajan, thank you...
Sajan and Mehdi...
Thank you for the super chat...
Thank you, thank you...
Oh yeah, let me check when my lasagna gets here...
And we'll have a little food break too...
Lasagna...
Yummy, yummy...
Okay, 20 minutes...
Okay...
We'll get our lasagna in 20 minutes...
Next seat...
Thank you for the super chat...
Thank you, thank you...
Can't wait for lasagna...
Okay, what do I have to do?
Oh, I have to make sure they don't... Don't worry, I can do that.
I'll just run.
There we go.
That was easy.
Let me just run.
Like, he just wants to fight me.
I don't have to do anything.
Boom.
Okay.
Okay, this is a little bad, though.
Okay, nice.
Oh, nice.
Don't worry.
Oh, shit.
Okay, maybe worried.
Oh, okay, sorry.
Whoops.
Oh, no.
Man!
If all else fails, I have to spin!
Okay, I should have definitely been holding my attacks more.
That's actually so strong!
I did it, though!
Spin the wind.
All right, he's one hit.
Okay, I'll just do the last spin.
I should kill him.
Yeah!
The enemy officer has been defeated.
Ba-da-da-da-da-da-da-da!
All right, so I was debuffing myself.
I was actually playing with weights on for that.
Causing debris to rain down, strike enemies.
Debris will also hit, but can be injured.
Wait, do I hit myself?
No, okay, I don't hit myself.
Okay, I got a little worried.
I thought it would be like, why are you hitting yourself type deal.
Okay, nice.
Okay, I did it.
Will you leave your wife now?
Yes.
Really?
It's good to have trustworthy fellows like you.
He said yes, guys!
Like you close that ass.
Thanks to you, the sleeping dragon's first battle and victory.
The soldiers I sent you to chase were survivors fleeing from my last battle.
How'd they escape?
I had to give up my title and run scoring back into the mountains.
Okay, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm Doakfield.
How where I have grown, I don't suppose I could rest...
Oh!
Yes!
I don't suppose I could rest at your place.
Oh!
Wait, is he going to give me a concierge?
Well, if you want to sit, I'm kicking my feet right now.
Everything you need is close at hand.
Quite like the mountain retreat.
Ah, pardon me.
To appear out of the blue and immediately comment on the state of your residence, I must be more exhausted than I thought.
Why are you so tired?
An actual battlefield is nothing like the assumptions and analyses one makes...
No!
He has a wife, Doakfield!
Before he departed, Shishu saw to it that my abilities were known to many.
Because, thank you for the super sticker.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Yum!
Entreating me to become his strategist.
This is also known to many.
Lupu didn't stop her.
Why stop now?
I had to take advantage of the situation and play the part of a genius with God-given wisdom.
That is how I will demonstrate to friend and foe alike.
Oh, yeah, you saw the doll that his wife made with very accurate proportions and anatomy.
In order for Lord Liu Bei to stand out among his rival warlords, I must make it known that he has indeed gotten his hands on a rare resource.
You thought this through.
But, of course.
What else would one expect from a tactician?
Though today was my first foray into warfare, it would not do for me to appear unnerved by the experience.
In reality, it was highly stressful.
I am simply pleased that everything turned out well in the end.
The deeds done this day were a great help.
I speak of Lord Guan Yu.
Lord Zhang Fei.
Lord Zhao Yun.
And you, of course.
Of me!
He said me!
I exist!
You flatter me.
Third, they give the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Take his wife then.
Take him.
It's a strategy with no flaws.
No one is safe.
Though a tactician should play their cards close to the chest.
I assure you that this sentence comes from the heart.
It's from his heart.
He noticed me, guys.
Shall I explain why you alone are privy to these thoughts?
Yeah?
You want me to sit right next to you?
It is true that I consider you an excellent asset.
With our knees touching?
I wish to expand your utility further.
His heart!
You have sampled my vegetables, yes?
Then you well know my predilection for items with profound zest and a palpable bite.
May our fellowship be long and fruitful.
I might not mind this traipse through the muck and mire with one such as you by his side.
Black guy gets to be by his side, guys.
He's accepted me.
No!
Don't fade him!
Black!
I want to go, boy!
Why did they fade him, Black?
Tell me, boy!
Whispers sweet tacticians!
It's in my ear!
Go back!
Whisper the strategies you're gonna use to defeat Tau Tau.
We wanna know!
We just wanna know!
This is the gameplay I showed up for.
Okay, let's see.
I just wanna make sure we're not missing anything.
I wanna see if there's...
anybody we need to talk to.
Being hungry keeps you in low spirits.
Come and grab...
Oh?
Oh, okay.
My god, it's him again?
I'm...
I'll just pay.
Just pay for it.
I can't be bothered.
Here, intern.
Take my money.
I...
I can't be bothered.
I'll pay the intern, guys.
Where's it?
Is he here?
Okay, there he is.
Lord Shu Hong occasionally comes by to purchase gifts of appreciation.
There's, like...
Oh, wait, there's, like...
Oh, wait, I have to do this one.
344.
Oh, I don't need more guards.
Who cares?
Let's go increase our bond.
I see there's a dragon.
Hey, there you are.
Listen to this.
You seem...
happy.
Oh, you know?
That's our number two.
Just now, Lord Guan Yu complimented me.
He said that I'm starting to behave like a real officer.
What?
I paid you money!
Why do you still talk about Guan Yu?
Don't look at it.
All my homework is finally taken off.
I'm right here.
I'm so excited that I've been just raring to tell you ever since.
Right?
I knew that you were the one to relish this moment with.
I'm sad.
Even with the money I gave him, all he could do is think about him.
And then one day he might even call me his partner.
Oh, just thinking about his incredible.
I'll always be number two, the Guan Yu.
He's the number one guy until the day I die.
Until you die.
I can't see myself serving any other leaders.
I gave him 8K.
Hey!
I work for his lordship alone.
So that means that as long as I'm alive, I'll be by his side.
Now, as Lord Guan Yu's number one underling, I have something to tell you, number two.
Just because you can't be number one, doesn't mean you should quit in despair.
His loyalty is Oshi.
I think we would have made a great pair if Fated never brought his lordship and I together.
So from now on, let's both run where we will.
I'm like the rebound if he doesn't get Guan Yu.
Alright.
That's it?
All he did was talk about him!
I can't believe it.
That's all he did.
It was 8K!
Not just because I paid him, but it was 8K!
We are now entering Cheng Fong with the people from Cheng Province of Toad.
However, Tao Tao forces have caught up with us.
Our rear guard are currently in disarray.
And the formation is faltering.
I know that I must escape to Jian Xia, but I cannot abandon the civilians and allies who have come with us.
Yet, if I were to fall here, I would be trained to trust all the same.
My course is thus, to march forth together, no matter what toil awaits us.
This is my one and only path.
What's more, Zhugot Lan and Guan Yun are on their way to Jian Xia to call for reinforcements.
No!
I put there in Guan Yun is my trump card every time!
I just call him in and he kills everything!
Meanwhile, Zhang Fei is guarding the Changban Bridge to Sarmie Tao Tao's advance.
What would I do?
To establish some sort of order.
Truth in toad, I think it's gone to rescue my family members from the chaos there.
To be honest, I have no plan, but you always manage to find hope in times of peril.
Please, find a way through this battle.
And help our people and allies, alongside Zhang Fei and Zhao Yun.
Leave it to me.
Any enemy forces are seemingly endless, for I don't know, we're already cut off.
But your eyes will be a blessing to accomplish terrain to the self.
If you read the direction of the wind and find hidden paths for us, you may yet to catch them by surprise.
You should depart.
We don't have the luxury of time.
I'll stay here and rendezvous with our people.
No, I'm gonna go...
Wait, I have to be with a companion?
Uh...
I'll go with Zhang Fei.
I like the bridge fight more...
more than the baby.
Like...
Lu Shan is like...
unsavable.
So I...
We don't need Lu Shan.
If we save him...
It's just...
Gonna be...
Downhill.
He's...
We can't fix him anymore.
What's that?
Zhang Fei.
That's Zhang Fei.
Do not fear.
That may be Zhang Fei.
But he is alone.
We can take him together.
The bridge fight is much more iconic, though.
You have to admit.
There better be tens of thousands of you.
The bridge fight is much more iconic.
You are no match for me.
Now, which one of you wants to die first?
I'll take you all on at once.
There you are.
But now, it's less iconic because there's two of us.
Here we go.
It's less impressive now.
Nobody's getting across this bridge.
Now that there's two of us, it's not a special.
You think you can stop us with so few warriors?
That's true.
When he comes down, when Zhao Yun comes down with a baby, with a horse and stuff, it is like pretty cool.
But I still have to say the bridge fight scene is...
I think it's more memorable.
In my opinion.
I'll make sure you fall by my sword.
With all my might.
Alright.
History is ruined now.
No time to waste on the likes of you.
Out of our way.
There are still many left on the other side of the bridge.
Let us wait here and have faith that they will reach us.
Get out of here.
Yeah, they had to write me out of history.
Because I made Zhao Yun's like cool bridge fight look less cool.
Um, army of...
Excuse me?
I killed him!
What do you mean?
You can't just rewrite me now?
I'm literally right here!
How did I get rewritten already?
That's it.
I'll be jumping.
If you're gonna rewrite me on History, I'll do it now!
Wow!
I might as well be him!
I might as well!
What's the point?
You won't be out anyway!
Getting ridden out in real time.
That's rough, buddy.
Do not underestimate the tenacity of Leo-based forces.
Show them no mercy and hunt them down.
Okay, nice.
That's fucking right!
I'm coming over here!
That's right!
Oh my god, you're all so far!
Time to attack!
Okay.
Not real- Not anymore!
I'm glad I positioned reinforcements here.
Cause that man is whirlwind.
Okay.
Wait, reinforcements?
Oh no.
Okay, good job, Dragoons!
You distracted- Oh my god!
Oh my god!
Oh, I accidentally used my- Oh no, I accidentally used my musu- Oh, it's okay!
That's good!
Okay, I thought I fucked up by using my musu here.
Okay, nice!
Oh my god!
Invincibility frames right there?
The real fight starts now!
Jesus Christ!
That's fine?
Get twirled on?
The path of justice has fallen before me!
Oh shit!
Okay.
That's fine.
What?!
How did he fucking kill me?!
Oh my god!
So done us!
Woo!
Okay, he just missed.
That's good.
That was close.
Nice.
Speed!
That's right!
Get over here!
Get closer!
That's so fucked up.
Please!
Please don't die yet!
I'm trying to kill this guy!
Okay, nice.
Another one down.
Okay, last guy.
Boom!
Wait, Guan Yin's here!
Oh no, that's Jean Fei.
Oops.
Sorry, I got...
I thought I saw...
I thought I saw, you know...
The red hair.
Oh hey, it's Yao Yin!
Did you get the baby?
Where's the baby?!
Lord Liu Bei.
I have returned with your son.
He is safe...
And unharmed.
Xiao Yun!
Good to see you back in one piece.
You ran through hell, Ferato.
You have my eternal gratitude.
Alright, we did it.
Oh fuck, okay.
Um...
Okay, now...
Now it's special time, I guess.
I...
Um...
Okay.
I guess I'll have to figure out the secret passage now.
I have to go here?
No, I can't...
Wait, where do I go?
Wait, how do I...
Oh, I...
What do I do?
Hello?
Liu Bei.
We got the baby.
Oh, those are the peasants!
Wait...
Oh, we were waiting for them!
You waited for us!
We did it, guys!
It is good to see you safe.
It is difficult, I know.
But hang on a little while longer.
No, they...
No, he drops the baby.
You can't...
That's a cat event.
It seems not all were able to escape unscathed.
Still...
We must move on for now.
Okay, we gotta go.
Apparently...
I have to use my ego vision for this.
I don't know when it's gonna be helpful, though.
But apparently...
Oh, there it is!
Okay, nevermind!
There...
Nevermind!
There's people here!
Okay, where is he?
Where is the guy to kill?
He intends to continue down this path.
It is a road that can only be traveled while sacrificing people along the way.
Wait, you can guard?
We can just do that?
That's cheating!
You're not the main character!
Who lets you guard?
Okay, get out of here.
No one's allowed to defend him!
In my video games!
Oh.
Huh?
Oh my god, this is my Oshi!
Oh my god, my Oshi's here!
Yeah!
And, like, his plus one!
Whoever she...
She doesn't matter.
I'm glad he kept his fan.
That's, like, one of my favorite parts about his design.
Like...
Well, his mustache and his fans are, like, one of my favorite parts of his design.
It just sucks that they...
Um...
I'm just sad that they removed this mustache.
It just feels so empty.
But at least they kept the fan.
Because it's so iconic.
Oh, that's good.
Slash!
Oh my god, that's so strong.
We can start putting our plans into place.
New Bay must not be allowed to escape.
All forces are to pursue him with every man available.
Break all the shields!
Do it!
Oh my god, there's so many other...
Oh my god, there's so many reinforcements.
What the fuck?
Maybe the guy was running.
Maybe I...
Hmm...
Maybe...
Following me...
Provides too much killing.
Hmm...
Alright.
Alright, if Tao Tao gets too close, then I'll...
I'll kill Tao Tao.
No.
Wait, I can actually kill him.
Oh, guys, I ran out of buns.
Wait, this is bad.
I actually ran out of buns, guys.
I...
Oh, no!
No!
I am...
A little worried...
Because I am bun-less.
So, like...
I have one fear right now, in that I have zero buns.
Oh, nice.
Oh, they blocked the exit.
Nice.
Okay, maybe escape is easier.
Let's wipe them out, while they're confused.
Okay, I have to save my...
My...
I don't know what it's called, but my strong attack.
Get out of here.
There is something you should know about the mountain pass that Tao Tao's forces are taking.
There is actually a second route near the pass.
There's a second route?
Wait, what is me?
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
I'm almost dead.
Oh!
I can't...
I had to use it.
I had...
Guys, I'm...
This gives my HP back, though.
This might be a little...
This...
But, like...
I would have actually died.
I would have died.
That...
Okay, there you go.
I have my HP back.
It's okay.
It's okay, guys.
I have my HP back.
Yay!
Oh, no!
The wife died?
I'm so sorry!
If only I could have done something to stop it!
Now, we'll make you realize...
Oh!
My God!
I'm so sorry!
I will not allow you to block our path.
We will break through!
Are you...
Ready to face me?
What a shame!
I did not expect...
I have no choice...
...but to retreat.
Okay, that's good that you guys are still alive.
That's actually really good.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Oh, man!
If only I could do something about it!
Wait, what?
Oh my God, finally!
We've come with forces...
...bought from Jiang Sha!
So...
You're single now, right?
Now that, you know, your wife...
...died?
Now that...
...your wife, you know...
...failed?
It's such a shame!
Don't worry, I'll be the shoulder to cry on!
Also, I need to know when my food is here.
Give me a sec, guys.
Oh, okay, it's gonna be late.
Never mind.
It's gonna take more...
...another 20 minutes.
Okay.
I got a little worried.
I'm craving my lasagna right now.
I...
Don't worry.
I will be the shoulder you can cry on!
She just died!
I mean, he needs to process his grief!
He can't process his grief alone!
Everything has gone according to plan.
Guys!
I can't let him process his grief alone!
That would be too cruel!
Very nice.
Very nice, we gotta kill him.
Wait!
We gotta save him!
Oh my god!
Wait!
Get out!
Oh my god!
I did it!
No!
What's even worth fighting for?
Just for some peasants?!
Life is meaningless now without my Oshi.
What do I do now?!
I'm so sad.
Restart.
Wait, there's like a bunch of bread just lying there.
Too real.
It's so sad.
I can't believe he would do this to me.
What about me?!
How could he do this to us?!
All right, nice.
Oh no.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god, he's so tanky!
This retreat would be the best option right now.
I'm trying my best to kill him!
Now.
Please, let me kill you!
Time to act.
Oh my god!
He got me in the corner!
Jesus Christ.
I'm trying to kill you!
Alright!
Am I still gonna- Oh my god!
I have to fight him regardless!
I can't believe it!
It doesn't matter!
I have to fight him regardless!
Deadless.
What the fuck, where?
Oh my god, there's so many things happening!
Like, there's too many bosses!
What is this?
Eleven, thank you!
Welcome to Tomato Farm!
Welcome, welcome!
You're right for Baoshi.
Do it for him!
Oh my god, okay.
Alright, you guys are gonna die for this, I'm sorry.
He's coming for you!
I'm sorry!
Oh wait, oh wait, oh never mind, JK.
I was, it was a joke.
Sorry.
That was just a joke, guys.
What do you mean, die?
JK.
It was just a funny, haha joke.
Oh.
Oh, no.
No.
I'm sorry, dragoons.
I'm, I'm so sorry.
He doesn't know I'm here.
Guys, he knew I was, I, I thought I, I thought I could live.
I, I didn't, I didn't realize he would just kill all of us.
Holy shit.
He was so strong.
Um.
That was my bad.
Maybe, um.
I would say that that might have been my bad.
I thought, I thought we had longer to live.
Not gonna lie.
Alright, let's try and kill this guy.
Which is, I'm not very hopeful, Ren.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I am, I am scared.
Okay.
There you go.
I saved it for just this special occasion.
I got this.
Okay.
That's fine.
Now it's my power.
Bear witness to my power.
That's right.
Behold my power.
Let's end this.
It's rage time.
I kept it for this reason.
However, we shall meet in battle again.
Alright guys.
I think I can, I think I can take Tau Tau.
I'm going back.
Hahaha.
Guys.
I'm ready to change history.
I'm going back.
What is this fog?
Wait, what?
Wait, am I supposed to fight it?
What is this?
Hello?
I cannot let Liu Bei go after all.
Allowing him to pass.
Would be too great a risk.
Wait, what?
What happened?
So you've come, Zuluwan.
You mean to protect Liu Bei to the very end, it would seem.
Wait, what's a different ending?
You better ready yourself.
You'd best be prepared to fight.
Wait, what do you guys mean?
As guardians of peace!
Guys, what do you mean?
Wait, I could have done a different ending?
Helpless citizens into battle.
What can you call this but the worst kind of violence?
Despite this, you would protect him?
Does your bond with him truly serve as reason enough?
Time to act.
Oh my god.
What?
What am I- What is this?
How is that different from the guardians of peace?
We hate it so much.
How is Liu Bei any different from the ones who took everything from us?
How does you believe that?
How v?
bereich First And despair has been burned into my mind.
The suffering, the agony, the chaos, what has revealed to me?
Juzis!
My new pass.
Reject all heroes.
I rejected the Hanandu.
Oh my, okay, Shadow.
He truly is the shadow of this game.
No, this is actually Shadow right now.
So what's the different ending if I trigger it?
He's such an- Yeah!
It's literally just Shadow!
Why don't you remember?
How can you?
Do you mean to kill me, Tsuluan?
It would be a fitting end.
But as long as these heroes exist in the world, there will always be someone like me who opposes them.
Why not join us?
Let's return home together, Bailon.
Impossible.
Our village was destroyed.
And Juha is dead.
Neither of us will be returning anywhere.
However, I do not yet have the strength to defeat Liu Bei.
Okay, you hated me for following Sasa.
Now you hate me for Liu Bei.
Like, pick a lane.
You're giving me mixed signals.
The words Juha uttered before her death.
Do they still echo in your soul?
Live.
And create the world we dreamed of.
If you really think Liu Bei is a true hero- That we can trust- To bring our dreams to fruition.
Then do what you must- To make me believe it.
But the moment he strays from that path- And is deemed unworthy of our trust.
The guardians of peace will bring him to ruin.
Wait, that's not very peaceful of you.
No matter how long it takes.
That's not very peaceful of us.
Farewell, Zuluon.
May we one day fly together.
Wait a minute.
That's not peaceful at all.
The two of them who are united must unite.
While those who have been long united must diverge.
Thus has it always been, For empires and their people alike.
Guardian of Peace.
The time has come to part ways.
One will champion heroes, Striving to bring peace to the world.
The other will lurk in the shadows, keeping the heroes true to their path.
That is the new way of the Guardians of Peace.
And thus shall our purpose be fulfilled.
We need light and dark to do this.
This is the last time I appear before you.
Who are you, really?
Yeah, you're clearly not by long.
Well...
It is said that the founders of our order were mystical beings.
That they had the faces of children, with hair as white as snow.
And eyes as blue as the surface of a frozen lake.
And that no number of years could ever age them.
Zuluon, you must go now.
Let your eyes guard you on your true path.
I guess he's like a god or something.
And kill all that has been entrusted to you.
He's like a...
Like a...
Maybe like a de...
Like not a demon, but like a...
Like one of the gods.
It seems that everyone is safe.
And he just took...
He just took the appearance of...
Uh, Bai Long.
Cause that was Bai Long when he was young.
So like, they took his appearance.
Maybe a Buddha?
Could be.
We shall head downstream towards Jungsha.
Could be a...
Well, it could be any of the gods.
We need to start again.
Together.
A lot of them are pretty mischievous people.
There.
We still have a major problem.
Even if we have control of Jing.
I'm checking my...
Lasagna.
Though.
Given what we've lost.
It's hard to feel much joy.
Brother.
What?
Lord Liubei.
They cancelled my order?
Please do not be yourself.
For we've never had the luxury of time...
To lament.
It is true...
That we've lost much.
But...
Because of it...
Wait, why was my order cancelled?
You have been something much greater, my lord.
Wait a minute.
Guys.
I'm mad.
I'm reordering.
I need to know why this was cancelled.
I waited so long!
How was my order cancelled?
Guys, give me a sec.
I'm trying to figure out how my order was cancelled.
Wait.
Why would I...
I have to pay again?
Would it...
Wait.
View receipts.
Okay.
Um...
It doesn't say why it was cancelled.
It just said cancelled.
What?
I'm reordering the same thing.
I'm reordering this.
I'm...
I'm so hungry.
I don't understand.
They didn't even text me!
Why?
They didn't even text me why it was cancelled!
They just cancelled!
No, they would like be like...
Oh, we don't have your order.
Could you like...
But he like, waited!
Oh yeah, I have a...
Dad update.
Nice.
He's good.
He's getting more and more rambutious as he feels better.
He wants to run around and seems more back to normal now.
His back legs are still weak, but he can walk fine.
Um...
Just not very fast running.
You can tell he wants to start running, but his back legs can't go that fast.
Aw...
Aw, that's cute.
That's cute.
Also, why the fuck did they cancel my order?!
There was a delivery guy in everything that was assigned to me!
I...
Order it one more time.
I'm so sad.
I was looking forward to this lasagna.
I...
I'm so sad.
I literally waited...
I watched them prepare the food, and then they assigned a delivery man to like...
There's...
Yeah, but then it was like, order was cancelled.
It just...
Yeah, but then it says, order was cancelled later on, so I got so...
I...
I was like...
I'm looking at it.
Help.
Uh...
Wait, did they charge me for the cancelled order?
Your receipt.
Your order has been cancelled.
It just...
They gave me a refund, but I think they refunded it to my card.
Yeah.
They refunded it to my card.
But it doesn't tell me like...
They closed and like...
What?
They don't close yet.
That's the thing.
I could reorder it.
But like, I don't know why it got cancelled.
It's so weird.
Cause like...
A delivery guy was assigned to my order, and then he was going to...
I saw him go drive to pick it up.
Yeah.
Alright.
Sad.
Today is...
All I wanted was my lasagna.
I just want my cheese.
I was looking forward to...
Bro, I'm starving.
I wasn't paying attention.
I was sad about my lasagna.
I'm sorry.
Tempting to put the Longzong plan into action.
If it succeeds, your strength will grow to rival that of Cao Cao and Suinchuan.
Cao Cao will most likely continue his southward advance.
In order to stop him, we must ally with Wu, who also opposes him.
I mean, there's two against one.
Judging from what I hear of Wu, they would be likely to prioritize peace within their borders and among their own people.
If they are hesitant to fight, and opt to surrender, would that not cause everything to fall apart?
Indeed.
And I do not intend to drag Lord Liu Biao, nor Lord Sun Quan.
I thought Lord Liu Biao died.
Even more so if they are unwilling to go to war.
I am fairly certain that, like us, those in Wu do not wish to see Jing fall into Cao Cao's hands.
They must know that he will be their enemy, eventually.
It may take time for them to decide...
But Caprize Saturn!
What happened to...
I would understand if they like...
They didn't have...
For one of the items, but it like...
They could have cancelled it right away.
That is the first step.
That's so weird.
Yeah!
I held it up.
Yeah, I know.
It was so weird.
I was not expecting that.
Very nice.
That's...
Plus 28.
Uh, I don't...
I'm not gonna upgrade these.
These are, like, bad upgrades.
I'm gonna go back to attack.
Yeah, but I didn't even think they would remake it, too.
Okay, it's two more battles, right?
Two more fights left?
Ah, it's you.
Sorry, but...
Lord Zuga Liang is away.
And he won't be returning for a while.
Did something happen?
Just a little earlier.
A man named Lu Su from Wu paid him a visit.
I'm gonna look at my meal, by the way.
He's been looking for a way of securing alliance with our Lord.
I don't know why this text is going on.
I didn't make sure my order doesn't get cancelled again.
Although Wu is powerful in its own right, Cao Cao's faction far outstrips them, and having us as allies makes little difference.
Given the enormous gap in strength, many within Wu are advocating for surrender.
However, if Lord Zuga Liang's bold plan is to succeed, it is essential for the alliance to come to fruition.
As such, Lord Zuga Liang proposed that he himself would act as an envoy to Wu.
Okay.
Can you persuade them?
I don't know.
All I can say is that when I saw him go, I sensed a kind of aura from him.
Both fierce and resolute.
If anyone is capable of stirring Wu's military into action, it's him.
Now, we must trust in our strategist.
And wait.
Someone said a massive army- Oh, hey, Junfei.
Wait, Guan Yun?
Sorry, Junfei.
He's more important.
It's another war.
And a big one this time.
You did an impressive job protecting my brother in such dire circumstances.
Allow me to express my thanks once again.
You're impressive yourself, Guan Yun.
I saw the swings.
Thanks to your valiant efforts, we were able to avoid the enemy as we advanced.
Lord Lu Chi, the ruler of Cheng Sha, and an acquaintance of Lord Chu Gu Lian, has promised to lend us his aid.
But as I'm sure you know, Tao Tao's forces will neither bend nor break so easily.
The many talented officers under his banner will no doubt demonstrate their might and their cunning on the battlefield.
To call them the strongest army in the realm would be no exaggeration.
Our brother faces no greater threat than this.
However, we have no choice but to overcome them.
Brother now has an ambition to fulfill.
And people to protect.
All that remains is to make his dream a reality.
Don't worry, I got you Guan Yun.
I got you.
I'll make sure he doesn't lose.
And then I guess you can repay me by making sure I never existed.
I have to say, Cao Cao's persistence is becoming a real pain.
The situation was uncertain for a while.
But thanks to you, we made it to Zheng Sha in one piece.
You aren't hurt?
Of course not.
As if the great Cheng Fei of Yan could even be scratched by the likes of them.
We were outnumbered, but it was nothing we couldn't handle.
Definitely not compared to the battles brother has awaiting him.
I can barely even imagine how much work it's gonna take to build his ideal world.
A place where everyone can live as they wish.
I ain't nearly as cunning as Chu Ge Liang.
But if he points my blade in the right direction, that's where I'll swing.
Not nearly as...
Okay, you're putting yourself in a bit too high of a bar there.
Anyway, if brother's gonna be taking on overwhelming odds, I guess I'll just have to use my overwhelming mights to clear a path for him.
Well, that may be what I always do.
But having a clear goal in mind takes some of the weight off of my shoulders for some reason.
I don't really like the way Chu Ge Liang talks, but I guess I ought to give credit where credit is due.
He's literally the one brain cell in our entire army.
It's...
a little concerning.
Just a little bit.
It pains me to admit it, but I was in over my head.
My desire to lead the people to freedom led to some losing their lives.
Even so...
I just had to try...
Still being made, it's being prepared!
The people of Jing wanted me to lead them.
I understand, how did it get cancelled?
What happened?
If I had left them behind...
I could never again have spoken of my ideal...
For a world in which...
I could be eating lasagna right now while watching all these cutscenes!
He had no other choice.
I suppose that's true.
I must think of it that way.
We'll never know.
Our troubles have yet to pass.
We may feel the same lasagna.
If we are to rout Sao-Sao.
Yet...
I shall fight to the very end.
And fulfill my aspirations.
For the sake of those who are devoted to me.
I suppose that sounds like something Lord Cao Cao would say.
Perhaps it is only now that I bear the weight of these lives on my shoulders.
That I am able to stand shoulder to shoulder with such a giant.
At any rate...
Let us wait for Chu Ge Liang.
I trust that his return shall herald an alliance with Wu.
Yeah!
Wait, is the Battle of Redcliff next?
Oh my god.
That's actually my favorite...
Battle.
Like, I think it's like a lot of people's favorite battle slash event.
Because it's such a...
Like...
Crazy strategy and iconic moment in the Green Kingdom's history.
How went negotiations?
The fleet commanded by Wu's general, Zhou Yu, awaits at Fankou.
It's like literally THE battle in Three Kingdoms.
Before long, they shall take up arms against Cao Cao's advance force.
Then that means...
Indeed.
Lord Suan Chuan has decided to join hands with Lord Liu Bei.
Oh, here's Lu Su.
I don't know who he is.
I have no idea who that guy is.
You have my sincere thanks, Lord Lu Su.
I fear that without Chu Ge Liang's tenacity...
Wu may have long since chosen surrender.
Tenacity, you say?
I suppose it was necessary to draw those advocating surrender into a debate.
He acted as quite the villain, to put it lightly.
No need to hold back.
I'm sure he wasn't acting.
After all, he's always had a disagreeable personality.
We're in front of the man himself.
Allow me to keep my opinions to myself.
Even if we've secured an alliance with Wu, the fact remains that our forces are scarce in number.
That Lord Suan Chuan decided to fight with us means he must have seen some chance of winning.
Where's Lord Suan Chuan?
Why didn't he come over?
Is he scared of dying like his brothers and dad?
We will intercept the enemy on the river.
After discussions with Lord Zhou Yu...
Honestly, I won't be surprised if Suan Chuan becomes like a...
Like just a shut-in after that.
Like his dad and brother literally died in war.
Why would he do that to himself?
He should just stay in his...
Stay in this castle.
Oh.
Oh, is it Tuan?
Tuan?
Not Quan?
That was the English pronunciation in the Dynasty...
In the Dynasty Warriors original series?
So...
It's just an old habit.
Like how I used to pronounce Tau Tau as Kau Kau.
Because they used to call him Kau Kau.
Yet, on the water...
Such caution will only work against him.
That massive fleet...
Tired from the long journey...
Will be disorganized.
Fatigue will lower morale.
And the young sea will hamper their maneuvers.
Yeah.
I miss when Tau Kau was Kau Kau.
And Kau...
Kau Kau and Kau P. Oh yeah, Kau P. I forgot!
So it was Kau P. I miss those days.
The English dub was...
The English dub was truly...
Was truly amazing.
We simply must.
Sorry, they're talking about politics.
Our lives depend on it.
And I...
I miss my...
I miss my dating sim route.
Yes.
It is as you say.
All the more reason for us to hurry to the rendezvous.
And I miss my...
And I'm waiting for my lasagna.
I'm thinking about lasagna right now.
Phoenix!
Well, well.
So you're the one to call on me this time, Chu Ge Liang.
I distinctly express that I've no intention of putting my neck on the line.
Or have you forgotten?
Even for me, the very idea of dragging a dear friend into battle pains me to no end.
All the more reason to leave then, don't you think?
I have no desire to ally with Wu, or any of you.
Are you sure about that?
Cao Cao is constantly seeking talented individuals.
He may already have his sights set on you.
If Jing falls into his grasp, your days of peace are over.
You'd be forced into a life of vagabonding, or supplication to Cao Cao.
Is that a threat?
Sorry.
But that won't work on me.
The capture of Jing is well within my calculations.
I see.
Then you leave me no choice.
I didn't want to have to use this last resort, but here we are.
Wait.
Last resort?
Am I threatening him?
Well, I'll be damned.
So they've got you doing their dirty work for them, have they?
You're close with him, are you not?
Perhaps you could put in a good word for him.
They're like, that's it.
We're doing a honeypot now.
Yeah!
I'm gonna bring in the big guns.
You can't...
You can't say no to him.
We really need your help, Anton.
Oops.
Did I just drop something?
Let me just...
Pick it up real quick.
I almost feel guilty for...
Causing you to be...
Dragged out here.
If it were anyone but you...
I don't think I could ever bring myself to refuse if it meant damaging your reputation.
If only it was anyone else.
You're as insidious as ever, Chuga.
Did it just cause of me?
He literally was like...
Why?
You know I can't say no to him in this space.
Your support is most appreciated, Pengtong.
It's not working.
Just remember that I will support you as I see fit.
And at my discretion.
Still...
And if you say yes, he'll show up in your room tonight.
Don't you worry about that.
Fate to black.
That night...
Wait a minute.
Where am I?
Okay.
I need to be sure where I am.
But I have something urgent to discuss with you.
Wait a minute.
And let us speak.
I got... I got the worry.
There is a task that I wish to entrust to you.
A highly significant one at that.
Alright, I'm checking my food.
The plan I shared with Lord...
Okay, it's being picked up again!
Setting fire to Cao Cao's ships.
Such a strategy is no assured victory.
Alright guys, sorry.
I need to like, look at this just to make sure it's picked up.
There is one major hole in the plan.
What is it?
Cao Cao's forces will march southward.
And thus, they will naturally take up camp to our north.
I need to make sure it doesn't get cancelled.
This is...
The winds of the Yangtze River Basin blow from the west and the north.
But if we simply set Cao Cao's ships place, the northern wind will scatter the flames.
Doesn't it like, take money from...
Like...
No, it's a different one.
Does it take money from...
From them if they like, cancel the order?
If the winds were to shift...
Indeed.
We must detect that exact moment.
And your power...
The power to read the wind...
Is up to the challenge, is it not?
Perhaps due to the climate or terrain...
A southern wind sometimes blows down from the cliffs of Chibi at night.
I need you to sense that change coming.
Wait, me?
And give the signal to loose our flames.
Oh yeah, he's gonna perform some...
Magic.
Or he's gonna change the wind.
How do you like the flames?
Lord Zhou Yu is making the necessary preparations.
You focus on forecasting the winds.
This is a vital task I could entrust to no other.
Perhaps...
I...
Shouldn't say this, but...
Wait, me?
We're counting on that power of yours.
Victory or defeat...
Is in your hands.
Oh my god, that's a lot of pressure.
I'll do it for you, Maoshi.
Don't worry, sorry.
I'm not moving because I'm making sure that...
They don't take my lasagna.
Please, I'm so hungry.
All I want is lasagna.
I just want my...
Oh, guys, I have a...
I have a meeting with Pantone.
I think I have to...
Keep my bargain.
I'm so hungry, John.
You've truly...
Brought a storm upon my head this time, eh?
A storm?
Forgive me.
Honestly...
I've been running this way and that, thanks to your exploits.
Well, I admit, I don't mean to seriously admonish you.
Rather, I'm actually quite thankful.
You gave me the final push I needed to get my thoughts in order after being lost for a long time.
I must confess, I've been perplexed by the issue for some time now.
You're striving to become someone.
Whereas I haven't even been trying.
I've just been existing in obscurity.
Well, you still have a reputation, though.
I used to struggle greatly in communicating...
People still call him the phoenix, even though he's trying to stay in secret.
It was then that Master Shui Ching took me under his wing.
I had begun seeing the world as unfairly obtuse.
Even when my efforts were finally recognized.
Please pick up my order.
I...
Found the idea of choosing my own path burdensome.
Let alone...
Actually walking it.
It was thanks to you that I...
No, he is!
He's a real...
He dies.
I don't know how you miss...
Kept telling everybody that he dies later.
I've been...
I've been very, very explicit about the fact that...
He does die later.
I'm glad I was able to help.
More than you could imagine.
I dread to think of the state I'd be in...
Without your...
Sorry, yeah, you didn't have your jingle jangle.
What?
We give...
And receive...
Determines our fates...
With one another.
Master Shui Jing...
Told me that.
You hold so many bonds with different people...
And have discovered your own path.
I think others see you...
As one who provides guidance.
He picked it up!
It may take different forms...
What?
But you have the gratitude of those around you.
He picked up my order!
I know that to be true.
As I'm one such person...
What happened to my first lasagna?
I hope that we can stay close...
Sorry, Penton.
As we continue upon our own paths...
The ones we've chosen for ourselves...
Without hesitation.
He's like driving over right now!
I'm sorry.
This entire interaction with him...
I was not paying attention.
My lasagna was so much more important.
I'm sorry.
I'm just gonna give you money.
I...
Wait, but he's not driving!
Why aren't you driving?
Wait, where do I go?
I'm...
Sorry, I'm so hungry.
I...
I'm so hungry right now.
Okay.
Sun Quan.
Training of Lu Bei's forces.
Where the fuck is Daoyun?
Wait, why is the car not moving?
Oh wait, he's gonna send me a letter.
And then give me an address, right?
Yeah, okay.
I wish to thank you.
I'd like to thank you for Changbang.
And at the end, I'm much to ask.
May I come to see you?
There are some things I would like to bring with me as well.
I know I may be asking a lot.
But it all...
It's all because I wish to spend...
A memorable time together?
Okay, maybe he...
Okay, sorry.
Okay.
I'll come...
I'll be back.
This is...
I swear to God.
After my memorable time with Daoyun.
If...
If after my memorable time with him.
And then like...
And then like my order gets cancelled.
I will not be happy.
I...
I came back for this.
Okay.
I will be very unhappy.
I swear to God.
If he takes this away from me.
If I lose my lasagna.
Because of Daoyun.
Me...
Me mad.
Okay.
Where the fuck is he though?
There is the battle.
Oh my god.
Wait, that looks so cool.
That shit looks insane.
Oh, there he is.
Surprise quiz time!
I know a couple people who went...
Alright, what do you wanna do?
Daoyun.
Oh, late night drinking!
Thank you for your help at Chungban.
Without you, all would have been lost.
I don't know if I would have survived without your help there.
Truly.
You're...
Being with you made me feel so safe.
I felt that way from the moment we met.
Oh!
That's me!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, we're getting drunk together.
Just noticed.
Holy shit!
Alright.
I feel the same way.
Thank you, friend.
No.
Maybe partner is a bad word.
Oh!
I try to believe that I will never again meet such a kindred spirit.
Already?
Partner?
Domestic partners?
What?
Wait, Fade of Black?
Wait!
What happened in between?
What happened in between that fade?
I like the real...
What did happen?
What did he say when he was...
What did he say and do?
And during this...
I like the real you.
What did he do?
What?
What did I do?
Exactly!
I want to know too!
It's okay.
You can tell me.
Nothing you say will bother me.
Did I do something in my sleep?
If so, that too was the real me.
He's like...
Whatever I did drunk, I meant it.
And I was trying to put into words why it was that I sought after you and Lord Liu Bei.
But I've just realized...
His generosity truly knows...
Why are we talking...
I like how our...
Our bed talk...
His bed talk is that he has to talk about Liu Bei.
This is where I can truly be myself.
He's like...
That was great, but let me tell you about our great Lord Liu Bei and his benevolence.
Being with you really is like a dream.
I hope we will continue to have many nights like this one.
He wants more!
That was like...
He had a really good time.
He had it...
Oh my god!
Alright.
That was worth it.
What's going on?
Okay.
It's coming!
What happened to my lasagna?
What?
It's actually arriving!
What did he do to my lasagna?
I need to know!
What did the first guy do?
This is important!
What did the first guy do to my lasagna?
I think he actually ate my lasagna!
Because this lasagna... I ordered the same thing!
Oh, that's beautiful.
I literally ordered the same thing.
I didn't change my order.
There's no way he didn't eat it.
It was a good... I ordered it from a good lasagna place too.
Does it not take money from him?
I got refund though.
Two married dragoons talking about Toki before I met!
Shuriko, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, there's Joyu.
And his new roommate, Sun Chuan.
Kuzali, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
My Hoshi.
Tonight, we finally confront SaoSao in a battle that will decide our future!
We prepared as best we can.
All that's left is for us to believe in each other and fight through to the end.
I could be eating lasagna this entire time.
I'm sorry.
I'm still thinking about it.
We will win!
We're gonna do it!
Friendship is magic!
SaoSao's forces seem to have responded to their defeat by changing their formation.
They have linked their ships together into a solid platform, which will enable them to fight as if they are on land.
Oh, that's a foolish mistake!
I suppose such quick decision-making is to be expected from the ruler of the Central Plains.
But this time, those quick wits of his will be the cause of his downtime.
Yeah, it makes fire spread quickly if they're all linked.
Pong Tong's abilities have proven to be very impressive indeed.
For one so reluctant to join us, he has greatly exceeded expectations.
Okay guys, sorry.
I need a chair.
Okay, three more minutes.
Oh my god, it's gonna be right here!
My lasagna!
Don't tell me.
Lord Pong Tong was tasked with infiltrating the enemy ranks to offer a proposal to Cao Cao.
A plan to prevent his ships from rocking.
Oh, he was the one that gave him the plan.
The fire attack against a scattered fleet would give the flames no path to spread.
Oh, a double agent!
...trendering it largely ineffective.
Having their vessels clustered together and bound by chains will make the fire much more devastating.
In short, Lord Pong Tong's scheme is but the first step in our greater plan to defeat Cao Cao's army.
The chain stratagem.
Implemented by connecting several plans together in order to topple a powerful foe.
Still, we must keep in mind that a chain is only as strong as its weakest link.
And for that reason, we cannot abide even a single failure.
Yeah.
It's like a really complicated plan that somehow all just worked.
Cause like...
Like, he had to...
We all...
Like, everyone was like, oh, it's magic.
But like, Chu Got Lun looked into the sky and like...
Predicted when the wind was gonna change at that exact moment.
From just...
Like, you know, like how like sailors can predict like the weather and stuff from the sky and like...
Destinations and stuff like that.
And he could have escaped on his own.
No one knows where the enemy soldiers who surrendered in the last battle are either.
Yeah, he was like, a weatherman.
Something to do with it.
One guy a traitor?
It almost defies belief.
Oh?
Well, we haven't seen you around these parts in a while.
So, you've been at Lord Liu Bei's side, have you?
What's this about...
Hung...
Oh yeah, Hung Guy pretended to defect to...
Uh...
Defect to the other side, so he can set off like a...
Set off like bombs, like his own like firebomb.
We have turned traitor.
Not only has he been openly criticizing Lord Sun Chuen of late...
Oh, it's Chuen!
His actions have been consistently suspicious.
What's more, when Zhou Yu questioned him on his behavior, He carelessly spoke of having made contact with Cao Cao.
After that, he was flogged and thrown into the prison.
Yet, now...
Not a soul knows where he is.
I can hardly believe it.
Believe it or not, the fact remains that it happened.
I wish I had taken the opportunity to question him myself.
Regardless, if Huang Guy has defected to the enemy, Cao Cao may be aware of our plans.
We must proceed with the utmost caution in the next battle.
But yeah, Huang Guy defecting was part of his...
Zhukot Lun's entire plan.
It was so intricate.
That's why she...
The battle of Red Cliff is like one of the most like...
Um...
One of the most memorable fights...
Or like battles in the entire Three Kingdoms.
Because his plan was so...
Intricate...
And so...
Complicate...
It was so complicated...
And yet, everything worked.
Like, they were never supposed to win that fight.
Alright.
When's my food?
I swear to God.
If I see...
Okay, Derp.
He's gonna call me any second now.
Sorry, guys.
And then I'm gonna get my lasagna.
Alright, let's see what the letters are.
Oh, okay.
Wait, he still wants to...
We're still talking?
Okay.
I'd miss you a lot?
Oh my God.
If something were to happen to you...
I'd...
I'd miss you a lot.
Okay, buddy.
You...
This is a business relationship.
Okay.
I let you live here...
Without paying rent.
And that's it.
There's nothing happening between us, guys.
Famous officers and generals.
It's truly...
Lasagna.
Oh my God.
After all those cut scenes.
I don't get my lasagna.
No!
I go straight to bat...
Wait!
There was another cut scene!
Oh my God.
We must realize the long song plan.
I could have ate my food while we watched this.
We must first win this battle.
I didn't think there was another one.
I'll say it again.
But this mission relies on the outcome of the fire attack.
Call me!
As such...
We will give the command to go into battle.
The moment you sense a change in the wind.
Has the wind shown any sign of changing soon?
Oh my God.
It should arrive soon.
They called.
Understood.
Then we shall mobilize our troops at once.
Okay.
We just gotta make sure...
He...
We give him the right signal.
I didn't listen to what the right signal was.
But I'm ready.
Let's begin.
Tata's forces have been deployed to Chi B.
Just as we planned.
Now begin our real battle.
Please, everyone listen closely.
The enemy currently has a massive fleet on the river.
In terms of numbers alone, our alliances does not stand a chance.
However, Lord Zhukot Lan and I have a plan to win.
We will use fire to send the enemy running.
And put an end to Tao Tao's ambition.
We are in lines of Wu and Lord Lu Bei's forces.
This means both Lord Sun Qian and Lord Lu Bei must be protected.
Okay.
And to spare a thought for Lord Zhou Yu and myself.
As this battle cannot be won without our strategy.
The key to our fire attack is the direction of the wind.
We must wait until the northern wind turns towards south east.
As this battle begins, the enemy assault will be fierce and unyielding.
But this plan will not work unless you can stop to advance.
Hold your ground.
To encounter that traitor among them.
Do not hesitate.
Consider it an opportunity to remedy that concern.
Meanwhile, I will pray for the winds to change.
I will ask for someone to guard me as I perform the prayer.
No.
Hmm.
Turning to prayers like this for success?
Seems unlike you.
There must be some greater reason for this, no?
Yes.
This is very assumed of you, Lord Lu Su.
The reasons for this ruse are two-fold.
First, is to serve as a decoy.
When the enemy sees the sleeping dragon acting in such an unexpected way on the field, it will draw their attention.
This must be con- Oh!
Food!
I'll be right back.
Fia!
Food!
Lasagna!
Finally!
This is what I...
This entire time...
This is really...
What?
And I didn't even give via a fork.
Okay.
After all my struggles, I don't even get a fork.
I...
I don't even get a fucking fork after...
After everything I've been through.
I...
This is...
That's so fucked up.
I'm gonna eat a little bit of my caprese salad, though.
I know I should eat my actual lasagna, but I love caprese salad.
I love caprese cheese.
I just want my cheese!
Mmm...
It's good.
I love caprese salad.
Alright, mozzarella...
With the tomato.
It's so good.
Mozzarella with the...
I was thinking of burrata cheese, for some reason.
I forgot.
It's...
I love the mozzarella with the tomato.
So good.
And then the sauce on top of it.
Mmm.
Yum, yum, yum, yum.
The vinegar and pesto sauce.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Okay, let me...
Mmm.
Now it's lasagna time!
Sorry.
Small food ASMR.
Real quick.
Lasagna time!
Time!
I was hungry.
I was really hungry.
I'm sorry.
I kept thinking about this lasagna for so long.
Oh my god.
It's so good.
Oh my god!
Oh no!
It's so good!
That was worth waiting.
I wish I had my million of cutscenes to watch while I eat.
If I could, I'd make you guys watch Ink Masters with me while I eat.
But I can't do that on YouTube.
I would.
If I could, I would.
But I can't do that on YouTube.
I'll just take a couple more bites.
And then we'll play.
Just let me enjoy a couple more bites.
And then we'll... We'll keep playing.
Because I didn't... I promise you guys, we will finish.
We're so close.
We literally have two more battles.
In this moment, lasagna or chukotlan?
Ooh.
I'm hungry.
The thing is, I'm really hungry.
I don't know.
Why not both?
Yummy, yummy.
Okay.
I'm ready.
Wait, JK.
Let me take one more bite.
I'm pretty sure the driver ate my...
The first driver ate my food.
There's no way.
There's no way the restaurant cancelled the first order.
And then reordered the same fucking thing.
And then it got to me.
I had lunch.
But I had like...
I had a breakfast wrap.
So it wasn't like a lot.
Okay, I'm good.
I'm good to go.
All right.
They're surely concerned that we are up to something nefarious and will send soldiers to hinder me.
Secondly, it allows me to send a signal when the fires are to be lit.
The prairie area is on high ground and offers a view of the whole battlefield.
Once the altar is ablaze...
Oh, I looked...
I accidentally pressed it.
And that will tell the hidden troops it's time to launch the fire attack.
As for figuring out the exact timing, that will be your job.
You are to read the winds.
When the time is right, launch a fire arrow above the battlefield.
It will be...
How?
How would I know?
But how would I know?
How would I know when the wind changes?
You have to use my special eyes all the time?
I'm scared.
That's so much responsibility.
It's the wind blowing north right...
Where is...
I don't know.
Okay, it's this way.
The wind is that way right now.
Okay, it's blowing towards me.
Okay, you'll know when you know.
Okay, I believe.
I'll take command of this battle.
All right, we'll go forward.
Don't worry.
When I know, I'll know.
All of my plans depend on this decisive battle.
Each and every one of you must carry out your duties.
So that we may claim a crushing victory.
All right, I'm ready.
We should send ships from our flanks to attack the enemy.
If the time is right, we shall cut our way into their base from the front.
Oh, wait, look at that.
It's coming over.
You see those ships?
Oh my god, it's like a little taxi.
Beep, beep.
All units, strengthen your guard.
That's right.
As long as we hold firm.
Put your ship, connect your ship to ours.
That's right.
I dare you.
Stay on the defensive.
You think I'm scared?
I have no fear.
Read the winds.
Okay, it's that way now.
Okay.
All right.
Guys, I might need you guys to yell at me.
Because I will most likely fuck it up.
I'll let you guys know.
I will most likely fuck it up.
I need you guys to let me know when it's here.
I don't believe in myself.
Okay, nice.
All right, nice.
All right.
Wait, what?
Did I not...
Okay.
Oh my god, I can't do anything!
Oh my god, they all like...
They all attacked me.
I literally couldn't do anything.
Like, what do I do?
Push on through!
I see it!
Jesus.
Oh my god, I already had two bugs left.
The enemy officer has been defeated.
Okay, I got another one.
That's good.
The enemy officer has been defeated.
How?
HONDE!
I...
Oh my god, HONDE, you're useless.
You're actually useless.
I'm still, like, fighting 200 people!
I should fall back while I can.
Everything is going well so far.
I'd say it's just about time to land another blow.
Oh my god, I've been stuck here!
This is why people forget about you.
This just became a lot more complicated.
Okay, nice.
Oh my god, we're about to kill him.
Okay, we gotta go back.
Okay, we gotta go back and help the rest of the team.
Wait, what?
Maintain a constant barrage of arrows.
No, I killed him.
Wait, what?
When did he show up?
But I thought I killed you!
Oh, no, I can't.
How many...
But there's too many people!
We're gonna make it through this.
I can't do anything!
No, it's fine, I can kill him.
It's fine, Chugolay would live!
Trust me!
As long as he lives, he is short of the authority on my side.
I can, I can do this!
March forward!
Don't worry, it'll be fine!
It'll be fine!
As expected, you have bared your fangs at me.
This is in line with my prediction.
Trust!
You have my mind getting cornered!
Seriously?
Really?
What just happened?
Oh my god!
With all my might!
I!
What just happened?
Oh damnit!
Fine, it's fine, it's fine.
So...
I...
Nice!
I believe!
I can live!
Really?
I'm of no use to anybody dead.
It's fine!
He's almost dead!
No matter how you slice it!
I'll protect him soon!
Don't worry!
Okay!
Let's end this!
Ahhhh!
He's just staring for him!
But it's too late!
Okay!
I'm coming back!
Don't worry!
I'm coming!
Where did I go wrong?
Okay the wins is up!
Don't worry!
I will...
begin the prayer!
Wait, wait, wait.
Don't forget to pray in.
While carrying out the most vital part of the plan.
Wait, wait, wait.
I'm coming over.
I know this will be hard.
But... I am counting on you all.
Don't worry.
I'm here.
This is weird.
It's fine.
Hey.
Wait, where's the... Wait, I thought he was gonna do the musu attack.
Pass the attack and take victory for ourselves.
Advance the fleet.
With these ships, who is ours for the taking?
Okay, I got the musu.
So they've arrived.
Still, it's not yet time.
You have to endure their assault for now.
We've lost our archers in the east.
Oh, duh.
The enemy's offensive will go on unimpeded now.
Wait.
Oh yeah.
Wait guys, this is a little difficult.
I can do it left and right?
Wait.
With all my might death.
I keep learning.
I'm on well.
You're on the spot.
What one guy.
Like, he just said he's running away!
Oh my god, Stu and Shan-chan.
The enemy officer has been defeated, and the enemies advancing on our position have been eliminated.
Okay.
I think it's safe to say that our distraction was a success.
That's fine.
To aid our allies on the other fronts.
Alright.
The enemy officer has been defeated.
Annihilate the enemy.
Okay.
I'm coming over.
Now this is what I call intense.
I'm fucking riding my horse as fast as I can!
So I shall show you no mercy.
Get out of my sight if you wish to live.
Oh my god.
Oh I'm gonna go back.
I'm going back.
I lacked the foresight to predict his betrayal.
I shall take responsibility for this failure and stop him here.
I don't know where Hongai is.
I don't know.
Our eastern front is being overwhelmed.
We should send the rear guard to bolster our defenses there.
There's a lot of stuff happening.
Please.
You can't just tell me to go there and then...
Please, I have to deal with so much.
I assure you, at this point, there is nothing left to say.
Indeed, our blades shall do the talking.
Oh my god.
Wait, this is bad.
Are you ready to face me?
Almost at all limits.
Oh my god!
Oh no!
I believe.
I claim another victory in the name of our brother.
What do you mean you claimed it?
The enemy has breached the altar room.
Please, eliminate them at once.
Oh my god!
I have to do so much!
I'm one!
Time to end this!
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
What doing, what, what, what!
What, what, what?
What!
What...
I'm coming back, I'm coming back!
Please, just leave them, please.
Where, where, where, where?
Oh my god!
Oh my god, how do I... How do I win this?
Oh my god, wait!
Wait, wait, I went the wrong way!
Get out, get out, get out, get out!
Have you sensed any changes in the winds yet?
No!
If you sense a change while nearby, you needn't inform me.
Simply light the fire on the altar yourself.
The road ahead is thorny, but walk it we shall.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Lupin, nooooo!
No way.
I'm gonna lose?
I can't tell!
But south-south forces still have the edge.
It's like... Did the wind change?
I can't tell!
I challenge you to battle.
Here we go.
Got to spare yourself.
My dream... No!
He's dead!
I just... I just... I just made it to the altar!
Holy shit!
Okay.
This is a lot more difficult.
This... Let me eat my lasagna.
That was... That was a lot more difficult than I expected.
I need to eat my lasagna.
What the fuck?
Like, what do I do?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Let the first wave come to you.
We'll do that next time.
Okay.
I'm gonna not pick up Guan... I'm gonna restart the battle.
And then not pick up Guan Yin.
Because apparently, Guan Yin will defend the altar.
And like, I trust him more than John Pei.
Okay.
We're gonna... Okay.
Actually, do we keep Guan Yin with us?
Or... get someone else?
Guys, do we keep Guan Yin with us?
I don't know.
We should keep him with us.
Because he does kill people faster.
Go solo?
But like...
They're so strong!
Okay.
We quit the battle.
And then... we do this.
It's easier to do solo?
Okay.
We'll do... we'll try solo.
We'll try solo then.
Alright.
It's time to go solo.
I'm solo.
Yeah, I'm gonna change weapons.
I only was using it because it was stronger.
But I don't think it's as good.
Alright.
We've done all that...
I'm not like... I don't like it as much.
Not gonna lie.
I feel like...
Maybe I'll use the Cobalt Storm.
Maybe I'll do... I'll be more... feel better with this.
We must support each other and fight our way through.
Okay.
I'll let them come to me.
Show them your metal.
This battle... is ours for the taking.
For the sake of our inalienable ambitions.
But I'll kill them and then I'll ignore Sha Hu Yun.
I'll ignore Sha Hu Yun.
And I'll go to the other side.
Yes!
They come down first!
All of my plans depend on this decisive battle.
Each and every one of you must carry out your duties.
So that we may claim a crushing victory.
First, we shall...
Send...
Defense now!
All units...
Can I actually like redo my...
Oh, I can't.
I was gonna say...
Can I like fix my inventory?
Apparently I can't.
That's not good.
Alright.
Let's see.
Strengthen your guard!
Repel the hostile offensive!
This one and then kill at least one or two and then we'll go to the other side.
Our chance of victory remains.
Hold formation.
Is this...
These guys are first.
Stay on the defensive.
Okay, it comes to me.
Open up, open up, open up, open up.
We will not let anyone through.
Come out with all you have.
We must not let them reach land.
Lose arrows at will with all my might.
Boom!
Oh my god, that was fast.
Alright.
Nice.
I can't believe this.
The enemy officer has been defeated.
I could test my skills against you.
Oh dude.
Oh no, that's bad.
Oh nice.
I dodged it in time.
And I actually used it anyway.
Nice.
And then...
I leave!
The enemy officer has been defeated.
Alright, goodbye!
We can't let them take this position.
I must hold it.
I'm coming over!
Don't worry!
Oh my god, they're so...
Far!
Oh my god, they're so far!
Oh my god!
I'm coming over!
Oh my god, they're so far!
Oh my god, I'm riding the horse as fast as I can!
Please!
Why aren't you faster?!
Oh my god.
Across the entire map too!
I don't... I'm actually... I'm actually riding the horse as fast as I can!
To the other side!
There's, like, no other way I can go faster!
Like, I don't understand what they want from me.
There's no other way for me to be faster.
Oh my god.
I think this is the worst part.
Like, it's, like, actually so hard.
Okay, hello.
Hello.
You must maintain a constant barrage of arrows.
I...
Keep the enemy reinforcements at bay to protect our archers.
There's no way!
Take this!
We may not be able to make it through this.
There's no way!
Things don't look too good.
I can't...
They took me off!
I have to restart!
You are...
I can't...
EXCUSE ME!
There's no way!
I'm- I'm restarting.
I can't find the ladder.
He knocked me into the...
There's no way!
Is this where I'm in the water?
Is this where- I'm so sad!
I- I'm actually so sad!
Wait, you're right.
Okay, let me, um, do my skills real quick.
I'm so sad that happened.
I can't believe- I can't believe I was sent to the fucking Shadow Realm.
Um...
That's actually bullshit.
Show them your metal!
This battle is ours for the taking!
For the sake of our inalienable ambitions.
We must take command of this battle!
Oh, I finished my lasagna.
I was so fucking hungry.
I actually finished it already.
Yeah!
Hmph!
All of my- I told you!
I was hungry!
All units!
Strengthen your guard!
Repel the hostile offensive!
As long as we hold firm, our chance of victory remains.
Hold formation, and stay on the defensive.
Get over here!
There's still some remaining lasagna sauce.
Wait, what is that?
Anyway, the dragon tail spike.
Oh, wait, that's a good move.
Okay.
I'm so, so sad that happened.
I can't believe that happened.
I can't believe it.
We will not let anyone through.
That's all you have.
We must not let them reach land.
Noose arrows at will!
Let's go.
Easy.
Hit.
Jesus Christ.
I could test my skills against you!
Oh my God!
Get out!
You're not part of this!
Oh my, this takes so much heart longer.
This is actually taking so much longer because of the harder boss.
Oh my God.
I have to go back.
Let's go.
I'm sorry.
Wait, actually, I can maybe kill one more guy.
I can maybe kill one more.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
I could kill him, maybe.
Time to act.
Everything is going well so far.
I'd say it's just about time to land another boom.
Alright.
Okay.
Goodbye!
Goodbye.
Damn.
When did they get behind us?
Oh my God.
This just became a lot more complicated.
Wait.
Okay.
This is bad.
If someone doesn't get here fast, we're done for.
Oh my God, I'm trying my best.
Okay, I'll kill these guys too.
Oh, wait.
No, no, no.
I can't.
I can't afford to.
I'm sorry.
I have to go.
No!
We must maintain a barrage of arrows.
Keep the enemy reinforcements at bay.
Okay, but I'll kill him first.
I'll kill him.
I'll kill him first.
This is more important.
Oh, fuck.
We may not be able to make it through this.
Oh my God, this is so strong.
If we lose this one, I'm gonna go and equip like strong items and stuff.
So I can be stronger in this fight.
So I can kill people faster at least.
Because things are not okay.
Things are not okay right now.
They're too strong.
I must retreat and rethink my plans.
Oh my God, they made this fight so much harder than the previous installations.
This fight is actually crazy hard.
Yes, please.
Please let me duel you.
This makes it easier.
Let me duel you.
Oh, thank God.
I'm so happy.
He let me duel him.
It makes this so much easier.
One less guy I have to worry about.
Let's go.
Get out of here.
Oh, shit.
Yo, my perfect run.
Hit.
No.
Oh my God.
That's cheating.
No, it's fine.
It's fine.
With all my might.
No.
Come on.
Nice.
We're so close.
Yes.
Oh, thank God.
Thank God.
We made it.
It's time.
It's been defeated.
I'm...
He's...
Heading...
Let's go.
The altar.
Why?
That white fan.
His appearance.
That must be the sleeping dragon.
Chugen Leong.
As long as he lives, he is sure to be a thorn in our side.
The enemy officer.
March forward.
Got this.
Okay, I'll kill two more.
And then I'll go to the other side.
Let's go.
This is in line with my predictions.
Okay.
Get him out.
What the heck took you so long?
All right.
Just kidding.
We're going to the other side.
Has been defeated.
Come.
And face me.
Who's the other guy?
Oh, my God.
It's him.
Those things aren't going my way today.
Maybe next time.
This is tough.
No matter how you slice it.
Don't worry, Dracos.
Go do your thing.
The outcome of this encounter.
Oh, no.
Okay.
Sorry.
I have to leave now.
I leave.
I gotta leave now.
I have to go to the other side.
Oh, my God.
You guys got this, right?
I gotta leave.
They're complaining.
We must distract the enemy while carrying out the most vital part of the plan.
I know this will be hard.
But...
Oh, my God.
I am counting on you all.
I'm fucking riding the horse as fast as I can.
We've losing this battle.
Guard him with your lives.
Jesus Christ.
You guys.
We've lost our archers in the east.
What?
The enemy's offensive will go on unimpededly.
How?
How do we lose?
I've left for one second.
How is our chance to press the attack and take victory for ourselves?
How do we lose?
What?
I did not...
Who is ours for the enemy officer...
...has been defeated.
How do we lose?
I haven't already.
How?
Still...
It's not yet time.
I don't understand.
Oh my god.
I know, I went back to save Jukotlen!
I don't understand how we lost them already!
Oh my god!
I can't!
Alright, we're gonna... Alright guys, we're gonna do a level...
Okay, guys, we need to... We need to... We gotta... Grind a little.
We're too strong.
Lucas, thank you for the 50 gifted chips!
Thank you, thank you!
We got our... We may or may not have got our asses kicked.
So I'm gonna... I'm gonna level it up.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna... I'm gonna find some level up areas.
I do not care who moves this place.
Thank you so much for the 50 gifted chips!
Thank you, thank you!
I don't know if I like this.
I'll try it.
Maybe I'll try it.
This... The thing is, this doesn't kill as fast.
So like... What is the strongest weapon?
Guys, what is the strongest weapon in this game?
Like, in terms of like play style.
Yeah, there's consumables that make me stronger.
Howlbred?
Okay, but like... We don't have that.
We don't... What is the strongest weapons that I have right now?
That... That I... Currently own?
Which is the best?
Crescent blade?
Okay, I'll try Crescent blade.
So Lord Southside... Spear?
I mean, the spear has been like... Good for me for a while.
I'll try the spear.
Alright.
We'll do this.
We... We need to grind ourselves a little bit.
I realize that... We are... We might be a little fucked right now.
We might... We may or may not... Be a little fucked at the moment.
Everyone wait.
I must assess the situation.
Hey!
Tajo turns our knee.
Let's move!
Alright.
Take that!
Now!
Take this!
Take that!
Time to ask.
Okay.
Let's...
Grind spirit proficiency to level 8.
One... Okay.
To get the... Dragon Flash?
Okay.
But not ha... I don't have that yet, right?
I don't know if I do.
Let's go.
Okay.
We might try and grind the objectives too at this point.
At this point, we might actually have to.
We... We need as much... As much as we can get.
Okay.
What is the battle hearts first?
Wait.
Open the door.
Open.
Alright.
Yeah.
We... We paid to win a lot of stuff.
So, like...
I think it's time that... We actually have to...
We actually have to, you know...
Level up some stuff.
That's a hundred.
Okay.
Open the door.
I'm ready.
I'm fucking ready.
I'm going in by myself.
That's right!
Charge!
It's only me!
Wait.
Why is everybody charging without me?
Guys.
I'm right here.
Why is...
Guys.
I'm right here.
Why are you guys...
Guys.
I'm right... Guys.
Oh, shit.
There he is.
Oh, my God.
Thousand people right off the...
You know what else I could do?
I could do that again.
You know what I could also do again?
This.
I...
Jesus.
All right.
Nice.
Where are the chariots, by the way?
Oh.
Oh, they're all the way over there.
I was like, don't worry.
I got this.
And I...
I was ready.
Apparently, the chariots were all...
Don't worry.
Boom.
Jesus.
All right.
Two thousand.
You are a true warrior of the three kingdoms.
There we go.
There you go, guys.
That should be enough.
That should be a lot of XP, right?
And there's 2K.
All right.
You know what it's time to do?
Boom.
Here we...
Here we go again.
All right.
Again?
Okay.
What do I have to do here?
Oh, prevent his musu?
Where is it?
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
I don't think I can prevent that, though.
Like...
Unless...
Boom!
He...
Guys, he dodged it.
Guys, he...
He may or may not have dodged my...
My game crashed!
Guys, we're not finishing this game today.
That broke my... that... that... I think... I think... I think that was the sign that maybe today was not the day when we finished Dynasty Warriors.
And I think... I think that... that was the sign.
And that... I forgot that I'm not strong enough.
Because I have... because I need a practice for tomorrow.
Because I don't... I don't think we're finishing Dynasty Warriors.
Today.
I...
That... that... that was the sign for me.
I honestly... that... that was... that was the game telling me it's over.
That... that was the mess of me.
The game literally told me... that... I had to stop.
I...
Guys tell you to go here.
Looking forward to the next part.
Good luck in practice.
Solid Snake.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So glad I made it your time for the beginning of the playthrough.
Truths.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Deon.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This is really funny.
But it's also technique.
Very EXP efficient to nuke a large force like you're doing.
And also the grind of spirit to the...
Guys...
This was my side.
That was like...
A message from the heavens.
Like...
Oh my God.
I don't think I'm strong enough right now.
After...
My entire motivation...
Was gone after that.
Alright.
Next week...
We will...
Finish...
We will finish...
Dynasty Warriors...
We will...
Finish...
Dynasty Warriors...
Next week.
It might have been a little clickbait today.
I did not expect...
The...
I did not expect the battle...
To be...
Oh my God.
That difficult.
Alright guys.
One more YouTube stream.
Anyway guys.
I'm gonna call it...
I have to practice...
Today.
As always...
Everybody...
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around...
To get that blood flowing.
And if you...
Stay up for me...
Get to bed.
Cause...
You deserve it.
I might do like...
I might just do the mini stuff off stream.
Just cause like...
Like...
I don't wanna...
Spend...
The last stream...
Next week.
To like...
Do the whole grind again.
So like...
I might do that off...
I'm just gonna...
Do the mini areas.
Grind that off stream.
Don't worry.
I'll make sure I don't talk to anybody.
I'm just...
Gonna grind the weapons.
Gonna make sure the weapons...
Were strong enough.
And that I'm leveling up enough.
Hey guys.
I'll see you guys...
Tomorrow.
As...
Bye everyone.
Did I do my...
As always everybody stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around.
To get that blood flowing.
If you stay up for me...
Head to bed.
Cause...
You deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye.
Bye guys.